CHECKING TO SEE THAT YOU HAVE
LIKE AN ACTION. CORRECTLY. YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
TO EVERYONE AND WELCOME TO THIS
JOINT OVERSIGHT HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY INSURANCE COMMITTEE
AND THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE. DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
WERE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER AND THROUGHOUT THIS
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE. IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. BUT ALSO REQUIRING THAT
MASKS BE WORN PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR IN ANY OF OUR VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITES. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE. FOR THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM. WHEN
WE REACH THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION THE AGENDA I WOULD ASK
THAT ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE IN THE ROOM PLEASE
APPROACH THE MIKE ONE PERSON AT
A TIME PLEASE MAINTAIN PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AS YOU MOVE AROUND
THE ROOM- I WOULD ASK THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
PROVIDING YOUR COMMENTS OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. FOR DIAL
IN PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR PUBLIC COM. COMMENT
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. 877-692-8957 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THESE NUMBERS ON THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AND ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. THE OPERATOR ON THE
LINE WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE
QUEUE TO PROVIDE YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENTS. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. NO MOVING ON TO THE
HEARING ITSELF TO ALLOW AS MUCH
TIME AS POSSIBLE FOR QUESTIONS
AND ANSWERS. I'LL KEEP MY
OPENING REMARKS BRIEF. TODAY
WE'LL BE DISCUSSING THE
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
IDENTIFIED BY THE STATE AUDITOR
AND TO AUDIT REPORTS. AS THE
ART CONVEYED THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT WAS
UNPREPARED. THE PANDEMIC COST
HISTORIC LEVELS OF CLAIMS BUT
NOW ALMOST A YEAR LATER THE
DEPARTMENT IS STILL UNPREPARED.
UNPREPARED FOR PHONE CALLS
UNPREPARED FOR THE NUMBER OF
CLAIMS UNPREPARED FOR THE RE
IDENTIFICATION PROCESS
UNPREPARED TO PREVENT FRAUD AND
UNPREPARED TO HANDLE THOSE WHO
MAY BE VICTIMS OF IDENTITY
THEFT. IT'S NO SECRET THAT ARE
CONSTITUENCIES AND OUR CITIZENS
ARE SUFFERING. THERE ARE UNABLE
TO ADDRESS THIS EDT PROBLEM OF
THEIR E. D. D. PROBLEMS AND
CHALLENGES IN A TIMELY MANNER.
UNABLE TO RECEIVE BENEFITS AND
UNABLE TO NAVIGATE THE
DEPARTMENT SYSTEM AND EVER
CHANGING GUIDELINES. GENERALLY
OUR LOCAL STAFFS IN OUR LOCAL
DISTRICT OFFICES- HAVE HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS OF STORIES OF THE
CHALLENGES AND PROBLEMS THAT
EXIST. WHAT WE HEAR FREQUENTLY
IS IT'S EITHER GET BENEFITS OUT%
FAST OR PREVENT FRAUD WE HEAR
THAT FROM THE EDT WHY IS IT ONE
OR THE OTHER WHY CAN'T WE HAVE
BOTH OUR CONSTITUENTS DESERVE
MEMBER BETTER EXCUSE ME-
SENATOR LAYERED IS THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE JOINT. AUDIT
COMMITTEE AND I UNDERSTAND HE'S
ON A TIGHT SCHEDULE SO AT THIS
POINT I'LL ASK SENATOR LAYER
LAYER IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ED BOTH MISTER CHAIRS- I REALLY
APPRECIATED TO AND I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR THE FACT THAT I'M
SHARING A HEARING
SIMULTANEOUSLY AND SO I WILL
LEAVE A WHEN THIS IS DONE I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE JOINT HEARING OF
THE- JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE IN THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE I WAS
BRIEFED BY THE STATE AUDITOR ON
BOTH PIECES OF THE SORT. OF THE
AUDIT THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US ON
THE PERFORMANCE OF CALIFORNIA'S
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT IS SIMPLY THERE'S NO
OTHER WAY TO DESCRIBE IT
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IS A
PRIMARY LIFELINE GOVERNMENT CAN
WROTE TO PEOPLE WHEN LIFE COMES
DOWN HARD ON THEM IT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN EATING AND
STARVING. AS I WAS SWORN INTO
THIS OFFICE IN DECEMBER I WAS
KEENLY AWARE OF THE MANY MANY
CONCERNS I'VE HEARD FROM PEOPLE
ON THE CENTRAL COAST AND FROM
MEDIA REPORTS THAT ALL WAS NOT
RIGHT WITH THIS CRUCIAL
LIFELINE. PROGRAM THEN I BEGIN
TO HEAR THE RULES. OF FROM
MARKETS TO. AS THEY IN THE DISK
OFF. R. Y. WOMAN WITH THE PH IS
LIVING HER CAR BECAUSE PAYMENTS
BEEN. CLOSER ABOUT BE REAP. AND
SHE'S LOCKED OUT OF A POST
OFFICE BOX. ANOTHER IS DESK FOR
A TWO YEARS WORTH OF PAYMENTS
SO SHE CAN KEEP A ROOF OVER
HER. AND HER TODDLER'S HEAD.
WHAT'S WORSE IS THAT OUR PHONE
MIGHT GET CUT OFF. WHICH MEANS
SHE CAN'T CHECK TO SEE IF THE
DOZENS OF EMAILS AND CALLS
SHE'S MADE TO D. D. D. HAVE
BEEN RETURNED. THERE'S ANOTHER
CONSTITUENT WHO IS OWED NEARLY
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
THEN ANOTHER WHO IS TRYING TO
PAY THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS BACK
TO THE E. D. D. AND A MONTH
LATER HIS CHECK TO THEM HASN'T
CLEARED. THESE ANECDOTES JUST
SCRATCHED THE SURFACE I'M SURE
THAT EVERY MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE. HAS SIMILAR STORIES.
THE NUMBER OF UNPAID CLAIMS.
UNFAIRLY DENIED CLAIMS FROZEN
ACCOUNTS AND FRAUDULENT
ACCOUNTS IS STUNNING. WHAT WENT
WRONG AND HOW DO WE FIX IT. I
SINCERELY HOPE THAT THE EIGHTY
DETECTS THE HARD EVERY
RECOMMENDATION WITHIN THE STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT. MAKE NO
MISTAKE YOU ARE THE PEOPLE THE
LAST LINE OF DEFENSE AGAINST
HOMELESSNESS AND HUNGER THAT'S
A SACRED DUTY YOU MUST NEVER
LOSE SIGHT OF. AS A LEGISLATOR
I KNOW LIKE MY COLLEAGUES I
WILL BE CLOSELY SCRUTINIZING
THIS REPORT FOR LEGISLATIVE
FIXES. THERE ARE MANY THINGS TO
CONSIDER PARTICULARLY AROUND
THE RAMPANT FRAUD IN THE
FAILURES IN THE SYSTEM. THAT IT
IS COST. AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE
TRYING TO MAKE THIS ABOUT THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION. THE
ORDER DID AN AUDIT TEN YEARS
AGO ABOUT THE SAME ISSUES. THE
ORDER WAS BASED IN THE ACTIONS
OF THE ADMINISTRATION BEFORE
LAST. BUT WAS COMPLETED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION. SO THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT HAS SPANNED THE
ADMINISTRATIONS OF THREE
GOVERNORS. OF BOTH PARTIES BUT
IT IS UP TO US NOW TO MAKE SURE
THESE PROBLEMS ARE DRESSED- SO
I HOPE THAT EDT EXECUTIVE TEAM
THEIR STAFF IN THE STATE
ADMINISTRATION. ALL REDOUBLE.
THEIR FOCUS ON JUST TRYING TO
CLEAN UP THIS CRISIS. THEY CAN
PUT IN PLACE TO STRUCTURE
CULTURE DDD. OF THAT CAN DO
THAT AND DO IT FOR BETTER- INTO
THE FUTURE BECAUSE FRANKLY THIS
IS UNACCEPTABLE. SO I
APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO GO OUT
OF ORDER APOLOGIZE. FOR HAVING
TO LEAVE HERE. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED- NOW WILL TURN
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUDY SALAS
IS THE CHAIR THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE- I
WANT TO POINT OUT TO ALL THE
MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE BOTH
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND SENATORS
THERE WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITY.
FOR COMMENTS. AND QUESTIONS
FOLLOWING EACH OF THE PANELS
THAT WE HAVE TODAY. AND OF
COURSE THE FIRST PANEL WILL BE
THE STATE AUDITOR HERSELF IN
HER STAFF SO THEY'LL BE MANY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE MEMBERS
TO ASK QUESTIONS AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THE HEARING. MISTER
SALAS GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AND
THANKS AND ROULERS- FOR JOINING
US THIS MORNING WE APPRECIATE-
THE VICE CHAIRMAN HERE AS WELL-
FOR TODAY'S JOINT HEARING WITH
THE- WITH THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE AND THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE TO
DISCUSS TWO IMPORTANT A LOT OF
REPORTS RELEASED JUST LAST
WEEK- YOU AND I. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DALY ALONG WITH THIRTY
EIGHT OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE REQUESTED THE STATE
AUDITOR CONDUCT AUDIT WORK BACK
AT THE BEGINNING OF SEPTEMBER.
OUT OF CONCERN FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS WERE HAVING
DIFFICULTY OBTAINING THEIR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. WE HAD
CONCERNS AT THAT TIME YOU KNOW
SIX MONTHS AFTER THE PANDEMIC.
AND ECONOMIC DOWNTURN BEGAN.
ABOUT EDIE'S ABILITY TO
PROPERLY DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY
ISSUE PAYMENTS AND PROVIDE
BASIC CUSTOMER SERVICE. AT THE
TIME THE EXTENT OF THE FRAUD
ASSOCIATED WITH UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS WAS JUST STARTING TO
COME TO LIGHT. WE ALL WANT DVD
TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND HOPE TO
HEAR REASONS TODAY TO BELIEVE
THAT EDS TURNED A CORNER. AND
CALIFORNIANS ARE RECEIVING THE
BENEFITS AND SERVICES THEY
DESERVE AND THE PUBLIC FUNDS
ARE BEING PROTECTED. NOW
REPORTS. RELEASED LAST WEEK
CERTAINLY IDENTIFIED MANY
SERIOUS ISSUES AND GIVE US
GREAT CONCERN. THE STATE
AUDITOR IDENTIFIED MANY
DEFICIENCIES RELATED TO ED'S
ADMINISTRATION OF UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. LARGE REPORTS
CONCLUSIONS WERE DISTURBING.
THE EXTENT OF THESE
DEFICIENCIES COULD HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY MINIMIZE HAD
THERE BEEN SOME ADVANCE
PLANNING AND BETTER
PREPARATION. THE REPORT FOUND
THAT EDIE WAS WHOLLY UNPREPARED
FOR AN ECONOMIC RECESSION WHICH
LEFT SO MANY CALIFORNIANS
WAITING WEEKS. OR MONTHS FOR
THEIR BENEFITS WHILE
DESPERATELY TRYING TO CALL
PHONE SYSTEM MORE LESS THAN 1%
OF CALLS WERE BEING ANSWERED.
WELL I RECOGNIZE THE SURGEON
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS WAS
UNPRECEDENTED AS DEPARTMENT
THAT OVERSEES CALIFORNIA'S
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM
EDT SHOULD BE WELL AWARE THAT
RECESSIONS ARE CYCLICAL.
OCCURRING REGULARLY AND THAT
PLANNING TO INCREASE STAFFING
HANDLE INCREASED WORKLOADS AND
SERVICE CALIFORNIANS SEEKING
THEIR BENEFITS DURING ECONOMIC
DOWNTURNS. IS A NECESSITY IN
FACT. SOME OF THE DEFICIENCIES
WERE HIGHLIGHTED BY THE AUDITOR
AFTER THE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT RECESSION. EDT WAS ALSO
CLEARLY. TO GUARD AGAINST FRAUD
WHICH RESULTED IN AT LEAST TEN
POINT FOUR BILLION AND
FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS GOING TO
CLAIMANTS WITH UNCONFIRMED
IDENTITIES INCLUDING%
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT RECENTLY.
THE RELEASE FIGURES FOR MEDIA
IDENTIFIED AN ADDITIONAL
NINETEEN POINT FIVE BILLION AND
POTENTIALLY FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR BUT. I
BELIEVE CALIFORNIANS ARE
FRUSTRATED THEY'RE INFURIATED
THEY'RE FED UP THEY WANT A
SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR THEM AND
I'M HOPING TODAY'S HEARING WILL
NOT ONLY PROVIDE CLARITY BUT A
ROAD MAP FOR HOW THESE ISSUES
ARE ADDRESSED AND FIXED MOVING
FORWARD AND WITH THAT. I'D
APPRECIATE THAT'S MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU MR THANK YOU
MISTER SALAS. AND- YOU
MENTIONED A ROAD MAP AND- THIS
IS A PERFECT- SEGUE TO. THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE GOVERNMENT
THAT HAS LAID OUT A ROADMAP FOR
US. AND FOR EDT- THAT IS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR. AND
OUR NEXT PRESENTATION IS FROM.
ELAINE HOWELL THE STATE AUDITOR
AND ONE OF HER STAFF MEMBERS
BOB HARRIS. MISAO ARE YOU READY.
YES SIR THANK YOU MISTER DALY
BEAUTIFUL GO AHEAD PLEASE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- CHAIR SALAS AND
DALY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
INVITING US TO PRESENT THE
RESULTS OF THE AUDIT REPORTS
THAT WE ISSUED LAST WEEK ON THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT- BOB HARRIS IS
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ONCE WE GET TO THE Q. ONE DAY
I'M GOING TO STEP THROUGH IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME I WILL
STEP THROUGH THE KEY FINDINGS
THAT WE HAVE IN EACH OF THE TWO
REPORTS. AND FOCUSED- PRIMARILY
ON THE LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS- I KNOW MY
OFFICE MADE IT SOME DOCUMENTS
TO THE COMMITTEE- FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE GOING TO FOLLOW
ALONG WITH THESE DOCUMENTS I'M
JUST GOING TO GO OVER THE FIRST
PAGE THERE'S THREE DOCUMENTS.
THE FIRST. ONE- EIGHT MORE
REFERRING TO. IT TIES TO THE
FIRST THREE THAT WE IS LAST
TUESDAY. AND REALLY FOCUSED ON
PROCESS- THE ABILITY TO. CLAIMS
THE BILL TO. OUR CALLS COMING
IN AN IN PRAISE COMING IN FROM
CLAIMANTS ARE THROUGH THEIR
CALL CENTER. AND- EDIE'S. PROB
AND BEING ABLE TO DO THOSE
THINGS AND REASONS WHY AND AS
MISTER SALAS INDICATED AND
CERTAINLY SENATOR ARE LAYERED
INDICATED IN MY OFFICE ISSUED A
REPORT BACK IN MARCH OF TWENTY
ELEVEN LOOKING AT THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. ITS ABILITY TO
PROCESS CLAIMS IT'S CALL CENTER
PERFORMANCE AND WE IDENTIFIED
YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANT
DEFICIENCIES BACK IN AND TWENTY
TWENTY ELEVEN WHEN WE ISSUED A
REPORT AND AGAIN- THAT WAS. YOU
KNOW SUBSEQUENT TO THE
RECESSION AND R. ETT HAD YOU
KNOW- HEADS AS SURGEON. CLAIMS
DURING THE RECESSION- AND HAD
STRUGGLED TO DEAL WITH THAT
CERTAINLY THE PANDEMIC IS
MAGNIFIED EVEN MORE AS FAR AS
THE SIZE OF THE SERBS THAT
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCED- THIS
LAST YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
CONTINUES TO. SUFFER FROM HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES. BUT AS AS
MISTER SALAS INDICATED ONE OF
FIRST KEY ISSUES WE IDENTIFIED
IN THE REPORT IS THAT EDT WAS
NOT PREPARED ARE THEY SHOULD
HAVE THAT INSTITUTED SOME
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES BASED ON
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS WE
MADE BACK IN TWENTY ELEVEN ALSO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAD PUT.
EDT AND THAT CATEGORY
CONSIDERED HIGH RISK WHICH
MEANS THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO MEET
THE EXPECTATIONS OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS FOR THE NUMBER
OF CLAIMS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
SHOULD PROCESS. AND GET
PAYMENTS OUT WITHIN TWO TO
THREE WEEKS THEY WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY BELOW THE
EXPECTATIONS BACK IN THOSE
DAYS- THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WAS EXPECTING EDT TO IMPROVE WE
MADE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS EDT-
AND CLEARLY THEY THEY CONTINUE
TO STRUGGLE AND THE ISSUES THAT
THEY HAVE THAT HAVE. TO
CERTAINLY WERE EXACERBATED THIS
OP PANDEMIC UNFORTUNATELY- SO
ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATINS WE
HAVE AND I'LL GET TO THAT LATER
BUT WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT EDT
NEEDS TO HAVE A RECESSION PLAN
A PLAN FOR- YOU KNOW ONCE WE
GET PAST THIS PANDEMIC THIS
STATE AND COUNTRY WAIT WE DEAL.
WITH RECESSIONS EVERY FIVE TO
SIX YEARS YOU'VE GOT A PLAN FOR
THOSE SIX. ENNEDI WHY NOT FOR
THAT SO THAT WAS THE FIRST KEY
ISSUE AREAS THE FIRST REPORT.
WE ALSO FOCUSED THE CALL. AND I
MEMBERS HAVE HAVE OVER WE CAN
IN REPORT THAT. NOT ONLY DID
THE CALLS- STRONG QUITE A IT
AGAIN DEMIGODS. OR PERFORMANCE
FROM THE PAST- BACK INTO A WE
DID THAT THE CALLS WAS. ONLY
ABLE TO HIM PROBABLY 1560% OF
THE CALLERS THAT WERE COMING
AND WE'RE ABLE TO REACH AN
AGENT. ARE WE WERE SUGGESTING
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
AUTOMATION THERE NEEDS TO BE
IMPROVEMENT THEY NEEDED TO
TRACK WHY PEOPLE ARE CALLING.
ALSO THAT PERHAPS THEY COULD
PUT SOME FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS UP ON THEIR WEBSITE
THEY COULD HAVE PRE RECORDED
MESSAGES AVAILABLE TO CLAIMANTS
CALLING IN. A TO HOPEFULLY
ADDRESSING ISSUES THAT CLIENTS
HAVE WITHOUT THAT PERSON HAVING
TO REACH AN AGENT. WE FOUND THE
SAME SITUATION- WHEN WE
CONDUCTED THIS AUDIT ON THIS
LAST YEAR- THE CALL CENTER
PERFORMANCE WAS DISMAL IT WAS
DOWN TO ONE PERCENT. EVEN AFTER
THE GOVERNOR. BUT THE STRIKE
AND THEY HIRED ADDITIONAL STAFF
THE ONE TRIPLE THE NUMBER OF
STAFF WORKING IN THE CALL
CENTER. THEIR PERFORMANCE
IMPROVED BUT NOT ENOUGH TO
REALLY SERVE CALIFORNIANS WELL.
PART OF THE PROBLEM- SIMILAR TO
ISSUE WE IDENTIFIED BACK IN
TWENTY ELEVEN TRAINING TOOK A
LONG TIME A LOT OF THESE.
AGENTS THAT WERE HIRED TO
ASSIST WITH THE CALL CENTER
THEY WERE THINKING THEY WOULD
NEED NINE TO THIRTEEN MONTHS
THEY TRIED TO STREAMLINE IT
DOWN TO NINE MONTHS THAT'S
STILL A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME. FOR AN INDIVIDUAL GET
TRAINED TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST
CLAIMANTS WHO ARE ARE ARE
TRYING TO GET A CLAIM FILED
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND. WHY THEY
HAVEN'T RECEIVED THEIR BENEFITS
YET. SO SECOND ISSUE AREAS CALL
SO. EDT REALLY HAS CA. TO THEY
ARE NOT MEASURING- YOU KNOW
FIRST KALRA. THAT'S A INDUSTRY
BEST. ARE WE REACH. THE
CLAIMANTS. WENT THEY ARE ABLE
TO REACH AN AGENT AND HOPEFULLY
GET THEIR THEIR QUESTIONS
ANSWERED AND THEIR ISSUE
RESOLVED SO THAT THEIR CLAIM
CAN GET PROCESS AND THEY CAN
GET THEIR FUNDS. ON THEIR
BENEFITS TO THEM. SO THOSE WERE
THE FIRST TO KEY ISSUES- ARE
STRUGGLING TO PROCESS CLAIMS
CONTINUING TO STRUGGLE TO
PROCESS CLAIMS. A LOT OF BDD
SYSTEM- WAS A MANUAL PROCESS.
NEARLY 50% OF THEIR CLAIMS WERE
ENDING UP IN A MANUAL. PROCESS
WHERE THEY'RE HAVING TO VERIFY
IDENTITY DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY
ETCETERA- WITH THE USE OF ID ME
WHICH WAS IMPLEMENTED IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY. TWENTY THAT
AUTOMATION I'VE GOT A LOT
BETTER AND THEIR ABILITY TO
PROCESS CLAIMS INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY. BUT WHAT THEY
ALSO DID IS SUSPENDED CERTAIN-
REQUIREMENTS- THAT ARE TYPICAL
UNDER THE UNEMPLOYMENT PROGRAM.
PART OF THAT. IS BECAUSE OF THE
FEDERAL. DEMI PLEINEMENT
ASSISTANCE. WHICH WAS FORCED
EMPLOYED INDIVIDUAL END OF WHO
WORK. NOT ELIGIBLE FOR ON A- ON
THE DON'T HAVE GOOD. WAGES SO
SOME OF THOSE REQUIREMENTS EDT
WAS ABLE TO SUSPEND- DECIDED TO
SPEND AND NOT ALLOW THEM TO
PROCESS CLAIMS MORE QUICKLY.
BUT THEY STILL CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE TO RESOLVE CERTAIN
ISSUES- THE THIRD ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE OUR LAST ISSUE I'M SORRY
FOR THE ISSUE THAT WE HAVE IN
THE REPORT WORK RELATED TO SOME
DECISIONS THAT THEY MADE TO
SPEED UP CLAIMS AND IT'S THE
BALANCE BETWEEN AS A CHAIRMAN-
MISTER DALY SAID. IS THE
BALANCE BETWEEN TRYING TO
PREVENT AS MUCH FRAUD AS
POSSIBLE. ANNOUNCING THAT WITH
GETTING PAYMENTS OUT TO
CLAIMANTS ONE FIVE EDT DECIDE
TO- THAT THE DIRECTION OF THE A-
TO SPEND. ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS IDENTITY
VERIFICATION- SO THE FIRST
ISSUE WAS RELATED TO
ELIGIBILITY WHERE THEY
SUSPENDED THE ELIGIBILITY AND
NOW THEY'VE DETERMINED THAT.
BASED ON- US DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR LEADING EDT NOW WE'RE
DIRECTING EDT IN DECEMBER YOU
CAN'T SUSPEND ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS YOU HAVE TO GO
BACK NOW AND REASSESS ALL OF
THOSE CLAIMS THAT YOU SUSPEND
IT AND THERE'S OVER TWELVE
MILLION DETERMINATION
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION
ISSUES HI TO ABOUT TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION CLAIMANTS ARE THAT
EDT WILL NOW IN ADDITION TO ITS
REGULAR WORKLOAD HAVE TO GO
BACK AND DETERMINE WHETHER
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WERE ACTUALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR BENEFITS AND IN
SOME CASES THOSE INDIVIDUALS
MAY HAVE TO PAY. OUR BENEFITS
BACK WITH STATE CALIFORNIA MAY
HAVE TO TRY TO RECRUIT BENEFITS
SIMILAR SITUATION UNDER
TRADITIONAL UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AN UNEMPLOYED
INDIVIDUAL HAS TO CERTIFY.
EVERY TWO WEEKS. CHANYU THEY
REMAIN ELLA THERE THEY'RE A AND
ABLE TO ABLE AND AVAIL TO WERE.
THERE SO MANY NO SIR. EVERY TWO
WEEKS- THAT WAS ALSO. NOW FOR
ABOUT EIGHT WEEK WINDOW EARLY
IN THE PANDEMIC. MARCH TWO
EARLY MAY AGAIN THE US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR BECAME
AWARE AND SAID YOU CAN'T DO
THAT YOU NEED TO REINSTATE THE
REQUIREMENT TO SUBMIT THOSE
CERTIFICATIONS. JUSTIN THAT
EIGHT WEEK PERIOD- ABOUT ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION CLAIMANTS
OUR AFFECTED SO THAT'S
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD NOW THAT
EDT IS GOING TO HAVE TO GO BACK
AND I KNOW THEY'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF DOING THAT.
REQUIRING THESE INDIVIDUALS- TO
NOW SUBMIT THAT CERTIFICATION
ON THAT BY WEEKLY
CERTIFICATION- THAT THEY'VE
BEEN SEEKING WORK AND THEY'RE
ABLE AND AVAILABLE FOR WORK SO
THEY MADE TO WISH TO DECISIONS
THERE. I'M TRYING TO GET
PAYMENT OUT TO CLIENTS BUT YOU
ALSO HAVE AN ISSUE NOW WHERE
YOU'VE GENERATED A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF WORKLOAD THAT EDT NOW
BECAUSE YOU STOL SAID YOU CAN'T
DO THAT YOU CAN'T SUSPEND THOSE
TO. THE ELIGIBILITY AND THE-
THAT THE CERTIFICATIONS ARE YOU
NOW HAVE TO GO BACK AND MKE
SURE THAT THE ALL OF THOSE
FOLKS WERE ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE
BENEFITS THAT THEY RECEIVE. SO
THOSE WERE THE FOUR KEY AREAS.
IN THE FIRST REPORT. I'M SO
THAT IS ATTACHMENT A- THE JUST
THE FIRST PAGE- AND NOW I'M
GONNA GO ON TO. ATTACHMENT BE
R. DOCUMENT BE WHICH IS REPORT
THAT WE IS ON. OF WEEK. AND
THAT ONE- FOCUSED ON FRIDAY. TO
AND JUST. I THAT AGAIN IS MAY
THAT UNFORTUNATELY OPEN UP
STATE FORTIFY. PAYMENTS
POTENTIALLY FOR. CERTAINLY
PAYMENTS- AND WE HAVE THREE OR
FOUR ISSUES IN THAT REPORT I
WANTED TO GO THROUGH. THE FIRST
IS THAT EDT BEINGS TO REACT OR
TO BE PREPARED AGAIN. TO
PREVENT AND DETECT FRAUD. IN
THE MENU I PROGRAM PARTICULARLY
WITH THE AMOUNT OF MONEY COMING
INTO CALIFORNIA TO BENEFIT
THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE WERE
UNEMPLOYED BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. OF THE US DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR. WARRANTY ALL STATES
NOT JUST STATE CALIFORNIA BUT
ALL STATES IN APRIL AND MAY
THAT FRAUD IS GOING TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE YOU'VE GOT TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE. ALL OF YOUR
TOOLS THAT YOU USE
TRADITIONALLY AND EVEN BE MORE
DILIGENT ABOUT TRYING TO
PREVENT FRAUD. IN THE IN THE
SYSTEM- BECAUSE THEY'RE AT THE
POTENTIAL IS EXTREMELY HIGH.
UNFORTUNATELY EDT DIDN'T
ESTABLISH OR TO START WORKING
ON A COUPLE OF THINGS UNTIL
MONTHS INTO THE PANDEMIC. THE
FIRST ONE WE IDENTIFIED WAS
ABOUT FOUR MONTHS IN WHEN THEY
STARTED. STOPPING PAIN AMOUNTS.
SPECIAL STATEMENT THE
SPECIALIST. AND THEN ABOUT SIX
INTO THE US TO OR SEVEN INTO
PANDA- AROUND. IS WHEN THEY SEE-
RAISING IT OR TRY TO CLAMP DOWN
ON. PLANES THAT WHEN OUT TO.
ARAB SO AS YOU SEEN IN THE NEW
NOT MANY OF YOU KIND. HOW HAVE.
YOU EVER. TWENTY THIRTY ON AND
MAILBOX ADDRESS PEOPLE DON'T
HERE NONE OF THE IN IN MY HOW.
AND FOR BENEFITS SO I'M NOT
SURE WHAT'S GOING ON HERE IT
TOOK EIGHTY MONTHS INTO THE PAN.
TO TRY TO PUT MORE. OR THAT.
SAID AND SUSPEND PAYMENTS TO
THE- SUSPECTS AB. WHEN WE
CONDUCTED THE WORK WE ARE FOR
UP AND SELECTED OF THE-
ADDRESSES THAT NEEDED THE HAD I.
THAT WORSE IS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE PAYMENTS
HAD ACTUALLY STOPPED AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE FOUND THIS AS
FAR IN. AS A EARLY DECEMBER
THAT- AT LEAST TWO OR THREE THE
ADDRESSES THAT WE LOOKED AT I'M
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE PAYMENTS
AND ABOUT THIRTY THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS HAVE BEEN PAID
OUT TO ONE PARTICULAR ADDRSS
THAT WAS SUSPICIOUS. SO AGAIN
EIGHTY WAS VERY SLOW TO
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THESE
CONTROLS THAT COULD HAVE
PREVENTED. SOME OF THESE-
FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS FROM GOING
OUT. TO INDIVIDUALS WHO EITHER
STOLE THE IDENTITY OF
CALIFORNIANS- OR WERE JUST ABLE
TO DEFRAUD. THE SYSTEM ON
AROUND. CHU HI. SAID THE WE
ADDRESS IN THE AUTUMN. THE YOU
I'M SURE YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
ONE IS THE- COMMUNITY
COORDINATION WITH BANK OF
AMERICA. IN FREEZING ACCOUNTS-
THERE WAS A LOT OF BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN B. OF A AND ET D.
ETT DIRECTED BE OF VALUE TO
FREEZE THREE HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND ACCOUNTS- THE ISSUE WE
HAVE WITH THAT IS THEY DIDN'T
HAVE A PLAN FOR. FOLLOWING
THROUGH AND ANALYZING EACH OF
THOSE THREE HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND ACCOUNTS TO DETERMINE
HOW MANY OF THOSE ARE ACTUALLY
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS WHERE WE
NEED TO GET THAT ACCOUNT
UNFROZEN SO THAT INDIVIDUAL CAN
ACCESS HIS OR HER BENEFITS- EDT
TO- TO THE POINT AND WHEN WE
ISSUED. AUDIT REPORT DIDN'T
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE LIST TO BE
ABLE TO TRACK HOW MANY ACCOUNTS
WERE FROZEN BECAUSE EDT MADE
SOME DECISIONS TO STOP PAYMENT
ON CERTAIN ACCOUNTS- BE IF THEY
HAD CERTAIN ACCOUNTS THAT WERE
FROZEN AGAIN THERE WAS A LOT OF
BACK AND FORTH. SO EDT WAS NOT
ABLE TO GIVE US A COMPREHENSIVE
LISTING UP HERE ALL THE
ACCOUNTS THAT HAVE BEEN FROZEN
HERE'S THE STATUS OF OUR REVIEW
OF THOSE ACCOUNTS HERE'S OUR
COMMUNICATION WOULD BE A VERY
DIRECTING THEM TO UNFREEZE
CERTAIN ACCOUNTS. SO THAT
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS CAN GET TO
THOSE BENEFITS SO THERE THERE'S
QUITE A BIT AND NEEDS TO BE
DONE WITH RESPECT TO.
COORDINATION COMMUNICATION WITH
BFA ON TO MAKE SURE THAT
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS IN
CALIFORNIA. HAVE ACCESS TO
THEIR BENEFITS. THE SECOND CITY.
IS THE MATCHING WITH. DATA
RELATED IN CARS AND- THERE ARE
UP THIRTY FIVE SO. THAT DO THIS
TYPE OF MATCHING. CERTAINLY
WERE THAT THEY USE. ARE DATED.
HAD NOT BEEN DOING THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING HAVE DONE SOME OF
THE- USING A- TO LOOK AT
OUTLOOK. NINE CARS. DAY BUT
WHEN WE CONDUCTED THIS. EDT
HAVE NOT BEEN THAT PROCESS-
UNTIL THEY IN INTO A CONTRACT
LATE IN TWENTY. I WAS IN A- OF
TWENTY YEAR ALL I'M SURE WHERE
WHEN THE DA'S CAME OUT. WITH
SOME INFORMATION THAT THEY HAD
OBTAINED FROM THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR WHERE LABOR
HAD ACCESS OR- OBTAIN DATA FROM
E. AND DONE SOME OF THE CROSS
MATCHING AND IDENTIFY.
THOUSANDS OF CLAIMS THAT WERE
TIED TO INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED- CALIFORNIA EDT
HAS NOW. ESTIMATED AS WE
EXPLAIN IN THE REPORT ABOUT
EIGHT TEN. DOLLARS HAS BEEN
PAID OUT ON CLAIMS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS INCARCERATED EITHER AT
THE STATE LEVEL OR AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL NOW ET DE NOW DOES HAVE A
CONTRACT. IN PLACE WITH THE
VENDOR TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS-
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION BE
ABLE TO DO THE CROSSMATCH I
KNOW THEY NOW HAVE AN AGREEMENT
WITH CDCR- TO BE ABLE TO GET
INFORMATION WITH RESPECT TO
INDIVIDUALS INCARCERATED IN
STATE FACILITIES- BUT THERE
NEEDS TO BE LONGER TERM
SOLUTIONS TO THAT. AND I'LL
TALK ABOUT THAT IN A MINUTE
WITH WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE HAVE.
AND THEN THE LAST AREA-VERY
QUICKLY IS EDT JUST ITS
OVERALL- EFFORTS TO PREVENT
DETECT FRAUD EDT IS A LARGE
ORGANIZATION IT'S A HUGE STATE
AGENCY IN CALIFORNIA- HAS MAJOR
PROGRAMS YOU AYE PROGRAM IS
SIGNIFICANT D. I. IS A
SIGNIFICANT PROGRAMMING
CALIFORNIA. WITH RESPECT TO THE
U. I. PROGRAM WE WANTED TO LOOK
TO SEE. HOW DO THEY- EXERCISE
THEIR FRAUD PREVENTION AND
DETECTION EFFORTS- AND IS VERY
DISJOINTED THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT UNITS WITHIN EDT THAT
HAVE DIFFERENT RESPONSIBILITIES
WITH RESPECT TO FRIDAY. SUMMER
INTENSIFYING POTENTIAL FRAUD
THEN THEY HAVE TO COMMUNICATE
TO ANOTHER UNIT WITHIN DDD TO
MAKE SURE STOP PAYMENT ON THAT
PARTICULAR CLAIM IS STOP IT'S
NOT. THERE ISN'T AND OVER
ARCHING GROUP OR UNIT WITH ANY
TV THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MAKING SURE ALL THAT
COORDINATION COMMUNICATION
HAPPENS SO WE HAD A GRAPHIC IN
THE REPORT AND IT BUT IT'S-
IT'S VERY COMPLEX I WANNA SAY
CONFUSED. BUT IT'S ALMOST LIKE
A SPAGHETTI THING BECAUSE ALL
THESE DIFFERENT UNITS HAVE
DIFFERENT RESPONSIBILITIES IN
WE'VE GOT ERRORS GOING BACK AND
FORTH AND IT'S JUST. IT'S NOT
VERY WELL COORDINATED VERY
DISJOINTED SO EDT NEEDS TO COME
UP WITH- AN OVERALL STRUCTURE
FOR. WHO WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR MAKING SURE ALL. THAT FRAUD
PREVENTION TO ACTION
COMMUNICATE IS A- AND
APPROPRIATE INEFFICIENT. THE
OTHER IN. NOUS OF THE TOOLS
THAT THEY USE SO IF THEY HAVE A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT TOOLS.
WHAT BEST PRACTICES TELL YOU
IS. LET'S ASSESS THOSE TOOLS
AND DETERMINE HOW MUCH PRIDE
ARE WE ABLE TO PREVENT OR
IDENTIFY- AND THEN YOU KNOW
STOP PAYMENT ON THOSE
PARTICULAR CLAIMS LET'S
CONTINUE TO USE THOSE TOOLS AND
INVEST IN THOSE. IF THERE ARE
OTHER TOOLS THAT AREN'T AS
EFFECTIVE BUT THEY'RE IMPACTING
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS. ARE BY NO
FREEZING THEIR ACCOUNTS ARE
STOPPING PAYMENTS TO THEM. THE
WE NEED TO DO THAT COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS AND DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT. IT MAKES SENSE TO
CONTINUE TO USE THAT TOOL SO
THEY KNEW YOU NEED TO DO THAT
TYPE OF ANALYSIS UP THE TOOLS.
ON TO DETERMINE WHICH ONES ARE
MOST EFFECTIVE. SO THAT'S THE
TWO REPORTS A VERY HIGH LEVEL
WE'RE CERTAINLY WILLING TO GET
INTO MORE DETAIL THE PACKETS WE
PROVIDED TO YOU. PROVIDE MORE
DETAIL BEHIND THOSE KEY ISSUES
WITH OTHER GRAPHICS TO
ILLUSTRATE EACH OF THE ISSUES.
THE NEXT THING I'M GONNA TALK
ABOUT JUST A FEW MORE MINUTES
IS THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WE'VE MADE NOT ONLY TO THE
LEGISLATURE BUT WE HAVE A
VARIETY RECOMMENDATIONS WE MAY
T. D. THE LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS I'D LIKE TO GO
THROUGH THOSE- WHAT WE HAVE.
SUGGESTED THE LEGISLATURE DO IS
REQUIRE EDT TO DEVELOP A
RECESSION PLAN. WHAT TOGETHER
LESSONS LEARNED LEARN FROM WHAT
WE'VE WHAT WE'VE BEEN THROUGH
WITH A PANDEMIC LEARN FROM WHAT
YOU WENT THROUGH DURING THE
LAST RECESSION IN 200-072-0008
TWO THOUSAND NINE. BUT WE'VE
GOT TO HAVE A PLAN IN PLACE
THAT THAT CONSIDERS WE HAVE A
SURGEON CLAIMS HOW ARE WE GOING
TO ADDRESS THAT DO WE NEED TO
MODIFY ANYTHING IN OUR
PROCESSES. WE NEED TO PULL BACK
FROM OTHER AREAS WITH ANY DVD
WE NEED TO HIRE TEMPORARY STAFF
YOU NEED TO HAVE KIND OF A
CONTINGENCY. PLANNING OUGHT TO
BE ABLE TO BE. HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO REACT WHEN YOU
START SEEING A SURGEON CLAIMS
YOU SEE IT WORK WE'RE ENTERING
INTO A RECESSION. OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT UNFORTUNATELY IT'S
GOING TO GO UP WE'RE GONNA HAVE
MORE PEOPLE REACHING OUT TO US
WE'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO. HELP
THOSE FOLKS IN CALIFORNIA SO
THAT WAS A KEY ISSUE AND WHAT
WE'RE SUGGESTING IT ONCE THE
LEGISLATURE HOPEFULLY GETS THAT
IN STATUTE EDT COMPLETES THAT
FIRST RECESSION PLAN WITHIN
TWELVE MONTHS OF THE OF. THE
ENACTMENT. DATE OF THAT
PARTICULAR STATUTE. THAT'S THE
APPROACH AND THEN ADAM. EVERY
THREE YEARS AFTER. THEY'VE
COMPLETED A RECESSION PLAN
LET'S REFRESH THAT PLAN MAKE
SURE. THAT WE HAVE CONSIDERED
EVERYTHING WE NEED TO CONSIDER
WITH RICK AGAIN REGARD STAFFING
PROCESSING CLAIMS ETCETERA.
THREE YEARS MAKES SENSE BECAUSE
AT BASED ON RESEARCH WE SAW.
RECESSIONS OCCUR BETWEEN FIVE
AND SIX YEAR CYCLE SO EDT WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY LOOK AT
THEIR PLAN AT LEAST TWICE. YOU
KNOW IN BETWEEN. TYPICAL CYCLE
FOR RECESSIONS- WE'RE ALSO
ASKING EDT REPORT ON ITS
WEBSITE THE SITUATION WHERE
SOMEBODY'S CLAIMANTS MAYBE NOW
NOTIFIED BY ADD THAT THEY WERE
OVERPAID AND THEY HAVE TO
RECOUP MONEY BACK. OR THOSE
THAT CLAIM AND HAS TO PAY MONEY
BACK TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WE WANT EACH REPORT ON ITS
WEBSITE EVERY SIX MONTHS. THE
AMOUNT OF BENEFIT PAYMENTS AT
THE EVENT THAT A FIGHT THAT
HAVE BEEN OVERPAID HOW MUCH
THAT THE NOTICES HAVE BEEN PUT
OUT HOW MUCH MONEY THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO RECOUP FROM
INDIVIDUALS. THERE IS AN OPTION
FOR EDT IF A CLAIMANT YOU KNOW
SUBMITS- A HARDSHIP- APPEAL
BASICALLY SAYING I CAN'T AFFORD
TO PAY THESE THESE FUNDS BACK
EDT DOES HAVE I THINK A TWO
YEAR WINDOW. TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO THAT PARTICULAR
SITUATION THEY CAN. THEY CAN-
WAVE THAT REPAYMENT BUT AGAIN
THAT'S ANOTHER MANUAL PROCESS
THAT EDT WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH SO THAT'S GOING TO
AFFECT THEIR WORKLOAD IN THE
EVENT THEY THEY NOTIFY PEOPLE
YOU'VE BEEN OVERPAID AND THOSE
FOLKS. YOU KNOW ESSENTIALLY
FILE A HARDSHIP APPEAL THAT I
CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY THESE FUNDS
BACK CAN YOU JUST WAIT WAIT THE
OVERPAYMENT- SIMILAR TO THE
RECESSION. WHICH I EDT NEEDS TO
ALLEGE SO REQUIRE IMMEDIATE PUT
TOGETHER. GROUP OF DIFFERENT
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS- I BEGAN TO IDENTIFY
LESSONS LEARNED. THAT WILL FEED
INTO THEIR ABILITY PUT TOGETHER
THIS RECESSION PLAN- GET A
REPORT DONE BY JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- CERTAINLY-
THERE'S A LOT THAT THEY STILL
NEED TO DO THIS YEAR WE'VE GOT
A LOT OF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
EDT. TO ADDRESS SOME OTHER
CLAIMS PROCESSING ISSUES- THERE
FRAUD ISSUES THEIR CALL CENTER
ISSUES AND WE HAVE SPECIFIC
TIME LINES. IN EACH OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE MADE
TDD SO I DON'T WANT MEMBERS TO
THANK FOR WE'RE GOING TO WAIT
UNTIL JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY
TO. OFFER YOU NEED TO COME UP
WITH SOME SOLUTIONS TO SOME OF
THE PRBLEMS. ANOTHER
LEGISLATIVE RECOMMENDATION- IS
RELATED TO CROSS MATCHING-
INCARCERATION DATA AGAINST A
CLAIMANT INFORMATION CLAIMS
DATA INFORMATION. AND WE'RE
SUGGESTING THE LEGISLATURE
REQUIRE OF THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT TO DO
THAT ALSO REQUIRE. YOU KNOW
STATE ENTITIES LIKE CDC ARE AND
LOCAL ENTITIES TO COOPERATE AND
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION TO EDT
THAT PDP NEEDS TO DO THAT CROSS
MATCHING. THE REASON THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO BE IN STATUTE IS
WHEN EDT OUR WORK TRY TO WORK
IT WORK IT OUT WITH CDCR THIS
LAST YEAR- THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAD TO GIVE SEIZE YOUR
PERMISSION TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO EDT. WE THINK
THE LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE IT
CLEAR IN STATUTE THAT THIS
CROSS MATCHING IS EXPECTED AND
CDCR IS EXPECTED TO SHARE THAT.
THE APPROPRIATE INFORMATION
WITH EDT SO THEY CAN DO THAT
CROSS MATCHING- AND THEN THE
LAST TWO ISSUES ARE RELATED TO
FRAUD. LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS REQUIRING EDT
IT IT'S AND IT'S ANNUAL REPORT
IT SUBMITS AN ANNUAL REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE- ABOUT FRAUD IN
AND HOW MUCH IS DETECTED AT
CETERA. BUT WE WANT EDT TO.
EXPLAIN AND INCLUDING THAT
ANNUAL REPORT ON THE TOOLS THAT
THEY USE THE ANALYSIS OF THOSE
TOOLS WHICH ONES ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE WHICH ONES ARE THEY
GOING TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
WHICH ONES ARE THEY GOING TO.
YOU KNOW NO LONGER USE BECAUSE
THEY'RE MORE OF AN IMPEDIMENT
DOWN THEN AFTER DETERRENT WITH
RESPECT TO FRAUD- HOW TO
MEDITATE IN. GETTING THEIR PAY.
SO THE OTHER THING THAT WE WANT
EDT TO DO AND AGAIN THIS IS IN
THE LEGISLATIVE RECOMMENDATIONS
IS TO REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
ANNUALLY ON THE CROSS MATCHING-
HOW SUCCESSFUL HAS THAT CROSS
MATCHING BAND- HOW MANY CLAIS
THAT THEY IDENTIFIED HOPEFULLY.
AND IN MOST CASES WE WOULD
EXPECT THAT THOSE WOULD BE
BLOCKED PAYMENTS PAYMENTS THAT
NEVER GOT OUT THE DOOR I TO AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN
INCARCERATED AND OBVIOUSLY NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS. I'M SO
THOSE ARE THE KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS THE
LEGISLATURE- AS FAR AS THE
PRIDE AND THE EFFECTIVENESS.
ASSESSING THOSE TOOLS WHAT
WE'RE ASKING THE LEGISLATURE TO
DO IS REQUIRE EDT BY JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND THEN
EVERY TWO YEARS THEREAFTER-
ASSESS THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THOSE TOOLS AND REPORT THAT
INFORMATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
NOW WE SAID JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WHAT WE ALSO HAVE
INCLUDED IN THAT RECOMMENDATION
EDS. THEY HAVE TO GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE AN UPDATE BY JULY
OF THIS YEAR. SO YOU WON'T HAVE
TO WAIT UNTIL JANUARY TO BE
ABLE TO INQUIRE FOR MEDIA OKAY
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO REPORT TO US
IN JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
ON HOW WELL YOU'RE DOING AS FAR
AS DEVELOPING TECHNIQUES TO
ASSESS THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
YOUR FRAUD PREVENTION AND
DETECTION TOOLS- WHERE YOU ADD
ON THAT ARE YOU GOING TO MEET
THAT. JANUARY ON DEADLINE. THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO EDT NOT
GONNA GET INTO SPACE DETAILS
UNLESS MEMBERS ARE ARE
INTERESTED IN WHAT WE DO IS WE
HAVE- RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED
TO CLAIMS PROCESSING- MANY OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS AS I SAID A
FEW MINUTES AGO. INCLUDE
TIMELINES WE HAVE SOME THINGS
WE WANT NEED TO DO IMMEDIATELY
WORKING WITH BFA. DO YOU GET A
COMPREHENSIVE LIST OF- FROZEN
ACCOUNTS START TRACKING THOSE
ACCOUNTS START MONITORING THE
PROGRESS OF ASSESSING THE
VALIDITY OF THOSE ACCOUNTS AND
RELEASING THOSE FUNDS TO
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS. WE HAVE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE'RE
SUGGESTING EDT GET DONE BY
MARCH OF THIS YEAR. OTHERS BY
JUNE OF THIS YEAR- AND THE
INTENSE THERE WAS TO GIVE YOU
THE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME BUT
STILL HAD IT. WITHIN THIS
LEGISLATIVE YEAR- SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND MY OFFICE
CONTINUE TO. CAN CONTINUE TO BE
ENGAGED IN OVERSIGHT. HOPEFULLY
TO ENSURE THAT HE DOES
IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
THAT WE'VE MADE WITH RESPECT TO
CLAIMS PROCESSING THE CALL
CENTER AND CERTAINLY THERE AT
THEIR FRAUD PREVENTION AND
DETECTION EFFORTS. WITH THAT-
GERMAN SALICIN AND- DALY WE'RE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS I HAVE BOB HARRIS
AVAILABLE ALSO YOU'LL SEE
HEATHER KENDRICK'S NAME ON THE
SCREEN- SHE WAS- STAFF COUNSEL
WORKING ON THIS PARTICULAR
PROJECT SO IF THERE'S ANY
ISSUES. ARE RELATED TO YOU
ANYTHING FROM A LEGAL
PERSPECTIVE SHE- SHE ALSO WILL
BE A CALL ON HER TO ASSIST AS
WELL. SO. WITH THAT MEMBERS
I'LL TURN IT BACK TO YOU. THANK
YOU MISS FOR. YOUR OUTSTANDING
SUMMARY OF THE OF THE KEY
ISSUES THAT ARE. THAT WE'RE ALL
FACING HERE- THEN FOR YOUR
EXCELLENT RECOMMENDATIONS- THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE WITH US
IN- THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
ATTENDANCE WE HAVE A
OUTSTANDING ATTENDANCE- THIS
MORNING OF ALL GIVE A CHAIR
SALAS FIRST TRACKING ANY
QUESTIONS HE'D LIKE TO ASK
MISSILE AND THEN WILL. OPEN IT
UP TO THE FLOOR HERE FOR
MEMBERS TO ASK QUESTIONS GO
AHEAD MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER DALY
LANDAU I THINK WE HAVE IN THE
QUEUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AND
SENATOR BACKER AFTERWARDS-
JUST. THREE QUICK QUESTIONS-
MATTER MONITOR THANK YOU AND
YOUR TEAM FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD
WORK THAT YOU GUYS OF THAT I
KNOW WE'VE BEEN COMMUNICATING
OVER THE MONTHS ON THIS BUT
JUST- REALLY QUICKLY- WHAT.
BASED OFF THE WORK THAT YOU AND
YOUR TEAM HAVE DONE WHAT WAS
EDIE'S REASON FOR NOT HAVING A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN IN PLACE.
ESPECIALLY AS YOU OUTLINED.
SOME OF THESE ISSUES HAVE BEEN.
IDENTIFIED FOR OVER A DECADE
BACK IN TWENTY ELEVEN- CAN YOU
GIVE US. WHY YOU DIDN'T HAVE A
PLAN FOR FROZEN THE COUNCIL OR
THE PRISONER FRAUD. OR THE CALL
CENTER ISSUES. THAT WHAT WAS
OUR STATED REASON. I'M GONNA
ASK BOB HERE IS TO HELP IN A
SECOND MY UNDERSTANDING IS AND
WE DISCUSSED THIS IN THE REPORT
BRIEFLY IS EDT WHY IS WORKING
ON A RECESSION PLAN- BUT THEY
HAD WAITED QUITE A LONG TIME I
MEAN THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS I SAID. ACTUALLY
HAD EDT AND THEN AT RISK
CATEGORY BACK IN TWENTY TEN
BECAUSE OF THEIR POOR
PERFORMANCE AND PROCESSING
CLAIMS- AND THEN OF COURSE OUR
AUDIT CAME OUT IN MARCH OF
TWENTY ELEVEN. BUT IT WASN'T
UNTIL TWENTY NINETEEN. EIGHTY
WAS REALLY STARTING TO WORK ON
A RECESSION PLAN I HAVEN'T
COMPLETED IT IN EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY AND THE PANDEMIC HIT NAY
BASICALLY PUT IT ON THE SHELF.
ON WITH RESPECT TO BE OF A-
THAT AGAIN I WILL REFER TO ADD
HAVE BOB HARRIS ASSIST BUT WE
DIDN'T REALLY HEAR SPECIFICS
FROM EDT AS AS YOU ARE AWARE WE
MENTION IN THE REPORT. THERE
WAS A LOT OF BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN THE TWO ENTITIES- AND
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING AT A
HEARING LAST FALL- THE FORMER
DIRECTOR WAS SUGGESTING THAT HE
BE OF A WAS DOING A LOT OF
THIS. AT ITS OWN DISCRETION
THAT WAS NOT NECESSARILY TRUE-
BUT WE CERTAINLY ARE CONCERNED
THAT HE DID NOT HAVE A PLAN. ON
HOW THEY WERE GOING TO ADDRESS
FROZEN ACCOUNTS PARTICULARLY
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS ARE AND TO
TRY TO EXPEDITE THEIR ABILITY
TO RELEASETHOSE ACCOUNTS ON
FREEZE THOSE ACCOUNTS AND
RELEASE THOSE PAYMENTS TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO. DESPERATELY
NEEDED THEM- BUT I'M GONNA ASK.
BOB IF HE HAS ANYTHING ELSE TO
OFFER. SO BAD SURE SALAS CHAIR
DEAL MEMBER THANK YOU NAME'S
BOB HARRIS. WITH STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE- I GO OF
COURSE EVERYTHING THE STATE
AUDITOR JUST SAID SHE'S
ENTIRELY CORRECT I WOULD OFFER
A COUPLE OF OTHER THOUGHTS ONE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE GENERAL.
LACK OF A COMPREHENSIVE
RECESSION PLAN. EDV AND SHARED
WITH US THAT BETWEEN THE END OF
THE GREAT RECESSION IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC I
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON SEVERAL.
DIFFERENT INITIATIVES TO TRY
AND IMPROVE. ITS PROCESSING OF
CLAIMS- INTRODUCING YOU AYE
ONLINE IS IT IS A GOOD EXAMPLE
OF THAT. BUT I WELL THAT'S ALL.
NECESSARILY NOT NECESSARILY
UNTRUE THEY PAY DID MAKE
CERTAIN CHANGES TO THEIR
PROCESSES THAT IS STILL SHORT
OF A COMPREHENSIVE RECESSION
PLAN. THAT WOULD FOR EXAMPLE.
BUT SPEAK TO HOW ARE YOU GOING
TO SCALE UP YOUR OPERATION WHEN
YOU ARE IN MORE DEMAND THAN YOU
ARE. IN A YOU KNOW A GOOD
ECONOMIC YEAR SO. IT'S NOT TO
SAY THEY WEREN'T DOING ANYTHING
WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE REPORT
THEY WERE WELL SHORT OF THE
TYPE OF PREPAREDNESS AND
PLANNING. THAT WE WOULD EXPECT
THEM TO HAVE DONE GIVEN THAT
THEY KNOW. RECESSIONS HAPPEN ON
A REGULAR BASIS AND THAT THEY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO. SCALE UP
THEIR OPERATION BUT SERVE MORE
CALIFORNIANS DURING THE
RECESSIONARY TIME THAN THEY DO
DURING A NON RECESSIONARY TIME.
FINALLY WHEN IT COMES TO BANK
OF AMERICA I WOULD OFFER AS A
ANOTHER EXPLANATION. THE STATE
AUDITOR REFERRED EARLIER TO.
THE ED'S DISJOINTED APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING FRAUD PREVENTING AND
DETECTING FRAUD WE SIGN NO
CLEAR. OR CONSISTENT POINT OF
CONTACT FOR WOULD BE
COMMUNICATING WITH BANK OF
AMERICA WHICH I THINK ALSO
CONTRIBUTES TO. A LACK OF
PREPAREDNESS AND PLANNING TO
ADDRESS FROZEN. BANK ACCOUNTS
IN A TIMELY FASHION. GOT IT
THANK YOU PRESHEAF THAT I MEAN
THAT. JUST SOUNDS TO ME THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO ASK YOU TO
DO THAT QUESTION I KNOW THAT
THEY'RE LISTENING AND WE HAVE
THEM ON A LATER PANEL- LET ME
JUST ASK AT. THE ADDITIONAL
QUESTION DID HE DID HE GIVE A
REASON FOR SUSPENDING THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS WHICH
LED TO A LOT OF THE FRAUD. YES
SO. EDT AT THE DIRECTION OF
AGENCY SECRETARY SUSPENDED
THOSE ELIGIBILITY.
DETERMINATIONS IN AN EFFORT TO
EXPEDITE PAYMENT CALIFORNIANS-
SO EIGHT ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATION WOULD SLOW DOWN
PAYMENT. FIVE BECAUSE IT WOULD
TAKE MORE STAFF TIME TO REVIEW
THE POTENTIAL ELIGIBILITY
CONCERNS- IT'LL REQUIRE BACK
AND FORTH THE CLAIMANT
CONSENSUALLY- TO. MAKE AN
ASSESSMENT OF THEIR ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE PROGRAM SO. THAT IS
CERTAINLY A MORE TIME
CONSUMING. TASK THAN JUST
ISSUING THE PAYMENT WITHOUT
MAKING THAT DETERMINATION. THE
INTENTION WAS TO PAY PEOPLE.
THEIR BENEFITS MORE QUICKLY.
BUT AS YOU NOTED. THAT DID
LEAVE THE EDT MORE VULNERABLE
TO FRAUD- BECAUSE THEY WERE
PAYING PEOPLE WITHOUT KNOWING.
FOR CERTAIN THAT THEY WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM. GOT
IT SO IN YOUR FINDINGS YOU
FOUND THAT THEY RECOGNIZE THE
FACT THAT THEY SUSPENDED THESE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS THEY
WOULD BE OPENING THEMSELVES UP.
BUT DECIDED TO ACCEPT THAT RISK.
THERE'S NO CLEAR MENTION OF THE
INCREASED FRAUD RISK IN THE
AGENCY SECRETARY'S DIRECTIVE
THAT I CAN RECALL ANYWAY- IT
WAS MOSTLY FOCUSED ON. WE NEED
TO SPEND THESE DETERMINATIONS
SO THAT WE CAN MAKE PAYMENTS IN
A MORE TIMELY FASHION. GOT IT
AND THEN I HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION AND THEN I'LL DEFERRED
BY COLLEAGUES MAYBE COME BACK
FOR ADDITIONAL ONES BUT WANTED
TO TOUCH UPON THE CALL CENTERS
BECAUSE I KNOW THE LEGISLATURE
HERE- ALLOCATED RESOURCES
NEEDED DE HIRED AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED- STAFF
MEMBERS BUT- LOOKING AT THE
AUTO REPORT. YOU SEE. ONLY A
MARGINAL IMPROVEMENT IN TERMS
OF THE PERCENTAGE OF CALLS
ANSWERED- DID EDT GIVE A REASON
WHY THAT WAS OR WAS THERE
ANYTHING THAT YOU SAW. THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED
ACTUALLY HELP THE EFFICACY
RATES AT THE CALL CENTERS FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS. WELL AGAIN I
WOULD POINT TO THE LACK OF
PREPAREDNESS AND LET ME UNPACK
A LITTLE BIT WHAT I MEAN BY
THAT AS THE STATE AUDITOR
INDICATED EARLIER IN HER
PRESENTATION. NGUYEN EDT
ONBOARDED ITS NEW STAFF THE
TRAINING PROGRAM FOR IT THERE-
MOST HELPFUL TEAR IF YOU OTHER
EPR AGENTS THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE ABLE TO ASSIST WITH THE
WIDEST RANGE OF- CALLER
PROBLEMS. THAT TRAINING PROGRAM
WAS THE SLIMMED DOWN VERSION
WAS NINE MONTHS LONG. SO IF IT
TAKES YOU YOU KNOW FROM THE
POINT OF HIGHER TO NINE MONTHS
LATER TO BE YOU KNOW FULLY
TRAINED AND ONBOARDED INTO
BEING ABLE TO ASSIST CALLERS
WITH. PRETTY MUCH ANY OF THEIR
ISSUES THAT MEANS YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST
THEM. IN A MORE EXPECT
EXPEDITIOUS FASHION EARLIER ON
IN THE PANDEMICS OF THAT'S
THAT'S ONE PROBLEM AND THEN THE
SECOND PROBLEM WAS ET DE. DID
ON BOARD OF. A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
TO. ANSWER THE PHONES THAT HAD
NOT THE BACK THAT POSITION THAT
CLASSIFICATION- THAT TYPE OF
CALL CENTER AGENT HADN'T
EXISTED PRE PANDEMIC THEY CALL
THAT WE CALL IT IN OUR- AUDIT
REPORT THEIR TIER ONE AGENTS.
EDT PROVIDED THEM RELATIVELY
QUICK TRAINING TO GET THEM ON
THE PHONES. MORE QUICKLY THAN
THEIR EPR AGENTS. BUT THAT
TRAINING WAS FAIRLY LIMITED IT
WAS TO RESOLVE MINOR
ADMINISTRATIVE ISSUES WITH
SOMEONE'S ONLINE ACCOUNT AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE NOT
NECESSARILY TO HELP SOMEONE
WITH THEIR CLAIMS SO IT TOOK
EIGHTY ADDITIONAL TIME. TO
PROVIDE THOSE TIER ONE AGENTS
ADDITIONAL TRAINING THAT COULD
ALLOW THEM TO ASSIST CLAIMANTS
WITH. LIKELY WHAT MOST OF THEM
WERE CALLING ABOUT WHICH ISN'T
A PROBLEM WITH THEIR YOU Y.
CLAIM. GOT IT I KNOW THE
GOVERNOR'S STRIKE TEAM
INITIALLY SAID ABOUT 1% OF THE
CALLS LESS THAN 1% OF THE CALLS
WERE ACTUALLY- ANSWERED. AND
REALLY ANSWERS EVEN BEING
DELIVERED OR CONSTITUENTS- EVEN
AFTER THIS INFUSION. HOW MUCH
DID THE NEEDLE MOVES. RIGHT SO
IT WAS NO LESS THAN 1% CALL
RATE IS FROM EARLY ON IN THE
PANDEMIC. IT'S FROM THE- MARCH
TO APRIL TIME FRAME AND THAT IS
REALLY THE HEIGHT OF THE CLAIM
ACTIVITY. IN THE CALL ACTIVITY
INTO THE CALL CENTER. AS YOU
GET INTO THE LATER STAGES OF
THE PANDEMIC AND THEN PACKAGE
HEY THIS IS ON ON PAGE THREE.
AFTER THOSE ARE INTERESTED IN
SEEING THE GRAPHIC AS YOU GET
INTO THE LATER LATER STAGES OF
THE PANDEMIC- IS THAT. THERE IS
AN UPWARD TECH WHICH WE RELATE
TO IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF
CALLS ANSWERED. WE RELATE THAT
TO PEOPLE FINALLY YOU KNOW
BECOMING AVAILABLE TO HELP
PEOPLE ON THE PHONE- IN THE
PRIMARY CONSTRAINT ON ATVS.
NUMBER OF CALLS ANSWERED IS
THEIR STAFFING SOMEONE CAN ONLY
ANSWER SO MANY CALLS PER DAY.
AND HE HAS OR DOESN'T HAVE A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF PEOPLE SO
THEY'LL STAFF AS MANY AS THEY
HAVE. YOU CAN ACTUALLY BE
HELPFUL THE CLAIMANTS. AND THEN
THAT IS THE PRIMARY CONSTRAINT
ON THE NUMBER OF CALLS THAT CAN
ANSWER. SO THEIR CALL
PERCENTAGE RATES DO GO UP THERE
MARGINAL. THE PERCENTAGE OF
CALLS ANSWERED. IS ALSO
AFFECTED BY HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
CALLING AND YOU CAN ALSO SEE
TOWARDS THE LATER STAGES OF THE
PANDEMIC. THERE ARE FEWER AND
FEWER UNIQUE CALLERS CALLING
THE CALL CENTER AS WELL. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT- I'M GONNA
PAUSE THERE AND ALLOW MY
COLLEAGUES US QUESTIONS I KNOW
THERE'S A NUMBER IN THE ROOM-
THAT HAVE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
WITHOUT WILL MOVE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRS- JUST ASK A QUESTION
OBVIOUSLY- LOT OF FRIED YOU
THERE'S A SERIOUS SERIOUS
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT HOW TO
HOW TO MOVE FORWARD. THERE BEEN
PEOPLE CAUGHT UP. IN THE IN THE
FRAUD OR TRYING TO CORRECT THE
FRAUD PART OF THIS SO THEY GIVE
YOU A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES. FOR
WOMEN IN MENDOCINO COUNTY- I
WAS A SINGLE MOTHER OF TWO WAS
TOLD YOU CAN'T CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE HER BENEFITS BECAUSE
SHE'S IN JAIL. SHE'S NOT IN
JAIL SHE'S NEVER BEEN IN JAIL
SHE'S GOT NOTHING MORE THAN A
SPEEDING TICKET. WE CAN'T
RESOLVE THAT SO SHE CAN HAVE TO
GET SOME SORT OF AFFIDAVIT FROM
THE FROM THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM TO PROVE SHE'S NOT IN
JAIL. AND SHE CAN'T GET
THROUGH. ON A YOU KNOW SHE'S
GONNA SHE'S BEEN TOLD SHE CAN
GET AN APPEAL BUT- IT'S GONNA
TAKE AWHILE. I'VE GOT ANOTHER
GENTLEMAN. WHO FOR. MONTHS
TRYING TO GET BENEFITS GOT
BENEFITS AND THEY WERE
SUSPENDED- YOU CAN'T IT TOOK
HIM ANOTHER SIX WEEKS TO FIND
OUT THAT HE COULD. FILE AN
APPEAL. HIS APPEAL IS UNTIL MAY.
IN THE MEANTIME IS SLEEPING IN
A CAR. IN A STATE PARK PARKING
LOT. SO WHILE WE HAVE HE HAVE
HE WAS GETTING BENEFITS SO
WHILE WE HAVE DONE THEY WERE
MAKING EFFORTS TO CUT DOWN ON
THE FRAUD WE'RE CATCHING NINE
REAL PEOPLE UP IN THIS THAT ARE
NOT FRAUDULENT CLAIMS SO IS
THERE MY QUESTION IS DID EDT
OPERATES FOR A PLAN TO EXPEDITE
FIXING SOME OF THOSE. THOSE
THINGS BECAUSE LIKE WE'RE
REALLY GOOD AT GETTING WE WERE
PRETTY GOOD TO GET MONEY TO
PEOPLE IN WHO WERE
INCARCERATED. BY SOMEONE WHO
SAID THAT YOU WERE HERE WE GOT
SOMEONE WHO'S NOT INCARCERATED
BEING TOLD HE'S INCARCERATED
THANK HAS TO WAIT FOR MONTHS TO
GET A CLAIMS ADJUDICATOR SO IS.
MY POINT IS. WHAT IS EDIE'S
PLAN TO HELP. FIX THE OTHER THE
POWER FOR THE PENDULUM SWUNG
THE OTHER WAY THE AFFECTING
OTHER PEOPLE'S LIVES. CHECK
WITH RESPECT FAMILY MEMBER TO
THE ED'S PLANS TO HELP PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN CAUGHT UP PERHAPS
THAT THEIR- BENEFITS STOPPED
WHEN THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE BANNED
CERTAINLY WE NOTE SEVERAL
CONCERNS ABOUT EIGHTY DURING IN
FACT THAT BANK OF AMERICA IS A
GOOD EXAMPLE OF THAT- I WOULD
DEFER TO EDT IN TERMS OF. HOW
EXACTLY SOMEONE SHOULD. SHOULD
GO ABOUT TRYING TO GET THE
SYSTEMS WE DID NOT LOOK
DIRECTLY AT THE APPEALS PROCESS
THAT YOU REFERRED TO. BUT THIS
IS THE TYPE OF- THE IMPACT THAT
HAPPENS IF YOU'RE NOT REGULARLY
ASSESSING THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
YOUR FRAUD PREVENTION TOOLS. A
REGULAR ASSESSMENT GOING BACK
YEARS AND YEARS NOW. WOULD HAVE
ALLOWED EIGHTY D. TO DETERMINE
THAT IT. MORE FREQUENTLY THAN
IT SHOULD SWEEPS UP LEGITIMATE
CLAIMANTS IN ITS FRAUD
PREVENTION EFFORTS IF IT HAD
BEEN DOING THAT ANALYSIS-
BLEEDING INTO THE PANDEMIC.
THEN HOPEFULLY AND IDEALLY IT
WOULD HAVE FINE TUNE THOSE
FRAUD PREVENTION TECHNIQUES AND
APPROACHES SO THAT- AS FEW AS
POSSIBLE LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS
WERE GETTING CAUGHT UP IN THEM
AND THEN ALSO. HOPEFULLY
PLANNING AHEAD FOR HOW TO
EXPEDITIOUSLY HELP PEOPLE WHO
ARE CAUGHT UP- BUT I WOULD I
WOULD DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT
FOR PRECISELY HOW PEOPLE
SHOULD. ATTEMPT TO RESOLVE
THEIR INDIVIDUAL SITUATION. ALL
RIGHT SIR WE'VE HEARD FROM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD- WILL I
SEE A LOT OF MIKE'S UP WILL GO
TO SENATOR BAKER NEXT HE PUTS
MIKE UP FIRST GO AHEAD SIR.
GREAT THANK YOU I THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU ARE DOING
ON THIS- PRETTY WITH NO
TECHNOLOGY SOME IS RUN A
TECHNOLOGY COMPANY THIS IS
INCOMPREHENSIBLE. IT REALLY
STARTS WITH CUSTOMER SERVICE
THAT PROCEDURE MISSILES ASKING
ABOUT. THE PHONES AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE HEARD. TWENTY TWO
EVEN TODAY FOR CALLING HUNDREDS
OF HUNDREDS OF TIMES. A HUNDRED
EMAILS AND NOT GETTING A
RESPONSE. AS I WANT TO COME
BACK THAT THE MINUTE I WOULDN'T
START THOUGH WITH- REPORTED
EIGHT HUNDRED TEN MILLION. WAS
WENT TO INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS. THE OTHER NINE
POINT SIX BILLION IS BEING
REPORTED AS FRAUD. BUT IN
REALITY YOU SAY THAT THESE ARE
PAYMENTS WENT UNCONFIRMED
INDIVIDUALS SO OTHER THAN NINE
POINT SIX BILLION. HOW MUCH DO
YOU BELIEVE WAS ACTUALLY
FRAUDULENT. SO THAT THAT WILL.
THAT'S AN ASSESSMENT THAT ATV
WILL NEED TO DO IN THE COMING
MONTHS- THE REASON WE'RE
CALLING THAT. TENSELY
FRAUDULENT IS BECAUSE EDT
ITSELF CONSIDERS AN UNCONFIRMED
IDENTITY TO BE AN INDICATOR OF
POTENTIAL FRAUD- CERTAINLY WE
INDICATE THE REPORT. THAT THERE
ARE TIMES WHERE SOMEONE WILL.
THE UNABLE TO CONFIRM THEIR
IDENTITY WITH THE TV OR CHOOSE
NOT TO FOLLOW THROUGH WITH
CONFIRMING THEIR IDENTITY AND
THAT IS NOT NECESSARILY- FRAUD
BUT EXACTLY HOW MUCH IS NOT
KNOWN TO US BECAUSE AT THIS
POINT IN TIME IS NOT KNOWN EDT
THAT AS THE WORK IN FRONT OF
THEM COMING. WE SAID THEY
STOPPED ONE POINT SIX MILLION
PAYMENTS TO UNCONFIRMED
INDIVIDUALS HOW COME THE OTHER
FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY ODD
THOUSAND YOU IDENTIFY WENT
THROUGH. RIGHT SO IT'S A
COMBINATION OF FACTORS LIKELY
AND I'LL STEP THROUGH A COUPLE
OF THEM ONE IS THAT AT. AS A
STATE AUDITOR INDICATED
EARLIER- ET DE HAD A LARGELY
MANUAL PROCESS IN THE BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC FOR- APPLYING
STOP PAYMENTS TO POTENTIALLY.
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS. WE TALK
ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT THAT'S
THE FIRST STEP THE EDT TRUCK IN
IN JULY. TO CHANGE ITS BROAD
APPROACH- WHICH IS YOU KNOW
FIVE POINT SIX MILLION CLAIMS
INTO PANDEMIC THAT AUTOMATED
THAT STOP PAYMENT PROCESS SO
THAT IT WAS NO LONGER- STAFF
WHO HAD TO MANUALLY REVIEW
SOMETIMES OVER A THOUSAND-
SUSPICIOUS CLAIMS PER DAY. AND
APPLY THAT STOP PAYMENT
MANUALLY SOCERTAINLY BETWEEN
THE TIME EDT DETECTED. CERTAIN
CLAIMS MAYBE- SUSPICIOUS OR
POTENTIALLY FRAUDULENT TO THE
TIME THOSE STAFF WERE ACTUALLY
ABLE TO APPLY. THE STOP PAYMENT
TO THE CLAIM PAYMENTS COULD GO
OUT THAT'S ONE EXPLANATION.
ANOTHER EXCELLENT. I IN
PARTICULAR A STARK ONE HAS TO
DO WITH THE BILLION DOLLARS OF
THAT TEN POINT FOUR BILLION-
THAT WE ESTIMATE WAS
POTENTIALLY FRAUDULENT A
BILLION OF THOSE DOLLARS. WERE
PAID OUT BECAUSE OF A
DELIBERATE DECISION BY EDT
MANAGEMENT TO STOP USING A
FRAUD SAFEGUARDS. WE TALK ABOUT
THAT IN OUR WATER REPORT WHERE
WE DESCRIBE THAT EARLY ON IN
THE PANDEMIC IN MARCH. EDT
MANAGEMENT WAS TRYING TO
STREAMLINE THEIR PROCESS SEES
TO TRY AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY
THEY DIDN'T HAVE STUFF CLOGGING
UP THEIR SYSTEM AND STOPPING
PAYMENTS FROM GOING OUT. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THEY
MISUNDERSTOOD. THAT THE VALUE
OF A PARTICULAR FRAUD SAFEGUARD
THEY THOUGHT THAT IF THEY
STOPPED APPLYING. THIS STOP
PAYMENT ALERT- TWO CLAIMS WHERE
THEY HAD UNCONFIRMED IDENTITIES
IF THEY STOPPED APPLYING THAT
STOP HIM OR THAT SOMETHING ELSE
IN THERE IT SYSTEM ADDITIONAL
SAFEGUARDS WILL BACK THEM UP
AND STILL- STOP PAYMENTS FROM
GOING OUT TO THOSE CLAIMS UNTIL
THEY RESOLVED. THE IDENTITY OF
THE CLIMATE. UNFORTUNATELY THEY
WERE WRONG ABOUT THAT WHEN THEY
WAVE THAT STOP PAYMENT ALERT
WHEN THEY STOPPED REPLYING TO
THOSE CLAIMS. THEY PAID A
BILLION OF THE TEN POINT FOUR
BILLION. TO INDIVIDUALS WHOSE
IDENTITIES THEY COULD
EVENTUALLY NOT VALIDATE. IT
COULD'VE BEEN WORSE THAN THAT
WE TALK IN THE REPORT ABOUT HOW
THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION. THAT WENT
OUT THROUGH THE SAME PROCESS
EDT THAT BROKE FAVORABLY FOR
THEM FOR THAT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION THAT WENT TO CLAIMANTS
WHOSE IDENTITIES WERE
EVENTUALLY CONFIRMED- WHICH
GIVES COMFORT THAT THAT'S NOT
ACTUALLY FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS.
BUT THE BULK OF IT ONE BILLION
WAS THE DIRECT RESULT OF THE
DECISION TO STOP JUST STOP
APPLYING. A KEY FRAUD
PROTECTION THAT MEASURE. THAT'S
RIGHT BUT THE OTHER EIGHT
BILLION COULD HAVE GONE TO
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS IS THAT
CORRECT. AND THAT'S WHAT HE
DOES NOT KNOW AT THIS POINT YOU
ARE CORRECT YES AND THAT IS%
WHAT YOU NEED YOU WILL HAVE TO
DETERMINE. AS IT BEGINS TO
ASSESS WHETHER IT OVERPAID
CLAIMS OKAY THAT'S RIGHT WHICH
IS THAT YOU KNOW BILLION IS.
UNMATCHABLE TWO BILLION IS JUST
THAT YOU KNOW UNEXPLAINABLE BUT
I THINK WE SHOULD BE CLEAR IT'S
BEEN REPORTED AS ALL AFFRONT
WHEN YOU'RE REALLY YOU'RE
SAYING THE OTHER EIGHT BILLION
COULD HAVE GONE TO LEGITIMATE
FOLKS. YOU JUST IT JUST MAY
WANT TO UNCONFIRMED ADDRESSES
CORRECT. I THINK WE SHOULD BE
CLEAR WHEN YOU. RIGHT IT WENT
TO CLAIMS FOR WHICH I EDT
CANNOT CONFIRM THE IDENTITY OF
THE CLIMATE AND YES WE DESCRIBE
IT NOT A REPORT AS POTENTIALLY
FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS. OR JUST A
WRAP UP BACK ON THE CUSTOMER
SERVICE A POINT- AND I
MENTIONED YOU KNOW WE HAVE
CONSTITUENTS AND LIVE EVENTS
INDUSTRY- THEIR PAYMENTS WERE
FROZEN THEY'VE CALLED THEY'RE
STILL NOT GETTING. THROUGH WHAT
IS YOUR RECOMMENDATION YOU SEEN
HERE THAT WE'RE NOT USING BEST
PRACTICES FOR MANAGING THE CALL
CENTER AND APPRECIATE WHAT THE
ORDER SAID ABOUT DOING A SORT
OF START STOP CONTINUE WHAT
TOOLS THEY CAN USE IN THE
FUTURE TO PREVENT THIS- BUT
WOULD YOU BELIEVE CAN BE DONE
RIGHT NOW OTHER THAN MORE
BODIES. TO HELP THE CALL CENTRE
ISSUE. SURE SO CERTAINLY THEY
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO FIND
MORE PEOPLE ANSWERING THE CALL
CENTER TO ALLOW THEM TO ANSWER
MORE CALLS SO AS I MENTIONED A
MOMENT AGO THAT. THE PRIMARY
CONSTRAINT IS HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE ANSWERING THE PHONES. AD
THEIR MAXIMUM CAPACITY FOR HOW
MANY CALLS THEY CAN ANSWER
EVERY DAY SO THAT THAT IS THE
MOST IMMEDIATE BANG EDT CAN I
CAN DO BUT- AS WE MENTIONED IN
THE AUTO REPORT. AT IT'S ALSO
IMPOTANT THAT WHOEVER'S
ANSWERING THAT PHONE IS. TRULY
AND GENUINELY ASSISTING THE
PERSON WITH THEIR ISSUE THE
REASON WHY THEY'RE CONTACTING
EDT SO THAT YOU'D BE AND- I'M
NOT HAVE THAT PERSON HAVE TO
CALL BACK AGAIN A SECOND THIRD
OR FOURTH TIME. WHICH PUTS A
STRAIN ON THE CALL CENTER
SYSTEM. SO AGAIN YOU'RE CORRECT
THAT IN THE MOST IMMEDIATE TERM
THEY CAN ENSURE THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO STAFF THAT CALL
CENTER APPROPRIATELY WITH THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE. BUT IT IS
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT THAT THEY-
UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE ARE
CALLING. SO THAT THEY CAN
PROVIDE STREAMLINED QUICK HIT
TRAINING TO THEIR STAFF. FOR
HOW TO ASSIST PEOPLE WITH THAT.
AND THEN MEASURE WHETHER
THEY'RE ACTUALLY RESOLVING
ISSUES WITH ON THE FIRST PHONE
CALL. THANK YOU JUST- THIS IS
THE LINE HOW- IN ADDITION TO
THAT WITH RESPECT TO THE CALL
CENTER- ONE OF THE THINGS WE
IDENTIFIED IN THE REPORT YEARS
AGO WAS THEY THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO HAVE FOLKS YOU
KNOW ASK FOR A CALL BACK SO I
CAN'T GET THROUGH BUT I CAN
LEAVE MY INFORMATION AND ASKED
FOR A CALL BACK THE OTHER THING
IS HAVING PRE RECORDED
MESSAGES. PRE RECORDED
INFORMATION THAT A CALL OR CAN
LISTEN TO AND HOPEFULLY THAT
RESOLVES THEIR PARTICULAR-
QUESTION- SO WE ARE SUGGESTING
IN OUR RECOMMENDATIONS ET THEY
IMMEDIATELY DEVELOP THOSE PRE
RECORDED MESSAGES THEY HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO DO THAT WITH OUR
PHONE SYSTEM THEY LOST THAT
FUNCTIONALITY WHEN THEY
IMPLEMENTED THIS VIRTUAL-
CONTACT US SO THAT THEIR
COLLARS COULD BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC- COLORS COULD BE AT
HOME WORKING REMOTELY- THE
VIRTUAL I THINK IT'S CONSERVE
CALLED VIRTUAL. CONTACT SO-
SOME OF THE FUNCTIONALITY OF
THE PHONE SYSTEM WAS LOST THEY
NEED TO REINSTATE SOME OF THAT
LIKE THE PRE RECORDED MESSAGES
THE ABILITY TO OPT FOR A CLAIM%
AND TO LEAVE A MESSAGE SAYING I
NEED A CALL BACK FROM SOMEONE-
SO THAT THAT READ REDUCES THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE CALLING
MULTIPLE TIMES OVER AND OVER
AGAIN BECAUSE THEY'RE GETTING
BLOCKED THEY'RE NOT EVEN
GETTING THROUGH TO THE SYSTEM
WE'VE GOT TO FIND A WAY. TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF CALLS
CONTINUALLY COMING INTO THE
SYSTEM BECAUSE AS WE STATED IN
A REPORT ON THIS WAS TRUE NOT
TEN YEARS AGO THERE WERE
MULTIPLE MULTIPLE PEOPLE
CALLING CAN'T EVEN GET THROUGH
TO AN INDIVIDUAL THEIR BLOCK
STATE THEY CAN'T THEY DON'T
EVEN TALK TO ANYONE THEY CAN'T
EVEN GET THROUGH THE SYSTEM SO
THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT THEY
COULD DO IMMEDIATELY IN
ADDITION TO WHAT- MR HARRIS
SAID AS FAR AS- ADDING
ADDITIONAL STAFF. BECAUSE SOME
OF THE STAFF AS HE MENTIONED-
THESE TIER ONE INDIVIDUALS ARE
ONLY RECEIVED A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF TRAINING AND IN MANY CASES.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS COULDN'T HELP
THE PER CHEN WHO WHO. WERE ABLE
TO GET TO AND TALK TO THEM THE
CLAIMANT TALK TO THEM. AND IT
WAS A CLOSE 230% OF THOSE CALLS
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO RESOLVE
THE SITUATION AND HAD TO REFER
THAT. TO IT. AND ALL THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO HAD CALLED IN
I'M GONNA HAVE TO REFER THIS TO
SOMEONE WHO IS MORE EXPERIENCED
AND WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU WHICH
AGAIN. IT'S FRUSTRATING FOR
CLAIMANTS WHO FINALLY GOT
THROUGH. PERHAPS AFTER MULTIPLE
ATTEMPTS NOW GETS TO SOMEONE
WHO CAN HELP THEM AND CERTAINLY
THAT PERSON AT EDT IS
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE- THEY DON'T
HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO ASSIST PEOPLE. SO WE DO
HAVE SOME IMMEDIATE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE THINK
EDT NEEDS TO IMPLEMENT
IMMEDIATELY- AND THEN A COUPLE
OF OTHER. RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
THEY NEED TO IMPLEMENT BY MARCH
OF THIS YEAR AND WE THINK THAT
WILL HELP. IN RESOLVING SOME OF
THE ISSUESTHEY'VE HAD WITH THE
CALL CENTER PERFORMANCE. ALL
RIGHTS A- LOT OF MIKE'S UP-
WILL GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER TIM
GRAYSON NEXT AND I'D LIKE TO
ASK THE MEMBERS. IF YOUR
QUESTION PERTAINS. SOME
QUESTIONS WILL BE BEST ANSWERED
BY EDT. REPRESENTATIVES
THEMSELVES IF YOUR QUESTION
PERTAIS TO MISSILES AUDIT- BY
ALL MEANS ASK THOSE QUESTIONS
NOW BUT- IT JUST KEEP THAT IN
MIND BECAUSE THERE WILL BE
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES SO AFTER
EDT PRESENTS THEIR- DOES THEIR
PRESENTATION GO AHEAD MR
GRAYSON THANK YOU CHAIR DALY
AND SURE SALAS AND ALSO- THANK
YOU TO THE STATE ORDERED FOR A
THOROUGH AND COMPREHENSIVE
REPORT JUST A FEW QUESTIONS
HERE- THE FRAUD WHAT WAS FRAUD
MORE PREVALENT WITH ONE
PARTICULAR PAYMENT METHOD OVER
ANOTHER FOR INSTANCE A CARD
VERSUS A PRINTED CHECK- I DON'T
KNOW IF- YOU INCLUDED THAT IN
YOUR AUDIT. AND THEN ALSO- I
GUESS A FOLLOW UP TO THAT
QUESTION WOULD BE WHAT IMPACT
WOULD- THERE BE TWO BOEING
DIRECT DEPOSIT AND HOW THAT
WOULD ADDRESS FRAUD THE SECOND
MAIN QUESTION OF. THE SIDE THE
FIRST TO. BY UNITS IN YOUR
PRESENTATION- AT THE VERY
BEGINNING REFERENCED TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN REPORT. AND
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU MADE-
WERE A IN YOUR AUTO AT THIS
TIME WAS THEIR CONSIDERATION
GIVEN TO THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND DETERMINATIONS MADE.
WHETHER THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
WERE ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED AND
THE REASON WHY I ASK THAT. WELL
IT IS BECAUSE IN THIS REPORT
THIS TIME WAS IT AS EASY AS IN
SOME CASES JUST COPYING AND
PASTING YOUR RECOMMENDATION ALL
OVER AGAIN. AND HOW ARE WE ABLE
TO INSURE THAT WE DON'T JUST
RELIVE THE CYCLE FROM TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. AND YOUR
EXCELLENT RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
YOU'VE MADE IN YOUR REPORT GOAL
I'M IMPLEMENTED AND WE FACE
THIS AAIN DOWN THE ROAD SO HOW
BEST CAN WE ENSURE THAT YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THAT IT TO GO IN ORDER OF YOUR
QUESTIONS ONE NO WE DIDN'T LOOK
SPECIFICALLY NOTED THAT DATA
EDT GAVE US- IDENTIFY. METHOD
OF PAYMENT IN TERMS OF WHAT I.
THE DISTRIBUTION OF THE
POTENTIAL FRAUD- HOW THEY GOT
PAID OUT SO TO HAVE DON'T HAVE
ANY INFORMATION FOR YOU ON THAT
AND I THINK TO THE QUESTION
ABOUT DIRECT DEPOSIT. I BELIEVE
YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE
PRACTICE SOME OTHER STATES
ENGAGE IN WHERE THEY ALLOW FOR
PEOPLE TO RECEIVE THEIR BENEFIT
PAYMENTS THROUGH DIRECT DEPOSIT
I'M CERTAINLY AWARE THAT AT
LEAST THERE'S BEEN ONE BILL
INTRODUCED THAT WOULD ALLOW
PEOPLE TO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
SUCH AN OPTION- BUT WE MAKE NO
DIRECT. AUDIT FINDING ABOUT-
THAT THE PROS OR CONS OF MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION AGAIN WE HAVE
NO DATA ON THE DISTRIBUTION OF
POTENTIAL FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS
IN TERMS OF HOW THEY GOT PAID
OUT. WITH RESPECT TO THE CALL
CENTER RECOMMENDATIONS THERE
SIMILAR TO THE RECOMMENDATIONS
WE MADE IN THE PREVIOUS REPORT.
AND SILVA COPIED AND PASTED
NECESSARILY BUT THEY ARE IN THE
IN THE SPIRIT OF. THE SAME
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE FROM
PAST AUDIT REPORTS AND REALLY
THAT COMMON THREAD I EDT NEEDS
TO BE. ADHERING TO THE BEST
PRACTICES. THAT ARE COMMONLY
ACCEPTED FOR HOW TO RUN A CALL
CENTER OPERATION. SO THAT IT IS
THE MOST HELPFUL TO THE PEOPLE
WHO NEED TO USE THAT- WE HAD
ASSESSED THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
IS FULLY IMPLEMENTED THE ONES
FROM THE PRIOR AUDIT REPORT BUT
WHAT WE SAW WHEN WE ARE BACK IN
THIS TIME. THAT HE WAS NOT
FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH
CONTINUALLY IMPLEMENTING THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS SO THEY MAY
HAVE DONE SOMETHING IN THE
PAST. THAT WE TOOK A LOOK AT IT
WE SAID THIS IS GOOD. THE
SATISFIES OUR RECOMMENDATION.
WHAT WE DIDN'T SEE WAS THE
FOLLOW THROUGH WE DIDN'T SEE
THEM CONTINUING TO ADOPT. AND
FOLLOW THROUGH ON THOSE BEST
PRACTICES AND THAT'S WHERE- IF
THEY ARE LEFT THEMSELVES UP IN
SOME PRETTY KEY DEFICIENCIES.
WITH RESPECT OVERSIGHT
CERTAINLY WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW
UP WITH EDT ABOUT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS- I THINK OUR
FIRST RESPONSE IS DUE BACK FROM
EDT- NINETY DAYS FROM. FROM
LAST WEEK SO JUST ABOUT NINETY
DAYS FROM TODAY. ABOUT HOW ARE
THEY DOING WHAT ARE THEY DOING
TO IMPLEMENT OUR
RECOMMENDATION. AND WE CAN
CERTAINLY MAKE THAT INFORMATION
AVAILABLE AFTER WE'VE DONE OUR
QUICK ASSESSMENT OF THEIR
PROGRESS- TO YOU AND THE OTHER
MEMBERS AS TO WHAT YOU EAT WHAT
PROGRESS EDB IS OR IS NOT.
MAKING TO ADDRESS THOSE
PROBLEMS. AND JUST ONE TO ADD
TO THAT- IS THAT- WE MADE
SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
NEED TO PUT BE PUT INTO
STATUTE. LIKE THE CROSS
MATCHING REQUIREMENTS THE
REQUIREMENT TO PUT TOGETHER
RECESSION PLAN AS AS BOB
INDICATED THEY THEY HAD MADE
SOME IMPROVEMENTS WITH RESPECT
TO THE CALL CENTER AND SOME OF
THEIR CLAIMS PROCESSING WHEN WE
REVIEWED THEIR RESPONSES TO US-
AFTER WE ISSUED THE MARCH OF
TWENTY ELEVEN REPORT BUT WE DID
A FOLLOW UP AUDIT IN NOVEMBER
OF TWENTY TWELVE WHICH WAS
BEYOND. BEYOND ONE YEAR. WHICH
TYPICALLY IS THE CYCLE IN.
SIXTY DAYS SIX MONTHS ONE YEAR
IS A TYPICAL CYCLE FOR AND IT'S-T. TO REPLY TO US RESPOND TO US
AS TO WHAT THEY'VE DONE TO
IMPLEMENT RECOMMENDATIONS AND
WHEN WE HIT THE ONE YEAR MARK
THINGS ARE LOOKING PRETTY GOOD-
THEY WERE STILL. IMPLEMENTING
SOME NEW CHANGES TO THEIR THEIR
CALL CENTER THEY WERE ALSO
IMPLEMENTING SOME OTHER
AUTOMATION- EFFORTS SO WE
DECIDED TO GO BACK IN NOVEMBER
OF TWENTY TWELVE AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE FOUND THAT AS
MR HARRIS INDICATED SOME OF
THOSE THINGS HAVE SLIPPED BACK
SO THERE WASN'T CONSISTENT
CONTINUAL IMPROVEMENT- AND
FOLLOW THROUGH AND. SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT EDT HAD. A SENSE
REAP TO US DURING. THE FIRST
FIRST YEAR AFTER THAT MARCH
TWENTY ELEVEN REPORT SO I THINK
THE DISTINCTION NOW WILL BE.
MANY OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRING SOME
OF THESE THINGS THAT WE LIKE
WOULD LIKE YOU NEEDED TO DO TO
BE PUT IN STATUTE OUR INCLUDING
AS I SAID THE RECESSION PLAN
ACROSS MATCHING. ASSESSING
THEIR FRAUD TOOLS REPORTING TO
THE LEGISLATURE PUTTING THINGS
ON THEIR WEBSITE- SO THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS THE ABILITY TO SEE-
EDIE'S PROGRESS. IN CERTAIN
AREAS AND THEN A DISTINCTION
THAT WE MAKE IN OUR REPORTS NOW
THAT WE WE'VE EVOLVED AS AN
AGENCY- OUR THEIR SYSTEMS HAVE
SOME SOME FOLKS WE HIRED IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS- AS FAR AS
PUTTING SPECIFIC TIME FRAMES.
IN OUR RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
PAST WE WOULD MAKE. A
CONGLOMERATE OF RECOMMENDATIONS
ON A WHOLE LAUNDRY LIST OF
THINGS THE DEPARTMENT NEEDED TO
DO BUT WHAT WE DIDN'T DO IS
PRIORITIZE THESE ARE THE THINGS
YOU NEED TO DO IMMEDIATELY
THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE
EXPECT TO BE DONE BY MARCH. BY
NAY BY JULY- AND WE HAVE ALL OF
THOSE NOW. IN THE AUDIT REPORT
LAID OUT FREE DD IN THE
DOCUMENT THAT WE PROVIDED FOR
THIS HEARING. BOB HAS THE FIRST
PAGES THE LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE NEXT TWO
PAGES ARE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
WE MADE TDD AND WHAT WE DID IS
WE PULLED US OUT OF THE AUDIT
REPORTS SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD HAVE BEEN NICE TO WILL
NET D. WOULD HAVE BEEN NICE
TOOL THAT SAYS. HERE ARE THE
THINGS THAT ARE THE AUDITOR
EXPECTS EDT TO DO IMMEDIATELY
RELATE TO CLAIMS PROCESSING
RELATED TO CALL CENTER RELATED
TO FRAUD. AND HERE IT'S HERE
THE OTHER MILESTONES HERE'S
WHAT WE EXPECT THEM TO BE
COMPLETE BY MARCH BY MADE BY
JULY ETCETERA. SO IT'S A IT'S A
GOOD ROAD MAP ON TO USE A
MEMBERS TERM. FOR YOU AS
MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO EXERCISE
YOUR OVERSIGHT MY OFFICE TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE. TO MONITOR
EDIE'S PROGRESS IN IMPLEMENTING
RECOMMENDATIONS AND HOPEFULLY
IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S GONNA
SAYS T. D. AND DECIDING WHAT
ARE THEIR PRIORITIES WHEN THEY
NEED TO DO IN THE IN IN THE
SHORT TERM AND WHERE THE. TYPES
OF THINGS THEY NEED TO DO IN
THE LONG TERM. ALL RIGHT- LET'S
THERE ARE. STILL A LOT OF MIKE
SURPLUS CODY WERE SOMEBODY
WOMAN A- KAMLAGER. KAMATA DOVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. CHAIR
SALAS AND SHARE DALY FOR
CONVENING THIS AND THANK YOU
AUDITOR I JUST FOR THE RECORD
WANNA SAY THAT SOME. I THINK A
WEEK OR SO AGO- THE ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE HAD A-
MEETING WITH C. D. C. R. N. T.
D. ON THE FRONT COMING OUT OF
THE PRISONS. AND THEIR REPORT
STATED THAT IN FACT MANY OF THE
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WERE
VICTIMS OF IDENTITY THEFT SO I
JUST WANT TO SORT OF PUT THAT
OUT THERE BECAUSE I KNOW WE
TEND TO MISS CHARACTERIZE THOSE
FOLKS. THE REPORT AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU'VE
OFFERED FOCUS A LOT ON
INDIVIDUALS I WAS WONDERING IF
YOU COULD ALSO SPEAK TO.
ORGANIZATIONS SPECIFICALLY
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ALSO SEEM TO BE CAUGHT UP IN
SOME OF THIS SO SPECIFICALLY-
MANY NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
TEND TO SELF ON UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE THEY PAY OUT THE
CLAIMS. AND- THAT THEY-
BELIEVED TO BE OBVIOUSLY
LEGITIMATE- BUT THEN IN THIS
INSTANCE MANY OF THEM ENDED UP
BEING FRAUDULENT. AND SO IT'S
NOT ONLY IS PUTTING A NUMBER OF
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
THE BOYS AND GLUBB BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUB AND SOME OTHERS IN
FINANCIAL PERIL. BUT THEY'RE
ALSO BEGINNING TO SEE A LOT OF
THEIR INSURANCE PREMIUMS GO UP
BECAUSE OF THOSE CLAIMS SO HAS
YOUR OFFICE LOOK AT THIS
POPULATION AND ARE THERE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU WOULD
HAVE FOUR EDT REGARDING HOW TO
ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES. THAT
MANY NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
ARE NOW FACING AS A RESULT OF
THE FRAUD. WE DIDN'T
SPECIFICALLY LOOK AT NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THEY THE AUDIT-
THE EMERGENCY ON IT THAT THE
AUDIT COMMITTEE ASKED US TO DO
IS REALLY LOOKING AT THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT'S PERFORMANCE IN
ASSISTING CALIFORNIANS IN
ACCESSING. BENEFITS AND
CERTAINLY- THEIR ABILITY TO
PREVENT FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS
FROM GOING OUT SO WE DIDN'T
LOOK AT NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
AND- YOUR COMMENTS WITH RESPECT
TO INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS IS
ISN'T REALLY IMPORTANT POINT.
ARE THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING WE DON'T GET
INTO THE DETAILS IN THE AUDIT
REPORT ON THAT WERE VICTIMS OF
IDENTITY THEFT- WHO ARE
INCARCERATED- SO THAT IS THAT
IS AN IMPORTANT TO. A POINT
THAT YOU MADE AS I SAID WE ARE
OUR FOCUS REALLY WAS EDT
NEEDING TO HAVE THAT CAPABILITY
TO CROSS MATCH AGAINST
INDIVIDUALS AND IN THE EVENT
THEY DETERMINE THAT- AN
INDIVIDUAL INCARCERATED HAS IS
A VICTIM OF IDENTITY THEFT THEY
NEED TO DEAL WITH THAT AS WELL.
AND THAT'S ANOTHER WORKLOAD
ISSUE FOR EAT EAT EAT WHEN WE
LOOKED- ACT HOW WELL EDT WAS
DOING IN. REVIEWING COMPLAINTS
THAT WERE COMING IN FROM
INDIVIDUALS WHO BELIEVE THEIR
IDENTITY WAS STOLEN AND THEY
WERE WAY BEHIND TYPICALLY THEY
GET ABOUT SIX THOUSAND
COMPLAINTS WE LOOKED AT TWENTY
NINETEEN THEY GOT ABOUT SIX
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS OF IDENTITY
THEFT- AND HAD BEEN WORKING
THROUGH THOSE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. WHEN WE LOOKED ON
DURING THE COURSE OF THE OUT
AND THEY WERE OVER SEVENTY
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS AND THEY
HAD NOT REVIEWED VERY MANY OF
THOSE AT THAT POINT IN TIME SO
THERE ARE A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS
OUT THERE PARTICULARLY TIED TO
YOU. ALTHOUGH THEY MATERIALS
GOING OUT TO THE SUSPICIOUS
ADDRESSES OR GOING TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO NO ONE IN THE
HOUSEHOLD HAS FILED. FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE- AND
THEY'RE SCARED THEY'RE AFRAID
THEY MAY HAVE THEIR IDENTITY
STOLEN- AND THEY'RE- SUBMITTING
INFORMATION ET TO TRY TO GET
THAT CLARIFIED WE ALSO POINT
OUT AND REPORT THEIR MAYBE ON
SOME INDIVIDUALS OUT THERE WHO
AREN'T EVEN AWARE THAT THEIR
IDENTITY HAS BEEN STOLEN THEY
MAY GET SOME. INFORMATION FROM
EDT SAYING HERE'S THE INCOME
YOU RECEIVED UNEMPLOYMENT IN
TWENTY TWENTY YOU NEED TO
REPORT THAT- TO OBVIOUSLY TO
THE IRS- AND INDIVIDUALS ARE
GOING TO BE SHOCKED BY THAT AND
BE REACHING OUT TO EIGHTY SO I
THINK THAT. IDENTITY THEFT
AFFECTS A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA AND I APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE YOUR POINT WITH
RESPECT TO SOME OF THE
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE IN THOSE CROSS MATCHES ARE
LIKELY INDIVIDUALS WHOSE
IDENTITY WAS USED- TO FOR
SOMEONE TO FRAUDULENTLY GET
PAYMENTS. BUT AGAIN THE
IMPORTANCE OF ALL OF THIS IS
EDT NEEDS TO DO THAT CROSSMATCH.
AND HAVE THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE. TO YOU KNOW.
INVESTING THOSE PRETTY SHOULD.
TO DETERMINE. WHICH ONES ARE
FRAUDULENT- AND WHICH ONES THEY
CAN. THEY CAN- YOU KNOW. MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE PROTECTING.
OUR RESULTING IDENTITY THEFT
SITUATIONS FOR KALIFORNIA IS
WHETHER OR NOT. ALL RIGHT TO
MISTER GIBSON. YOU'RE UP TO BAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR. GERMAN
AND ALSO- CHAIRMAN DALY AND
ALSO- FOLLIS- GREAT TO SEE HIM
IS HOW WHEN I WAS A LECTURE SHE
DID A HECK OF A JOB- WITH HER
WORK AS A STATE AUDITOR SO I
HAVE A QUESTION CLARIFYING
QUESTION THIS IS REGARDING A
WHAT I THOUGHT I HEARD WAS IT
EDT THE ONE WHO DIRECTED BANK
OF AMERICA TO PLACE THE WHOLE
OR THE FREEZE ON THESE BANK
ACCOUNTS OR WAS IT BANK OF
AMERICA PUT THAT IN THE FREEZE
ON WHAT THEY BELIEVE WAS
SUSPICIOUS ACCOUNTS. THAT'S MY
FIRST QUESTION. THANK I'LL LET
BOBBY ANSWERED BECAUSE IT'S
LIKE I THINK IT'S A
COMBINATION- MISTER GIBSON.
THEIR WORK OR SOME SITUATIONS
WHERE. THEY WAS COMMUNICATING
TO EDT WE THINK THESE ARE
SUSPICIOUS ACCOUNTS EDT NEED TO
REVIEW THEM AND THEN DIRECT. BE
A BAY TO FREEZE UP ACCOUNTS AND
THERE WAS A LOT OF BACK AND
FORTH. BOB CAN CAN DO A BETTER
JOB THAN I EXPLAINING SOME OF
THE DETAILS FOR YOU. SURE SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT. IF WE
WERE TO LOOK AT ALL BANK
ACCOUNTS THAT ARE. FROZEN OR
HAD BEEN FROZEN THEN IT'S TRUE
THAT SOME OF THOSE WERE FROZEN.
BY BANK OF AMERICA ON THEIR OWN
INITIATIVE. AND OTHERS WERE
FROZEN BY BANK OF AMERICA BUT
AT EDT IS DIRECTION I THINK IS
THE MOST SIMPLE WAY TO BREAK
DOWN. THE TWO POSSIBILITIES THE
THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND THAT WE FOCUS ON. THAT
BANK OF AMERICA FROZEN
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY WAS
DONE AT EDIE'S DIRECTION. WE'RE
TALKING THE REPORT ABOUT THE
LONGER TIMELINE THAT LED UP TO
THAT WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY WAS
BANK OF AMERICA PROTEGER EDT
WITH A LIST OF ACCOUNTS THAT
THEY BELIEVE MIGHT BE. A
FRAUDULENT THEY HAD PEAK FOR
BANK OF AMERICA AS POTENTIALLY
FRAUDULENT ASKED EDT TO REVIEW
THOSE. EDT COMPLETED THAT RUBIO
AND THEN INSTRUCTED. BY BANK OF
AMERICA TO FREEZE SOME BUT NOT
ALL OF THOSE SO THERE WERE SOME
THAT EDT DIDN'T ASK THANK
AMERICA FREEZE. AND THEN ADDED
ADDITIONAL ONES TO THEIR
COMMUNICATIONS WITH BANK OF
AMERICA THAT BANK OF AMERICA
HAD NOT BROUGHT TO EAT IS
ATTENTION THAT ALSO FREEZE FEES
AND THEN IN TOTAL THAT AMOUNTED
TO THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND. WE FOCUS ON THAT
BECAUSE IT WAS THE LARGEST AND
MOST SUBSTANTIVE SET UP. BY
FREEZING THAT OCCURRED DURING
THE PANDEMIC BUT CERTAINLY
THERE BEEN OTHER SMALLER
INSTANCES OF- FEWER NUMBERS OF
ACCOUNTS FROZEN BY BANK OF
AMERICA DEPENDENTLY OR IN
COLLABORATION WITH EDT SO WITH
THAT BEING SAID- IN MY TO
UNDERSTAND THE BANK OF AMERICA-
WHO FROZE AS WELL AS THE-
DIRECTION BY ATV. WHAT HAPPENS
WITH THE INTEREST. WHO GETS THE
ANSWERS. IS THAT INTEREST
RETURNED BACK TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOES THE PEOPLE OF
THAT CALIFORNIA OR IS THAT
INTERESTS. YOU KNOW JUST GONE.
BECAUSE OF THE COUNSELING
FROZEN. I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OKAY MY NEXT
QUESTION WOULD BE- TO STATE
AUDITOR HAVE IN FACT THE EDT
DEPARTMENT- IMPLEMENTED SOME OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OR WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS- THAT YOU
RECOMMENDED HAVE THEY ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED- TO DATE. TO YOUR
KNOWLEDGE. ARE YOU SAYING THAT
THEY HAVEN'T DONE ANY OF THEM
YET ALTHOUGH I WOULD NOT BE
AGREED WITH ALL OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS SO THEY
INDICATED THAT THEY WILL BE
IMPLEMENTING THEM- BUT BASS
DAVE NOT MADE ANY SUBSTANTIVE
PROGRESS TO HAVE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED ANY OF THEM THAT'S
DISHEARTENING TO ME BECAUSE OF
WITH THE WITH ALL THIS **** IS
GOING ON RIGHT NOW WITH THE TV.
TO PUT A BLANK. YOU KNOW THEY
SHOULD BE YOU KNOW JOHNNY ON
THE SPOT TAKING ALL THE STATE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATION. TO
SECURE IT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT PRODUCT IS NOT GOING TO
TAKE PLACE AND PEOPLE ARE NOT
TO BE DISENFRANCHISED. AS A
RESULT OF THEIR BLUNDER LET ME
TELL YOU ABOUT A STORY ABOUT A
MAN NAMED MAY AND THEN A MAN
NAMED. MISTER JOHN HE IS
SLEEPING IN HIS CAR. HE HAS NO
JOB PEOPLE ARE GOING BY GIVING
HIM MONEY JUST TO MAKE ENDS
MEET. AND YOU CAN'T GET RECALLS
BECAUSE THE RETURN CALLS BACK
HE'S NOT GETTING ANY RESPONSE
OR ANY HELP. FROM THE ENTITY
THAT SHOULD BE SUPPORTING HIM.
AND I CANNOT UNDERSTAND WHY.
ARE THESE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
NOT BEING HERE TO BASED ON THE
STATE AUDITOR. ASKING
REQUESTING THESE THESE- THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO BE
IMPLEMENTED THERE'S NO EXCUSE
WE'RE IN A CRISIS AND I'M NOT
DIRECTED TOWARDS YOU. BUT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM STATE
AUDITOR WHO'S DONE A I'M SURE
FOR A FORENSIC JOB CAME UP WITH
HIS RECOMMENDATIONS AT A VERY
PRUDENT MANNER. THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS SHOULD IN FACT
BE IMPLEMENTED AT ONCE. WITHOUT
HESITATION. FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA PISSED OFF AND SO
ARE WE- AND THERE IS NO EXCUSE
FOR THEM NOT TO IMPLEMENT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROTECT THE
PEOPLE OF THAT CALIFORNIA WHO
IS MOST VULNERABLE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. AND IS USABLE IN BY
MARCH. AGAIN IT'S NOT DIRECTED
TOWARD YOU I JUST DON'T KNOW
WHY THEY'RE NOT IMPLEMENT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT'S ALL. IN
MISTER GIBSON ELEVEN
OPPORTUNITY TO. DIRECT THAT-
WELL PLACED QUESTION TO EDT.
JUST THE DOWN THE ROAD A BIT
LATER THIS MORNING- LET'S GO TO
MISS PETRIE-NORRIS AND THEN
MISTER COOPER. MISTER COOPER
HONEST TEAM MEMBER OF THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE SO BY THE
WAY THANK YOU ALL THIS IS A
GREAT ATTENDANCE AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATED. ALL AHEAD MISS
PETRI NOTNG HERE TEAR DALY AND
THANK YOU TO OUR SALAS AS IS
OUR COLLEAGUE INDICATED THIS IS
ONE OF THE NUMBER ONE ISSUES IN
THE RUN CRISES FACING STATE OF
CALIFORNIANS SO MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. I'M SO THANK YOU
TO THE STATE AUDITOR FOR THIS-
VERY THOROUGH IF SOMEONE WERE
FINE I REPORT ON THE AT. THE
NEAR OF FAILINGS AT THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT A COUPLE OF THAT
SPECIFIC FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
SO- AND I THINK YOU'VE HEARD
SOME OF THE FRUSTRATION AND-
JUST THE HORROR ON BEHALF OF
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES ON BEHALF
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS THAT WE
HAVE. LEGITIMATE CONSTITUENTS
WITH LEGITIMATE CLAIMS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO. PUT FOOD ON
THEIR TABLES PAY THEIR RENT AND
MAKE ENDS MEET YET. WE HEAR
REPORTS OF FRAUD THAT EDT HAS
SAID COULD ACTUALLY TOP NOT
JUST TEN BILLION DOLLARS BUT
YOU UP TO TWENTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS- AS SOMEONE WHO'S
WORKED THROUGH THE KIND OF
KAFKA ESQUE. PROCESS OF
IDENTITY VERIFICATION AT THE E.
D. D. WITH HUNDREDS OF
CONSTITUENTS I REALLY DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT. WHAT WAS IT SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND CLAIMS WERE PAID WHEN
THEY COULDN'T VERIFY THE
IDENTITY OF CLAIMANTS. TOTALING.
SEVEN TEN POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS DOLLARS. DO YOU SEE DID
YOU EVER. THE POSSIBILITY THAT
AN INTERNAL INVESTIGATION IS
REQUIRED I'M JUST I GUESS MY
PERSPECTIVE WE JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW SO MANY
LEGITIMATE FOLKS. ARE STILL
WAITING FOR BENEFITS AND IT
SEEMS A REAL REAL EASY FOR
FRAUDSTERS TO GET PAID. RIGHT
SO WE MAKE NO RECOMMENDATION
FOR IT AN INTERNAL
INVESTIGATION YOU SUGGESTED I
WOULD POINT AGAIN TO THE VERY
SLOW. WAY THE EDT REACTED TO
THE INCREASED PROGRESS AT THE
BEGINNING A PANDEMIC AND WE'RE
NOT. POINT DIRECTLY TO- ACTIONS
LIKE THE WAVE TO SAFEGUARD.
THAT LET ONE BILLION OF THAT
TEN POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
BE PAID OUT. N. ET DE DID NOT
HAVE A CONFIRMED IDENTITY SO TO
BE CLEAR THOSE PAYMENTS WERE
MADE. AT A POINT IN TIME WHEN
E. D. WAS NOT SURE. THE ONE
BILLION REPRESENTS THE AMOUNT
PAID TO THOSE. WHO DAY
EVENTUALLY COULD NOT CONFIRM
THE IDENTITY OF STUFF YES IT'S
TROUBLING TO SEE THAT BUT WE
THINK WE'VE INDICATED SOME
PRETTY- MAJOR REASONS WHY BAD
AMOUNT OF. BENEFIT PAYMENTS WAS
ALLOWED TO BE MADE TO
POTENTIALLY FRAUDULENT CLAIMS.
PARENTS HAVE SIR JUST LAST HAVE
OF COMMONSENSE DECISIONS BEING
TAKEN RATHER TAN ANYTHING
NEFARIOUS IN YOUR VIEW. WELL I
THINK WITH RESPECT TO THAT THE
ONE BILLION DOLLAR FIGURE AND
FINDING THAT I JUST TALKED
ABOUT WE ATTRIBUTE THAT TO EDT
NOT HAVING PREPARED IN ADVANCE
TO UNDERSTAND ITS I. T. SYSTEM
AGAIN IT WAS A MISTAKEN BELIEF
THAT. I'VE INTENTIONAL
SAFEGUARD WOULD STOP PAYMENTS
FROM GOING OUT AND THAT WAS
JUST WRONG GOT IT STOP THIS
PAYMENTS FROM GOING OUT. I
DON'T THINK THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT SIR MISTER COOPER EUROPE.
THANK YOU MICHELLE ONE THING
BOTH THE CHAIRS OF THE VERY
QUICK. AND FOR- MISS HOW HER
STAFF YOU GOT ALWAYS DO A GREAT
JOB. OBVIOUSLY THOUGHT IT WAS A
DECADE AGO- ET THE GORE THE
FEDERAL RECOMMENDATIONS AND IF
IGNORE THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS- YOU'RE THE
OVERSIGHT GIVES RECOMMENDATIONS
BUT OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT WORKING
IT HASN'T WORKED. THIS IS NOT
JUST WHAT ADMINISTRATION'S
FAILURE IT'S MULTIPLE
ADMINISTRATIONS THAT GOES ON
AND ON AND ON. THERE'S ALWAYS
CONTINUE SO- OBVIOUSLY THE-
CITY HAS OVERSIGHT BUT- HOW WE
REALLY DEAL WITH THIS AND DRILL
DOWN TO MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN AGAIN. BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY. YOU'RE RECOGNITION
THAT BEEN IGNORED. THE
LEGISLATURE IS BEING ORDERED TO
APPOINT A WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
IN OCTOBER. WE HAVE THE-
BEVERLY HILLS MAYOR THE POLICE
SYSTEM POLICE CHIEF TALK ABOUT
THEIR ISSUES THE MOST THOSE
FOLKS- DOING EASY CARDS WERE
FROM OUT OF STATE. SO HOW WE
ONCE AND FOR ALL. PUT THIS TO
BED JUST WITH PEOPLE AGENCIES
THAT CAN. NO THE LEGISLATURE.
IN GOVERNING. IT REALLY
HAMMERED HOME. WELL THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION MR COOPER- I
THINK ABSOLUTELY SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE'VE MADE TO A
LEGISLATURE TO PUT SOMEOF THIS
SOME OF THESE REQUIREMENTS IN
STATUTE- THE ANNUAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS- FOUR EIGHTY TO
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE NOT
JUST ON FRAUD BUT ON THE CROSS
MATCHING- THERE IS ALSO AN
ANNUAL REPORT YEAH EDT HAVE TO
REPORT TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. HOW WELL IT'S DOING
AS FAR AS GETTING THOSE INITIAL
CLAIMS PAID WITHIN A FOURTEEN
DAY OR TWENTY ONE DAY WINDOW-
AND THAT'S SOMETHING ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS THAT EDT REPORTS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE
ACTUALLY LOOK AT THAT AS PART
OF FEDERAL COMPLIANCE WORK THAT
WE DO. BUT AGAIN THERE'S A LOT
OF STATES THAT STRUGGLE TO DO
THAT I'M NOT TRYING TO MAKE
EXCUSES FOR EDT BUT I DO THINK
SOME OF THE RECESSION PLANNING
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT THE
STRIKE TEAM IDENTIFIED AS FAR
AS WORKLOAD- ANALYSES AND AN
EDT MAKING BETTER DECISIONS AS
TO WHERE THEY CAN ASSIGN THEIR
STAFF WHAT ARE THE PRIORITY
THAT'S WHY WE TRIED TO
PRIORITIZE THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
YEAH BUT WE ALSO TRIED TO POINT
OUT THAT NOT ONLY DOES EDT HAVE
TO DEAL WITH PROCESSING CLAIMS
AS THEY CONTINUE TO COME IN BUT
THEY'VE PUT THEMSELVES IN A
VERY DIFFICULT POSITION NOW
BECAUSE OF THE SUSPENSION OF
THE ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
THE SUSPENSION OF THE DIFFERENT
THEIR CERTIFICATIONS AND US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR CAME DOWN
AND SAID YOU CAN'T DO THAT- SO
THEY HAD TO RE ESTABLISH THOSE
REQUIREMENTS BUT NOW THEY HAVE
THIS ADDITIONAL BACKLOG. OF
MILLIONS OF ISSUES AND MILLIONS
OF CLAIMANTS THAT THEY NOW HAVE
TO ADDRESS AND THEN IN ADDITION
TO THAT THEY HAVE AS I TALKED
ABOUT A FEW MINUTES AGO THE-
IDENTITY THEFT PROBLEM WHERE
THEY HAD OVER SEVENTY THOUSAND
COMPLAINTS R. AS A VICE IT WAS
NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR WHEN WE
WERE LOOKING AT THAT ISSUE SO
EDT REALLY NEEDS TO COME UP
WITH. AND THAT'S PART OF THE
RECESSION LAND PART OF WHAT
SHOULD DO A- AS- WATER ALL OF
OUR WORK. IS YOU ARE ASSESSMENT
AND LET'S FIGURE OUT WHAT HOW
ARE WE GOING TO ASSIGN STAFF TO
BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH ALL OF
THIS. IN THE SHORT TERM BECAUSE
THERE IS AN IMMEDIATE- OUR-
CONCERN AS MISTER GIBSON AND
MANY IF YOU I'M SURE ALL OF
YOUR CONSTITUENTS- THERE'S MANY
PEOPLE OUT THERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE REALLY STRUGGLING- THAT
NEED HELP- SO. I THINK THAT
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE'VE MADE WILL ASSIST
WITH THAT BUT I REALLY THINK
WHAT WE NEED TO DO. AND
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT
IS JUST MONITORING WHAT DO YOU
NEED EDT IS DOING. TO ASSESS
BECAUSE WE TALK ABOUT IN SOME
OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU
NEEDING. YOU GOT IT YOU KNOW
YOU'VE GOT TWELVE MILLION
ISSUES TIED TO TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION. CLAIMANTS BOMB WHERE
YOU PASS JUST THE ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS. DO A RISK
ASSESSMENT OF THOSE YOU KNOW
BASED ON PAST HISTORY. WHICH OF
THOSE TYPICALLY RESULT ARE ARE
A FRAUDULENT CLAIM BEING
SUBMITTED. SO DO THAT RISK
ASSESSMENT SO THAT YOU'RE USING
YOUR RESOURCES. TO THE BEST
POSSIBLE YOU KNOW THE HIGHEST
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES SAME
THING WITH THE CALL CENTER.
WHEN THEY IMPLEMENTED THE
VIRTUAL CALL ABILITY TO HAVE
THEIR THEIR CALL CENTER FOLKS
BE ABLE TO WORK REMOTELY
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC. THEY
LOST SOME OF THE FUNCTIONALITY
THAT THEY HAVE IN THE PHONE
SYSTEM THAT WOULD BENEFIT FOLKS
IMMEDIATE AND THEY HAVE THE
CAPABILITY WITH OUR PHONE
SYSTEM TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
TOOLS. GET THOSE TOOLS
IMPLEMENTED SO I THINK EATING
NEEDS TO COME UP WITH- AND
PERHAPS A DIRECTOR OF TALK
ABOUT IT TODAY AND- AS FAR AS
WHAT THEY'RE WORKING ON. FROM A
STAFFING PERSPECTIVE A WORKLOAD
PERSPECTIVE AND BEING ABLE TO
DO THAT RISK ASSESSMENT
PRIORITIZE. WHAT ARE THE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO DEAL WITH RIGHT
NOW AND WHAT RESOURCES DO WE
HAVE AVAILABLE. TO ADDRESS
THOSE PARTICULAR ISSUES BUT
THEN ALSO JUST CONTINUING TO
MONITOR AS AS BOB INDICATED.
THIS ORDER IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN OUR TRADITIONAL
AUDITS THAT WOULD PUT OUT
NORMALLY IT'S A SIXTY DAY SIX
MONTHS ONE YEAR. RESPONSE TIME
FRAME WE DID DECIDED UNDER THE
EMERGENCY AUTHORITY UNDER J.
LACK BUT I ALSO IDENTIFIED THIS
SITUATION IN CALIFORNIA IS A
HIGH RISK SITUATION SO. WE PARK
WE ARE COMBINED. A COUPLE OF
AUDIT TEAMS UNDER MR HARRIS'S
LEADERSHIP. WHERE WE WERE DOING
WORK UNDER THE EMERGENCY
REQUESTS FROM J. LACK AND THEN
OUR HIGH RISK OF TORY THAT
ALLOWED US TO DO THIS. MORE IN
DEPTH COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS
AND AUDIT. AND WHAT THAT MEANS
WITH RESPECT TO EDT REPORTING
TO US IT'S A IT'S A NINETY DAY
WINDOW SO EVERY NINETY DAYS WE
WILL BE GETTING. REAP REPORTS
BACK FROM EATING. THE OTHER
THING WE CAN DO IS WE CAN ASK
FOR A- MORE FREE. THAN THAT
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE'RE
SUGGESTING YOU HAVE THIS DONE
IN FEBRUARY YOU NEED TO HAVE
THIS DONE IN MARCH SO WHEN WE
HEAR BACK FROM MEETING WE CAN
PARTNER WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND SAY. YOU KNOW WHAT WE TRULY
NEED TO GET THIS DONE BY
FEBRUARY THEY GOT IT DONE OR
THEY DIDN'T GET IT DONE AND
THIS IS WHY THEY DIDN'T GET IT
DONE SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
IS KEPT APPRISED OF. YOU KNOW
EDIE'S PROGRESS NOT ONLY FROM
E. D. THE ADMINISTRATION WHICH
I TRUST THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. BUT USING US AS
YOUR INDEPENDENT SOURCE TO SAY
EDT IS ASSERTING THEY'VE DONE
THESE THINGS WE VERIFIED YEAH
THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS OR THEY'RE
SUGGESTING THEY CAN'T AND THIS
IS WHY. AND WE THINK THAT'S A
REASONABLE EXPLANATION- SO.
JUST TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. ALL RIGHT SIR MR
KILEY YOUR MIKE SIR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISS HOW FOR
THESE- REPORTS YOU KNOW IT'S
INTERESTING TO SEE THAT THE
HAND WRINGING IN THE VENTING-
IN THIS LEGISLATURE ABOUT- THE
EDT IS THAT THERE WERE SOME
EXHAUSTION IS ACTOR WHO'S JUST
SUDDENLY ARRIVED ON THE SCENE-
AND BOARDED OUR WELL LAID PLANS
WHEN IN FACT THIS IS AN ARM OF
THE STATE- THAT'S IMPLEMENTING
POLICIES- PASSWORD LEGISLATURE.
ANDTHAT STAFF IN ACCORDANCE
WITH STATE LAW- SO WHEN I SEE
IN THE REPORT THEY DIDN'T DO
THIS THEY DIDN'T AS THEY DON'T
DO THIS OVER THE COURSE OF
HOWEVER MANY YEARS- YOU KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE ASKED WHY IS
THAT I WANT TO ASK THAT IN A
MORE SPECIFIC WAY. BECAUSE IF
THE AGENCY IS CONSISTENTLY NOT
BEEN FOLLOWING BEST PRACTICES
IN THE WAY THAT A WELL RUN A
PRIVATE ENTERPRISE WOULD I ONLY
SEE TWO POSSIBILITIES ONE IS
THAT THE FOLKS IN MANAGEMENT
ROLES- ARE NOT CAPABLE THEY'RE
NOT COMPETENT THEY'RE NOT
QUALIFIED WHATEVER THE CASE MAY
BE OR THE OTHER POSSIBILITY IS
THAT MAYBE THERE ARE CAPABLE
PEOPLE BUT THERE ARE LEGAL-
BARRIERS SYSTEMIC BARRIERS-
THAT PREVENT THEM FROM MANAGING
THE ORGANIZATION. IN ACCORDANCE
WITH BEST PRACTICES SO BASED
UPON YOUR STUDY OF THIS AGENCY-
WHICH IS IT IS IT THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE POOR PEOPLE POOR
LEDERSHIP AND MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS AT THE AGENCY OR IS
THERE SOMETHING THAT'S GETTING
IN THEIR WAY. OF MANAGING THE
AGENCY WHILE. I'M NOT AWARE OF
ANY STATUTORY LIMITATIONS OR
ANYTHING THAT PRECLUDES EDT
FROM BEING ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE NOW TEN
YEARS AGO WHICH THEY WERE
STARTING TO DO. BUT THEN THEY
THEY DIDN'T FOLLOW THROUGH. SO
I THINK THAT LEADS US TO YOUR
FIRST NOW- OPTION. IS
MANAGEMENT AND I THINK. YOU
KNOW MANAGEMENT HAS A LOT TO DO
WITH IT AT THIS STATE AGENCY MY
STUDENTS MY AGENCY ANY STATE
AGENCY IN CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW
THAT IT'S THERE IT'S THE CLICHE
TERM BUT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
STONE FROM THE TOP. MAKING SURE
THAT- YOU KNOW LEADERSHIP IS
LAYING OUT EXPECTATIONS. FOR
EMPLOYEES IN THAT PARTICULAR
ORGANIZATION- I THINK EDT LIKE
A LOT OF LARGE AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA. IT'S SUCH A HUGE
BUREAUCRACY IT'S DIFFICULT TO
GET THAT TONE FROM THE TOP. YOU
KNOW PUSH DOWN THROUGH ALL OF
THE SECTORS WITHIN THE
ORGANIZATION I THINK. EDT IS
NOT ALONE IN THIS. NOW I'VE
BEEN THE AUDITOR FOR A LONG
TIME THERE ARE A LOT OF STATE
AGENCIES THAT ARE JUST YOU KNOW
ENTRENCHED IN THEIR TRADITIONAL
PROCESSES. THIS IS THE WAY
WE'VE DONE IT THIS IS THE WAY
WE'VE ALWAYS DONE IT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY WE NEED TO
CHANGE. I MEAN SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT EIGHTY THE EMPEROR
THIS YEAR. AUTOMATE USING ID ME
THERE WAS A HUGE CHANGE AS FAR
AS GOING FROM A MANUAL PROCESS
TO VERIFY SOMEBODY'S IDENTITY
WHERE. CLOSE 250% OF PEOPLE
SUBMITTING A CLAIM. THEY HAD TO
GO THROUGH THAT MANUAL PROCESS
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE ID ME
DIDN'T HAVE THAT IN PLACE THEY
PUT ID BE IN PLACE IN OCTOBER.
AND THAT SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE ABLE TO VERIFY THEIR
IDENTITY GET THAT CLAIM EXCEPT
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE PROCESS
BEGIN. SO I THINK. THERE THERE
CERTAINLY IS A NEED AT THE AT
THE HIGHEST LEVELS BUT ALSO TO
BE ABLE TO. YOU KNOW. MAKE IT
CLEAR TO FOLKS AT THE LINE
LEVEL WHO ARE DOING THE WORK ON
A DAILY BASIS THIS IS WHAT WE
EXPECT TO DO WE NEED TO HEAR
FROM YOU WHAT ARE THE ISSUES
YOU'RE YOU'RE RUNNING UP
AGAINST- DO WE PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. ON SOME
OF THE ISSUE RELATED TO
TRAINING- AS BOB SAID YOU KNOW
WHEN WE LOOK AT- EDT TEN YEARS
AGO IT TOOK ON THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN MONTHS TO TRAIN
SOMEONE NOW THEY'RE SAYING WE
STREAMLINED IT DOWN TO NINE.
WELL I THINK THEY NEED TO BE
MORE CREATIVE THAN THAT. DO WE
IS THERE A WAY WE CAN
STREAMLINE THAT EVEN MORE OR DO
AN ANALYSIS OF WHY PEOPLE ARE
CALLING. HAVE THREE RECORDED
INFORMATION ON THEIR ON THEIR
WEBSITE OR ON THEIR IN THEIR
CALL SYSTEM HAVE FREQUENTLY
ASKED QUESTIONS ON THEIR
WEBSITE- THEY RECEIVED A LOT OF
INFORMATION ONLINE THAT THEY
JUST NEVER BOTHERED TO RESPOND
TO BECAUSE IT WELL WE HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM THAT PERSON AGAIN.
SO I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE
SOME STRATEGIC LEADERSHIP- FROM
THE DIRECTOR AND OTHERS. AND I
KNOW THERE'S A- BRAND NEW TEAM
OVER THERE. AND THEY ARE
COMMITTED I WANT TO LET THE
MEMBERS NOW I'VE HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THE DIRECTOR
I'VE HAD CONVERSATION WITH THE
AGENCY SECRETARY- AND SOME OF-THE OTHER. STAFF WERE HIRED
INTO MANAGEMENT POSITIONS AT
EDT AND I THINK THEY UNDERSTAND
THEY CLEARLY UNDERSTAND THE
CRISIS THAT CALIFORNIA IS IN.
BUT I THINK THEY ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS AN
AGENCY. THAT YOU KNOW IT'S KIND
OF EMBEDDED IN OLD BUREAUCRACY
ALL PROCESSES AND WE NEED TO BE
MUCH MORE CREATIVE. AND
APPROVING AS FAR AS USING
AUTOMATION I'M DOING THESE RISK
ASSESSMENTS MAKING SURE WE'RE
DOING A BETTER JOB AS FAR AS-
STAFFING. WHAT ISSUES ARE WE
ADDRESSING FIRST ARE WE GOING
ABOUT PROVIDING STAFF. TO
RESOLVE SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT- WE CERTAINLY IDENTIFIED
IN THE REPORT AND EDS IS WELL
AWARE OF. SO IF OFTEN A POINT
ABOUT HOW IT'S SORT OF THIS
ENTRENCHED- YOU KNOW
BUREAUCRACY THAT SET IN ITS
WAYS SO YEAH LET'S SAY THAT YOU
WERE ABLE TO BRING IN- TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY LIKE TO PICK YOUR
NUMBERS AND I. THE BEST
MANAGERS IN THE PRIVATE. MOST
CAPABLE WHO COMPLETE REPLACE.
THE OPERATION ON OF MANAGEMENT.
WOULD THAT BE ENOUGH TO YOU
THINK GET THE TO RIGHT THE SHIP
WOULD THEY BE ABLE TO DO IT OR
WOULD THERE BE THINGS THAT
STILL STOOD IN THEIR WAY. I'M
I'M NOT AWARE OF THINGS THAT
WOULD STAND IN THEIR WAY BUT I
DO THINK WE NEED TO DO A COUPLE
OF THINGS EDT HUGE AGENCY- AND
I'M NOT TRYING TO MAKE IT CHEAP
BUT IT BUT IT IS A HUGE AGENCY.
AND THEN IT WAS UNPRECEDENTED
BUT WITH ALL THAT SAID. THERE
CLEARLY WERE LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THE LAST RECESSION TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. WHERE YOU KNOW THEY THEY
WERE REALLY PAYING ATTENTION TO
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN
YOU KNOW AFTER A YEAR GOES BY
THEY KIND OF. BACK AWAY AND GET
CAUGHT UP IN THE DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS AND I THINK. SOME OF
THE EXAMPLES WE HAVE IN THE
AUDIT REPORT LIKE WHEN BOB SAID
THAT YOU KNOW THEY THE AGENCY
SECRETARY DIRECTED THEM TO.
HELP BASICALLY SHUT OFF A
SAFEGUARD WELL EDT SHOULD HAVE
DONE ASSESSMENT SAID OKAY BUT
IF WE DO THAT. HERE'S THE COST
BENEFIT WE'RE GONNA GET
PAYMENTS OUT MUCH MORE QUICKLY.
BUT HERE'S THE RISK OF FRAUD.
DO WE REALLY WANT TO DO THAT
AND THERE COULD HAVE BEEN THE
CONVERSATION. WELL YEAH LET'S
DO THAT BUT LET'S MAKE SURE
THESE OTHER FRAUD MANY. FRAUD
TOOLS ARE GOING TO PREVENT
PAYMENTS FROM GOING OUT. AND IT
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IN AND-
TALKING WITH THE AUDIT TEAM
ACTUALLY. SPEAKING WITH THE
AGENCY SECTOR RECENTLY THOSE
TYPES OF CONVERSATIONS WEREN'T
HAPPENING- SO I THINK IF YOU
BRING IN ARE THEY HAVE YOU KNOW
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BROUGHT
IN SOME NEW FOLKS- THAT WILL
MAKE A DIFFERENCE. BUT THIS
ISN'T SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
CHANGE OVERNIGHT I THINK THERE
ARE THINGS THEY CAN DO
IMMEDIATELY- I THINK THEY-
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
WE'LL DO OUR JOB AND HOLDING
THEM ACCOUNTABLE TO IMPLEMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS WILL BE
STEADFAST WITH THAT- AND I
THINK THAT'S- THE BEST I CAN
GIVE YOU AT THIS POINT MR
KILEY. AGAIN I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION ALSO FOR THE
DEPARTMENT- AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ANSWER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AS MY FINAL
COMMENT YOU KNOW- WE SEE THIS
ISSUE AS YOU NOTED ACROSS
DIFFERENT AGENCIES IS NOT JUST
THE MEDIA THIS IS CERTAINLY
BECOME THE POSTER CHILD FOR.
AFTER GOVERNMENT FAILURE- AND
SO IF THE PROBLEM REALLY IS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT
PEOPLE. IN MANAGEMENT ROLES
THEN I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
RAISES THE QUESTION. OF HOW DO
WE IMPROVE THAT PROCESS SO THAT
WE CAN ATTRACT THE BEST AND
BRIGHTEST INTO THESE POSITIONS-
OF SUCH POWER. AT THAT HAVE SO
MUCH INFLUENCE OVER THE LIVES.
OF PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS HERE WHICH ARE
GREAT IS A GOOD RECOMMENDATION
YOU PROVIDED BUT- EVEN SOME OF
THE ONES TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
SOME SENSE A BLUR THE LINE
BETWEEN POLICY AND MANAGEMENT.
AND I THINK THAT PERHAPS WOULD
BE BETTER SERVED IF WE LOOK AT
THE OVER ARCHING POLICIES. THAT
ARE DETERMINING. WHO WINDS UP
LEADING THESE STAY AGENCIES AN
WE FIX THE- SO THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE. WHO HAVE GOOD MANAGEMENT
EXPERIENCE WILL BRING THE BEST
PRACTICES OF THE PRIVATE SECTOR
IN THE GOVERNMENT. THEN YOU
KNOW WE WOULDN'T NEED TO KEEP
HAVING AUDITS LIKE THIS WITH
THE HORRIFYING FINDINGS THAT
THEY MAKE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MR KILEY- I HAVE ONE QUESTION
FOR STATE AUDITOR AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO OUR NEXT PANEL
WHICH INCLUDES AN EARLY BUT TO
I'M SORRY I'M SO I DIDN'T SEE
YOUR YOUR MY COAT SENATOR LEYVA
GO AHEAD CHECK GO AHEAD PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF MADAM
AUDITOR I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU YOURS TO SUCH A
THOROUGH REPORT IN YOUR- YOUR
IDEAS TO MOVE FORWARD ARE
ALWAYS JUST COMPLETELY DIRECT
AND VERY EASY TO UNDERSTAND. MY
QUESTION KIND OF GOES BACK TO
THE LAST RECESSION WHEN YOU
SAID THAT A LOT OF THESE ISSUES
AROSE THEN MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY- EBV WAS ACTUALLY
TRANSITIONING TO A BETTER-
SYSTEM BUT THEY HAD TO STOP
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC SO THEY
WERE FORCED TO USE THE
ANTIQUATED SYSTEM I WAS JUST
CURIOUS IF YOU KNEW IF THAT WAS
TRUE. AND IF THERE BE ANY WAY
THEY COULD GO BACK TO WORKING
TO GET TO THAT. MORE
STREAMLINED SYSTEM. OKAY IF.
THANK YOU SIR IF YOU'RE
REFERRING TO THE BENEFIT
SYSTEMS MODERNIZATION PROJECT
WHICH IS I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO THERE. SO EDT PUT
THAT PROJECT ON PAUSE AT AFTER
THE STRIKE TEAM RECOMMENDED
THAT THEY DO SO. AND REALLY
OUR- RECOMMENDATIONS EDT FOR
HOW TO MOVE FORWARD FROM HERE.
I THINK WHERE YOU'RE QUESTIONS
WAS HEADING IN THE STRIKING
RECOMMENDATION THEY'RE VERY
THEY'RE VERY SIMILAR IT'S JUST
BREAKING CREDIT- EATING TO.
TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT THAT
BENEFIT SYSTEMS MODERNIZATION
PROJECT IS A LARGE IT PROJECT
WASN'T SCHEDULED TO BE
COMPLETED FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
STILL. AND THEY NEED TO SEE
WHAT CAN NAY. REMOVE FROM THAT
LARGER PROJECT AND GET DONE IN
A COMPONENT BASIS IN THE MORE
SHORT TERM THAT WOULD BE
PROVIDE THE MOST IMMEDIATE
BENEFIT TO. CLAIMANTS AND TO
EDIE'S ON STAFF SO WE'RE
RECOMMENDING THAT THEY DO THAT
ANALYSIS SO THAT THEY KNOW.
HERE ARE THE PARTS OF THIS
LARGER SCALE IT PROJECT THAT
WASN'T GOING TO BE DONE FOR
YEARS STILL. THERE WE CAN
IMPLEMENT NOW THAT WOULD HAVE
THE MOST DIRECT BENEFIT FROM
THE MOST IMMEDIATE TERM TO
CALIFORNIA. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE SENATOR I DID SEE
YOUR MIKE. AND I SEE A MIKE IN
THE BACK THERE WITH THE MEMBER
COOLEY GO AHEAD SIR. COLLEAGUES
I JUST WANT TO JUMP AND I THINK
THIS IS A TREMENDOUS HEARING
ELAINE VERY EXCELLENT JOB AS
USUAL- OBVIOUSLY THIS IS THIS
RAISES UP THE ISSUE OF
OVERSIGHT AND AGGRESSIVE
OVERSIGHT BY THE LEGISLATURE.
AND I THINK WE ARE GOING TO
RIDE THE WAVE OF OVERSIGHT IS A
BODY INTO THE FUTURE. IN THE
PAST WERE THE LEADING BODY OF
OVERSIGHT IN THIS CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT. TO THE MOST AUGUST
SENATORS IN THE ROOM WITH ME- I
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT WHILE WE
FOCUS ON THE TVAND THE
SPECIFIC THIS. I WANT TO URGE
ALL TO TAKE A LOOK AT
GOVERNMENT CODE. THIRTEEN FOUR
HUNDRED AND THE FOLLOWING. THAT
IS ACTUALLY THE STATE
LEADERSHIP ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
AND THIS IS A BODY OF LAW THAT
HAS ACTUALLY SEEN A LOT OF
ACTIVITY IN THE LAST. TEN YEARS.
AND GOING BACK TO TWENTY ELEVEN
WAS. A STRAIGHTENER THE STATUTE
IN TERMS OF ACCOUNTABILITY
AUDITS AND FINANCIAL AUDITS. TO
ADDRESS FRAUD. AND OF THE END
OF THE PRIOR GOVERNOR THERE WAS
MOVEMENT TO MODIFY THAT. I
THINK YOU'RE FOR SOME FIRST
PRINCIPLES OF GOOD GOVERNMENTAL
ACCOUNTING. THAT WE WILL FIND
IF WE GO BACK TO THE STATUTE AS
EXISTED BACK. WHEN WE WERE
SWORN IN REFER NOW THE CLASS OF
TWENTY TWELVE. AND I THINK THIS
OF. IT IS A MORE FUNDAMENTAL
ISSUE EVEN THE EDT IS IMPORTANT
AS YOU DO THESE OPERATIONS ARE.
LIKE HOW DO YOU RAISE THE BAR
ACROSS ALL STATE AGENCY FOR A
HIGH LEVEL OF ACTIVITY AND HOW
TO WE IS LEGISLATURE FORTY
SENATORS TO FORWARD. AND I WANT
TO AGAIN CALL ATTENTION TO THAT
ACT GOVERNMENT CODE THIRTEEN
FOUR HUNDRED- OF THE LEADERSHIP
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT I THINK IS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT THIS. AND I
SPECIFICALLY WOULD. SAY WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE STATE OF THE
LAW AS IT EXISTED UPON THE-
SIGNED INTO LAW BY GOVERNOR
BROWN OF SB. SIX ONE SEVEN-
WHICH WAS A BI PARTISAN
MOVEMENT THE SPEAKER AT THE
TIME THE PRO TEM OF THE TIME
FOR BALL THE DRAFTING OF THAT-
I THINK WE'LL WANT TO LOOK AT
THAT I NEED TO GET ON A RULES
CONNECTED MATTER FOR
POLTERGEIST. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR COOLEY. I HAVE ONE
QUESTION OF THE STATE AUDITOR
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO OUR PANEL
WITH. LABOR AND BUSINESS
REPRESENTED- THERE'S A MENTION
OF A CONFIDENTIAL LETTER
PROVIDED DVD. MENTION IN THE
CAN YOU AT LEAST GIVE US. A
HINT OF WHAT TOPIC THAT
INVOLVES THIS CONFIDENTIAL
LETTER- THERE'S A VARIETY OF
ISSUES THAT WE IDENTIFIED
DURING THE COURSE OF THE AUDIT.
TIED TO- IDENTITY. I CAN'T GET
INTO A LOT OF SPECIFICS THAT'S
WHY WE SHARED THE INFORMATION
WITH THE NEEDY IN A
CONFIDENTIAL MANNER- JUST SO
YOU KNOW MISTER DALY I DID
SHARE THAT SAME LETTER WITH
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP. AS WELL
AS THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR OF
THE AUDIT COMMITTEE SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE A COPY
OF THAT LETTER EDT OF COURSE IN
A AT AN AGENCY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE KNOWS THAT I
SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE- BUT BEYOND THAT.
MR DALY AYE I WOULD BE
UNCOMFORTABLE DISCUSSING IN
DETAIL ANYTHING IN THAT LETTER-
BECAUSE WE FEEL THAT WE
IDENTIFIED SOME THINGS THAT IF
WE HAD PUT IT IN A PUBLIC
DOCUMENT WOULD EXPOSE THE STATE
TO POTENTIALLY- MORE FRAUDULENT
SITUATION SO- INFORMATION IN
THERE THAT IS IMPORTANT. FOR
EDT TO ADDRESS IMMEDIATELY BUT
I DID SHARE IT WITH. THEM
LEADERSHIP- YOU KNOW BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE AS WELL AS THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR OF THE
AUDIT COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- AND THEN WE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND WHY IT'S LABELLED
CONFIDENTIAL ON THE OTHER HAND
WE DON'T WANT TO BE. A BLIND
SIDED- HERE IN THE COMING
WEEKS- BASED ON THE EXPERIENCE
WITH THE DD- IT'S- THE WORD
TRUST IS NOT TO NOT TO.
PARAMOUNT MISTER SALAS TELLS ME
HE HAS BEEN IN THE LOOP ON
THIS- AS THE CHAIR OF THE JOINT
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE SO THAT DATA IS VERY
APPROPRIATE. AND- APPRECIATE
YOUR ANSWER MICELLE I THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH YOU'RE
PROTESTING DALY. YEAH AND I DID
COMMUNICATE WITH MISTER SALAS
THAT THERE WAS THE POTENTIAL
FOR THIS TYPE OF COMMUNICATION
AND CLEARLY WE YOU KNOW WE
WANTED TO SHARE IT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE WE WANT
THE INTEGRATION TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES BUT WE FELT NOW I WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE FEEL LIKE
I'M A PARTNER WITH- THE
LEGISLATURE SO- WE LIMITED I
TALKED TO MY CHIEF COUNSEL AND
NOW WE FELT THAT SHARING IT
WITH LEADERSHIP WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT- THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR OF THE AUDIT COMMITTEE-
AND CERTAINLY- AS WE HAVE DONE
IN THE PAST. IT'S THE
DISCRETION OF THE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WANT TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION WITH OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT WE
CAN'T THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
WE SHARE THE LETTER WITH IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO ASK YOU KNOW
LEADERSHIP CLEARLY VERY
IMPORTANT AND THE COMMITTEE
THAT I REPORT TO THE AUDIT
COMMITTEE- SO BUT- IMPORTANT.
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION NEEDS
TO DEAL WITH. IMMEDIATELY.
AGAIN THANK YOU N- YOUR
HANDLING OF SENSITIVE ISSUES-
AS USUAL IS A HIGHLY
PROFESSIONAL AND I CERTAINLY
RESPECT TO THE WAY YOU HANDLED
THIS ENTIRE ABOVE AUDITS AND
ANY OF THE CONFIDENTIAL ASPECTS
THAT WERE ASPECTS YOU'VE CHOSEN
TO MAKE CONFIDENTIAL I TOTALLY
RESPECT AND UNDERSTAND YOUR
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT. SO WITH
THAT LET ME IT IT'S GONE TO THE
THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK YOU
GOOD GOOD- OUR NEXT PANEL
INCLUDES THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND- I HOPE
THAT THE THOSE- TWO INDIVIDUALS
ARE TEED UP AND READY TO GO
MISTER EDUARDO MARTINEZ. THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FED- IS THE
FIRST PARTICIPANT ON THAT NEXT
PANEL ARE YOU WITH US MISTER
MARTINEZ. YEAH YES SIR CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES BEAUTIFUL YEAH
PLEASE GO AHEAD SIR. OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH- AND THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
OF THESE COMMITTEES FOR
ALLOWING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY- MY NAME'S
EDUARDO MARTINEZ SOME
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION. WE
REPRESENT OVER ONE POINT TWO
MILLION WORKERS IN OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED AFFILIATED UNIONS. BUT
GIVEN OUR CHARGE TO ADVOCATE
FOR ALL WORKERS ORGANIZED AND
NOT WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE AND
WELCOME THIS OPPORTUNITY IN
CONVERSATION ABOUT WAYS TO
STRENGTHEN CRITICAL SOCIAL
INSURANCE PROGRAM. TO BE CLEAR
WE COME TO THIS CONVERSATION
NOT SIMPLY TO FOCUS ON AN OVER
BURDENED AND UNDER RESOURCE
DEPARTMENT. WERE HOPING THIS
NEWFOUND FOCUS ON UNEMLOYMENT
INSURANCE CAN BE THE CATALYST
FOR A LARGER SYSTEMIC CHANGE TO
BETTER SERVE CALIFORNIA WORKERS.
THE STATE AUDITOR'S REPORTS
LAID BARE WHAT MANY OF US
ALREADY KNEW. WEAKNESS IN
CLAIMS PROCESSING WORKLOAD
MANAGEMENT AND INADEQUATE
STAFFING AT CALL CENTERS.
CONTRIBUTED TO MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS GOING WITHOUT
BASIC EIGHT. ACCORDING TO
LATEST JOB NUMBERS DESPITE
RECENT POSITIVE JOB GROWTH
NEARLY ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
REMAIN OUT OF WORK COMPARED TO
THIS TIME A YEAR AGO. AND
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO THE
FAILURE TO IMPLEMENT A POSSIBLE
FRAUD PREVENTION SYSTEMS
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE AUDITOR'S
SECOND REPORT MANY LEGITIMATE
CLAIMS HAVE BEEN FROZEN OR MADE
INACCESSIBLE ONE BIT
POTENTIALLY BILLIONS OF PROJECT
PAYMENTS HAVE BEEN ISSUED. FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE WE BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD FOCUS ON
ADDRESSING EDT WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES. TO ENSURE THE
DEPARTMENT IS PREPARED TO MEET
THE CHALLENGE OF FUTURE
RECESSIONS. ALTHOUGH THIS
RECESSION WAS MUCH MORE SAID IN
AN UNPRECEDENTED SCOPE. AS THE
AUDITOR FOUND TO REPORT THE
ONSET OF THIS PANDEMIC WAS NOT
THE FIRST TIME HE DDS FAILED ME
TO SOUTH COAST CALL CENTER
BENCHMARKS. THIS IS LIKELY TO
PERSIST UNLESS MORE STRUCTURAL
FORMS ARE MADE HOW EDS FUND.
WHEN TIMES ARE GOOD IN THE
EMPLOYMENT REYES LOW INDUCED
NEEDED TO COMMUNITY RECEIVES
LESS FUNDING FOR STAFFING
RESULTIN IT BEING UNPREPARED
WHEN A RECESSION. HITS AND
WORKERS NEED ACCESS TO THE
SYSTEM. WELL TYPICAL RESEARCH
CAL OUT FIRST ADDRESS. TO MEET
IN INCREASING CLAIMS. OBVIOUSLY
COVER NINETEEN AND THEY BE
COVERED NINETEEN INDUCED
RECESSION PROVIDED NO SUCH LEAD
TIME. BEYOND THE NEED TO INVEST
IN INFRASTRUCTURE BOTH PEOPLE
AND SYSTEMS- WE BELIEVE THE EDT
CAN MAKE BETTER USE OF ITS
EXISTING PARTNERSHIPS TO HELP
ADVOCATE APPLICANTS NAVIGATE
AND ACCESS THE SYSTEM. FOR
EXAMPLE THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION PARTNERS WITH EDT TO
PROVIDE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES TO WORKERS ORGANIZE
AND NOT. WHO HAVE BEEN
SEPARATED FROM WORK. THROUGH
THE USE OF VIRTUAL WEBINARS AND
ACCESS TO EDT STAFF WE ESTIMATE
THAT OUR STAFF HAS BEEN ABLE TO
DIRECTLY ASSIST OVER THREE
THOUSAND WORKERS YOUR ACCESS
YOU AYE BENEFITS OR OTHER TOP
RESOURCE. AND I COULD JUST TAKE
A QUICK MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
ALL OF THE STAFF DOING THIS
CRITICAL WORK UP PARTICULARLY
AGREE LEGISLATIVE STAFF. I'M
SURE YOUR STAFF TO SHARE WITH
YOU HOW DIFFICULT THIS WORK IS
A GIVEN THE VOLUME OF CONTACTS
AND THE FREQUENT INABILITY. FOR
STAFF OUTSIDE OF THE TV. EDT TO
RESOLVE CASES. AS WE CONTINUE
TO WORK TO MODERNIZE OUR YOU I
SYSTEM WE WOULD ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
TO CREATE STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY
COMMITTEES TO OVERSEE THE NEW
SYSTEM IMPLEMENTATION. I WAS
OTHER STATES HAVE MODERNIZE
THEIR SYSTEMS THESE COMMITTEES
HAVE HELPED IDENTIFY ISSUES
REACHING HARD TO REACH
COMMUNITIES. AND FINALLY AS YOU
CONSIDER POLICY CHANGES WE
WOULD STRONGLY URGE MEMBERS TO
CONSULT WITH THE PDP WORKFORCE
AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE THESE
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANTS WILL
BE KEEN IDENTIFYING
EFFICIENCIES AND IMPLEMENTED
NEEDED SOLUTION. NOW OBVIOUSLY
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TECHNOLOGICAL CHALLENGES.
HOWEVER FROM OUR POINT OF VIEW
THESE PROBLEMS COULD BE
RESOLVED AND YET THE U. I.
SYSTEM WOULD STILL BE PLAGUED
BY TWO EVEN MORE SERIOUS
CONDITIONS. GROSS BENEFIT
INADEQUACY AND PERSISTENT AND
COSTLY PERIOD OF YOU I FIND
INSULTS. JUST A LITTLE
BACKGROUND CALIFORNIA'S YOU I
SYSTEM HAS BEEN CHRONICALLY
UNDERFUNDED SINCE THE EARLY
NINETEEN EIGHTIES WHERE THIS-
SYSTEMS FUNDING OUR SYSTEM WAS
CHANGED UNDER WHICH IN GOOD
ECONOMIC TIMES THE U. I FIND
ACCUMULATED RESEARCH TO SEE IT
THROUGH TO- SESSION. TO ADD UP
TO A PAY AS YOU GO SYSTEM AS A
RESULT OF THIS CHANGE OUR SPACE
YOU I FIND HAS NEEDED TO BORROW
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. TO
BE SURE THESE LOANS ARE PAID
BACK OVER THE YEARS BY
EMPLOYERS FOR GOING THEIR
NORMAL FEDERAL TAX CREDITS BUT
THE INTEREST ON THESE LOANS
AMOUNTING TO OVER ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
FROM THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
RECESSION ALONE. COME FROM CAL
TACK. BE A THE GENERAL FUND.
THE ADOPTION OF THIS PAGE YOU
GO TO THE SYSTEM AND THE
FAILURE OF ANY FUNDING FIXES TO
BE ENACTED HAS LED US TO THE
POINT WHERE THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR. THANK
CALIFORNIA'S YOU I FIND DEAD
LAST AMONG ALL STATES.
MEANWHILE CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF
THE LOWEST WAGE REPLACEMENT
RATES IN THE COUNTRY AVERAGING
ABOUT 26% OF THE WORKERS
CURRENT. TWENTY SEVEN STATES
INCLUDING OUR NEIGHBORS IN
NEVADA OREGON AND WASHINGTON
PAY HIGHER MAXIMUM WEEKLY
BENEFIT. TWENTY EIGHT STATES
PAY HIGHER MINIMUM WEEKLY
BENEFITS. TWENTY NINE STATES
PLUS THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA
VIRGIN ISLANDS PUERTO RICO PAY
HIGHER AVERAGE WEEKLY BENEFITS.
UNLIKE CALIFORNIA THIRTEEN
STATES PROVIDE PROVIDE
DEPENDENT ALLOWANCE. ALMOST
HALF THE STATE'S INDEX THEIR
BENEFITS TO KEEP UP WITH
INFLATION. HOWEVER WE DO NOT.
JUST OPPOSE OUR STATE YOU AYE
SYSTEM TO THAT OF ONE OF OUR
NEIGHBORS ND WE CAN SEE WHAT'S
POSSIBLE. JUST LAST WEEK DURING
THE HEIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC
WASHINGTON STATE PASSED
LEGISLATION THAT NOT ONLY
REDUCES TAXES ON EMPLOYERS BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY INCREASES-
INCREASES THE MINIMUM BENEFIT
AWARDS AND EXPAND THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT EMPLOYERS
CAN ACCESS YOUR BENEFITS. WELL
WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
FOCUS TODAY ON THE MEDIA ISSUES
IDENTIFIED IN THE STATE AUDITS
WE HOPE THE LEGISLATURE WILL
LOOK AT THE SYSTEM
HOLISTICALLY. THE REALITY IS
OUR STATE YOUR SYSTEM HAS BEEN
FALLING SHORT FOR WORKERS FOR
DECADES AND MUCH MORE WORK
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO STRENGTHEN
THIS CRITICAL SOCIAL INSURANCE
PROGRAM I CALIFORNIANS DEPEND
ON. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
JACK. THANK YOU MISTER
MARTINEZ. AND- LET'S GO NOW TO
IN IN MISTER MARTINEZ IF YOU
COULD- IT'LL LINGER A BIT AND
CAISTOR QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS. BUT NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM MR ROBERT MOULTRIE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IS A POLICY ADVOCATE THERE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD SIR- GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE HERE THANK YOU
WE CALL THIS NUMBER FOR A LONG
OVER HEARING ON WILL- AND NEED
ALL OF THE- LET ME NEXT QUARTER
OUR NOT. WITH WHAT ONLY ONE TO
THEM IF WE OUR DO THAT IT'S THE
KIND OF WORKERS EXPLAINED NEXT-
SO WHAT SURPRISED. SOMEONE WHO
KNEW- MARC LEVINE ABOUT FIVE
FUNDING RIGHT WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER THE FALL- AND I WRITE ON
THE BRICK WALL AND PEOPLE LAUGH
WORKING. FOR SO THE FIRST THAT
IN BONTA ARE- YES NOTED- YOU
ARE ALREADY SPONSORED BY YOUR
IN QUESTION ON WHAT OKAY HOW
MUCH OF PROJECT THE NEW LAW-
THE STATE'S LAW ON THE FEDERAL.
E. RATE MONIQUE LIMON HOUSEHOLD.
ON SUNDAY. THERE WE PULL SO CAN
ONLY HE SAID THAT HE SOMEWHERE
AROUND ON WATER OR WILL BE WHAT
MORE CENTER. ALL THE STATE LAW-
THIS CLEARLY. IT MAY BE YOUR
MIKE- THE TECHNICIANS HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER. SAY WE
HAVE THE VOLUME TURNED UP TO
THE MAXIMUM. IF YOU COULD MAYBE
GET CLOSER TO YOUR MIND OR
ADJUSTED SOMEHOW- YES LET ME
TRY TO SPEAK MORE AND MORE
ALLOW GOOD THAT'S IT'S ALREADY
BETTER THANK YOU OKAY APOLOGIES
I- I GET EXCITED. SO THESE
SMALL DOWN AND TRY TO MAKE- SO
SPEAKING ABOUT ARE THE SOURCE
OF THE PROJECT WE'RE KIND OF
WE'RE THE PRODUCT MAKING MODEL
BOB I HAVE FOUND CALIFORNIANS.
OR UP FROM THE FEDERAL BENEFITS
HI IF YOU'RE AROUND FIVE
PERCENT. EIGHTY MIGHT FIVE
FORTY FIVE THEIR PASSCODES LAST
MONDAY MEMBERS AND ALTHOUGH
WHAT. IS A MEDICARE- THE
QUESTION 85% 5% WHAT NUMBER.
BROADLY SPEAKING ON HAPPY JUST
TEN BILLION WHILE ESTIMATE
WHICH I FOR TO THE MORE MINUTES
NOT HAVE ONE SEVEN. NOT AND
THEN WE ARE REPORT NUMBER IS
LIKELY LAW. RECENT ALSO NOTES
THAT THE UMBER A LOT OF I
DIDN'T MEET MUCH THE- SEVENTY.
OF PREVENT WITH THE THEIR ALL
BROUGHT. THAT MEANS THAT ARE
NUMBER. SOME BETWEEN. AND. IT'S
STILL A LITTLE MUDDLED- SO. TRY
TO ADJUST IT ONE MORE TIME.
YEAH YOU JUST ONE MOMENT. AND
IF NOT I MAY CALL IN. WHAT WAS.
CALLING. YOU SEE YOU MAY CALL
IN OR YOU WILL CALL. IS CALLING
IN NOW OKAY.
A CONSIDERING ALL
THE LOGISTICS- THESE HEARINGS
ACTUALLY GO QUITE WELL. I KNOW
OUR STAFF DOES ITS- DOES THEIR
BEST. HOW ABOUT NOW OKAY. YES
IT'S BETTER. OKAY I'M FOR ALL
THE TROUBLE EVERYONE'S- WE WILL
NOW TRY TO MOVE QUICKLY AND
CLEARLY- GIVEN THAT I'M ALREADY
A LITTLE OVER TIME- SO BANKING
OF COURSE THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUDITOR FOR YOUR WORK I'M I'D
LIKE TO START OUT WITH- KIND OF
FOCUSING ON A P. THAT WASN'T
COVERED- AT IN OUR COMMON
PREVIOUSLY WHICH RELATE TO WHAT
THE FRAUD MEANS TO THE HEALTH
OF THE FUN AND KIND OF WHAT
HAPPENED NEXT. YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS PAY FOR
THE HEALTH OF THE FUNDS AND SO
THAT YOU CAN WILL START WITH-
AND I'LL BE READING THAT THE
MAP HERE ON THE DATA FROM THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT AS WELL AS
DATA RELEASED BY EDT LAST
MONDAY IN THEIR PRESS RELEASE
THAT IS A MORE UP TO DATE
NUMBER- SO PUTTING IT NUMBERS
TOGETHER- THE AUDITOR AND HE
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT ABOUT 5% OF
THE KNOWN FRAUD- IS. THE TRIVIA
OF. THE DAY YOU Y. CON- AND HAD
TAKEN THEIR- THE FOR- BIGNOT
THERE'S LESS MORE BROAD IT NOT
YET BEEN FULLY IDENTIFY- JIM
FACT. IF YOU NEED TO A TELLER
COMMON EARLIER IF IT. WILL WE
WOULD CALL. FRAUD WHERE IT'D
BEEN DEATH BROUGHT BUT OF
COURSE IT HAD ALL BEEN TRACKED
DOWN YET- ET FLAG LAST MONTH
THAT A- 70% OF THEIR BENEFIT-
DISTRIBUTED WHICH- MAY ALSO BE
A PROBLEM. THAT WOULD MEAN THAT
THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF FRAUD WOULD
BE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TEN AND
THIRTY BILLION DEPENDING ON
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THAT
ADDITIONAL 17% OF BENEFITS- I
TUNING THAT 5% OF THOSE ARE
ATTRIBUTABLE THANK YOU I FIND
THAT MEAN FOR LOOKING AT-
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION AND ONE POINT FIVE.
BILLION IN FRAUD APPLICABLE TO
THE STATE YOU Y. FUND. WHICH
THAT EMPLOYERS WILL BE- PAYING
BACK OVER THE NEXT TWENTY FIVE
YEARS- DEPENDING ON HOW LONG IT
TAKES TO GET OUT. SO THAT'LL BE
THAT'LL BE THE EXTENT THE MATH
SO. APOLOGIES FOR LEADING UP
WITH THAT BUT THAT NEEDED TO
THE NEXT QUESTION. WHAT
HAPPENED IN TERMS OF RECOVERING
THAT- I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
HERE- A NOTE FROM THE AUTHORS-
JANUARY TWENTY SIXTH REPORT.
WHICH WAS THAT THIS PRODUCT
WILL BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
RECOVER FROM. THANK YOU NEED TO
RECOVER FROM THE CLAIM- TRUE
FRAUDSTERS RIGHT UTILIZED OTHER
IDENTITY WILL BE DIFFICULT TO
TRACK DOWN. AND EVEN IF THE
PROJECT CAN BE TRACKED DOWN
THEY LIKELY WILL BE HOLDING THE
FUNDS- YOU KNOW OF COURSE WE
APPRECIATED THE PROPERTY TOIL
EFFORTS TO KIND OF PURSUE THEM.
BUT AT THE AUDITOR'S REPORT NO
THE SCALE OF THE AFTER. THE
FALL- ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE
SMALLER THAN THE PRODUCT WE'RE
TALKING BOUT- I BELIEVE
PREDICATED. FILED A SEARCH
ABOUT THIRTY MILLION. IN BROAD
SO AT TO BE RECOUP THAT THIRTY
MILLION VERSUS. YOU KNOW FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION TO A BILLION OR
MORE- SO GIVEN THAT THOSE
RECOVERY EFFORTS ARE VERY
LIMITED RIGHT THE NEXT QUESTION
HAD BECOME. WHAT HAPPENED NEXT-
THE AUDITOR'S REPORT DEALS WITH
THIS WLL AND BLACK THIS YOU
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS WITH WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT. OBVIOUSLY CAN HAVE TAX
IMPLICATIONS IF YOU'RE
RECEIVING BENEFITS BE
RADICALLY. BUT NOT ACTUALLY
RECEIVED THEM YOU MAKE IT TAX
FROM OR YOU MAY BE UNABLE TO
CLAIM THE FUTURE. AND OBVIOUSLY
ALL OF THOSE CASES ARE ON
ACCEPTED- AND THE POINT THAT
I'M HERE IF. THE THING APPLY TO
HELP EMPLOYERS IT'S- WHICH IS
TAKEN FROM THE FUND. WILL HAVE
ONGOING TAX IMPLICATIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS AS WELL
FOR THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS. AND
OBVIOUSLY AT JEFF AS INDIVIDUAL
CLAIMANTS. WHO THAT GUARANTEES
WERE STOLEN HAD NO CONTROL AND
SHOULD BEAR NO PUNISHMENT FOR
THAT. I'M CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS
ALSO HAVE NO CONTROL AND WE
WOULD DAY SHOULD. BEAR NO
PUNISHMENT. BROUGHT I. LOOKING
FOR I LIKE TO A HIGHER AND THE
AUTHOR FOR NUMBER DIRECTLY FOR
TO THAT RIGHT- RECOGNITION
RECOMMENDATIONS BY AND IN THE
JANUARY TENTY EIGHT REPORT.
THAT WAS IT CENTER TRACKING-
TOOLS TO REVIEW BROUGHT AND
PURSUING ONGOING AND NOW WHICH
TOOLS ARE AFFECTED- AND REPORT
OUT THE LEGISLATURE AND OTHERS
CAN BE AWARE OF THAT AND
EXERCISE OVERSIGHT WE SUPPORT
ALL OF THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS-
AND BELIEVE THEY'RE NECESSARY-
YOU KNOW LOOKING BACKWARD HOW
DO WE WHAT CAN WE DO TO IMPROVE
THAT RECOVERY RATE SOME PLAYERS
ARE LEFT OUT OF HERE RIGHT- ONE
POINT I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT OF
COURSE IF YOU HAVE MONEY RIGHT
MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- YOU KNOW MONEY TO
REPLENISH THE FUND WOULD HELP.
TO MAKE THIS FRAUD NOT HIT THE
COMMUNITY AT MUCH AND HOPEFULLY
WILL BE BETTER LEGISLATION
ADDRESSING HIM- BUT ONE ELEMENT
OF POTENTIALLY IMPROVING
RECOVERY- THE AUDIT REPORT NOTE
THAT THERE IS A LIMITED TIME
LINE FOR E. D. TO- TO SEEK TO
RECOVER- FRAUDULENT PAYMENT-
AND GO TO PROVIDE NOTIFICATION
THANK YOU THE FRAUDULENT CLAIM
IS THAT THERE MAY HAVE BEEN
CORRECT. YOU KNOW WE WOULD
REQUEST THE DATE IN THE CAN BE
DONE TO EIGHT THOSE RECOVERY
EFFORTS- SHOULD BE DONE AND IT
MAY TAKE THE FORM OF EXTENDING
THE TIMELINE FOR EDT TO PROP
THAT REDEVELOPMENT YOU IDENTIFY
THAT AND YOU RECOVER THAT ANY
EFFORTS THAT AFFECTS WOULD BE
HELPFUL FONG FROM THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY FREE OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE EMPLOYERS WHO ARE GOING
TO END UP IN A BATTLE HERE-
WITH. THE RESPONSIBILITY- FELL
OFF UP THERE APOLOGY THE TECH.
ISSUE AND HOPEFUL- THEY WITH
AUDIBLE WILL BACK OUT OF PHONE.
TO YOU MISTER MO. AND- YEAH
AFTER YOU FIX- AFTER THE FIXING
YOUR PHONE CALL IT WAS MUCH
MUCH EASIER TO UNDERSTAND. YOUR
COMMENTS- MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO
EITHER MR MOULTRIE FROM THE
CHAMBER OR MISTER MARTINEZ.
FROM LABOR FED ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISTER CELLS DO YOU
HAVE THEM THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- JUST A QUICK
QUESTION I THINK YOU GUYS FOR
DISCUSSING THE IMPACTS OF THE
U. I. FRONT. BUT WOULDBE
INTERESTED QUICKLY IF YOU CAN.
IF YOU COULD WHICH SAFEGUARDS
THAT DO YOU THINK SHOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE UAAP YOU AYE
PROGRAM- THAT WERE NEITHER
LISTED IN THE- THE AUDIT
REPORT- THUS FAR THANK YOU.
I'LL GO FIRST IF THAT'S OKAY-
OF THE SECTOR- THAT MISTER
SALAS AYE AYE- WOULD BE- WOULD
HESITATE TO OFFER SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS ON IT ARE OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS THAT THAT
REPRESENT THE BEST WORKFORCE-
ARE GOING TO BE REALLY KEY I
THINK TO- EXAMINEE POTENTIAL-
OPPORTUNITIES FOR. SYSTEMS
IMPROVEMENT SO I WOULD JUST
REALLY STRONGLY ENCOURAGE ANY
MEMBER THAT'S THAT'S LOOKING AT
THIS AUDIT AS POTENTIAL
LEGISLATIVE- JUMPING OFF POINT.
TO BRING THEM TO BRING THEM TO
BRING THEM IN EARLY AND. OFTEN-
TO TALK ABOUT. AND THEN I DON'T
KNOW IF MISTER MUTRIE WAS.
TRYING TO CHINA. GO AHEAD MR
MOTRIN. OKAY THANK YOU I THINK
I'VE BEEN UNDEFEATED CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW YES YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU PERFECT. SO THE PACO MISTER
MARTINEZ A COMMENT I WOULD NOT
FEEL PROPERTY GET AHEAD AT THE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATION. I
THINK THE AUDITOR IS GONE
THROUGH IN FLAG MOST OF THE
ISSUES I THINK. ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUE- HAS. ALREADY THE
RESULTS WOULD AGREE WITH THE
WHOLE THING IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY OF SOME OF THE
EXPANSION OF CRITICAL
VALIDATION ARGUMENT ELIGIBILITY
VALIDATION. SO THAT THAT WHOLE
THING IS A HUGE IMPROVEMENT NOW
GOING FORWARD WHICH AFRICA
WHICH SPECIFIC PROGRAMS THEY
MUST HELPFUL I THINK. OBVIOUSLY
ONLINE PROMPTING IN KEY BUT I.
I WOULDN'T WANT TO GET AHEAD
AND GO BEYOND THE AUTHOR'S
STATEMENT BECAUSE I WOULD.
REALLY NOT BE IN MY PROPER
PLACE. I ALL RIGHT A- THANK YOU
FOR PARTICIPATING- BOTH MR
MOULTRIE AND MISTER MARTINEZ
AND- PLEASE- HELP A REMAIN
FOCUSED ON ON THIS SUBJECT IN
THE WE WELCOME ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS- FROM EITHER OF YOUR
ORGANIZATION'S. ON THIS MATTER.
AND- LET'S NOW GO TO THE- TO
THE LAST PANEL THE LAST OF
PORTION OF OUR HEARING WHICH IS
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. WHICH IS NOW LED BY
MISTER REDA SIGNS WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF EDT MISSILES
MISSILES ARE YOU WITH US. YES I
AM SIR BEAUTIFUL OF. PLEASE GO
AHEAD THE I HOPE YOU WERE ABLE
TO- FOLLOW THE EARLIER PARTS OF
THIS HEARING AND TO HEAR SOME
OF THE GIVE AND TAKE AMONG THE
LEGISLATORS- AND THE STATE
AUDITOR AND NOW WE WELCOME YOUR-
YOUR COMMENTS ON THE SUBJECT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
AND- I WANT TO SAY. OBVIOUSLY
WHAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY IS VERY
SOBERING. YEAH ARE YOU A NEW
EXECUTIVE TEAM TAKE ALL OF
THESE TAX RECOMMENDATIONS
SERIOUSLY. I'M READY TO SIGN ON
THE RECORD OF EMPLOYMENT THE
NEW DIRECTOR OF EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US HERE TODAY TO
PROVIDE INPUT ON THE DEPARTMENT
IGNITION PARTS THE CUSTOMER
SERVICE RELATED TO E. D. AND
I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON THE NEEDS
ARE THREE. DURING A BACKLOG THE
CALL CENTER. PREVENTION EFFORTS
INDEED HE HASN'T. AS YOU THE
EXACT THE AUDITORS WERE. IT'S
OUR INTENTION TWO WEEKS WATERS
OF THE DEPART. WE TO THE STRIKE
RECOMMEND. ARCTIC'S REPORT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS WE HAVE WILL
PREFER HOW TO MOVE AHEAD. WITH
ME R. EDT EXECUTORS EXECUTIVE
G. YES CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR POLICY REGISTRATION
EXTERNAL PARTNERS. OUR REAL
NEWS CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
OPERATIONS. AND KEVIN MATTER.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS. THE NEW CONTACT WITH
THE WORK STAFF OVER THIS PERIOD
OF TIME. AFTER THE PANEL WE'RE
GOING TO ANSWER ANY OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS QUESTIONS
LIKE I'VE MADE SOME NOTES HERE
THAT ARE- HAPPENED COULD YOU
MIGHT JUST WANT. BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH THE UPDATES HOWEVER
I'D LIKE TO SHARE SOME OF MY
BACKGROUND. INFORMOVAL CALL OF
DUTY. I STARTED WITH A DVD IN
JANUARY I HAVE OVER FORTY YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE LEADERSHIP IN
BOTH THE PUBLIC AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR'S REVENUE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN NINETEEN.
BENEFITS PROGRAMS AND ALSO
FAMILIAR WITH CALL CENTER
OPERATIONS. WHAT DEPARTMENT
WHICH I HAVE SERVED AS
DIRECTOR- COULD BE MEETING WITH
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. I HAVE USED THIS
FIRST ONE TO GET TO KNOW WHAT
OUR CHANGES ARE IN THIS AREA
THEY ARE MAYBE. I MEAN I HAVE
ALL THE ANSWERS TO YOUR
QUESTIONS TODAY BOB GENER
COMMITTED TO GETTING THE PUBLIC
ANSWERS. I HAVE THREE
PRIORITIES. ANY MOMENT GETTING
CREDITS. PREVENTING FRAUD AND
RESTRUCTURING THE DEPARTMENT TO
BE EFFECTIVE. BONTA TAXABLE
CUSTOMER SERVICE CAPABILITIES.
AS YOU HEARD GOING INTO THE
PANDEMIC OF FEBRUARY. ANY
TWENTY WE HAD A HISTORICALLY
LOW UNEMPLOYMENT RATE OF THREE
POINT 9% THE RATE MOST
DRAMATICALLY 255% IN APRIL. AND
CLICK ON THE PERFORMANCE
BENEFITS SERGEANTS 13100% OVER
THAT SAME TIME FRAME. WE
EXPERIENCE LEVEL FIVE TIMES
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS TWENTY
TWENTY AS WE SAW IN TWENTY TEN
THE WORST YEAR OF THE GROUP
RECESSION. PROCESSED AS MANY
CLAIMS THE FIRST FOUR WEEKS OF
A PANDEMIC AS WE GET IT ALL FOR
TWENTY TEN. THE HISTORIC DEMAND
HAS NATIONWIDE OF CALIFORNIA
BEING THE MOST POPULOUS STATE
HAS BEEN HIT THE HARDEST. WOW
PROCESS ONE IN FACT THE
NATION'S UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS.
THIS FAR EXCEEDS THE VOLUME HEY
OUT OF ANY OTHER STATE
INCLUDING TAXES AND MARK HI.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE SEEN PROC
WHAT RATHER DEPRESSED EIGHTY
PLUS SYSTEMS I DIDN'T. WHICH
PROVIDES IDENTITY CHECKS FOR
FOURTEEN STATE ESTIMATES THAT
35% OF ALL. THANKS HARPER. WE
TO ARTISTS WHOSE LAST WEEK
IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF
DECISIONS THAT ARE HAVING A
SIGNIFICANT DOWNSTREAM AFFECT
ON THE DEPARTMENT. BECAUSE YOU
GET ECONOMIC ACTIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND IT JUST KIND
OF LOW FEDERAL BENEFITS
PROGRAMS. DEPARTMENT DECISIONS
DECIDE. WHEN TO HAVE THE
CUSTOMER STATE. THE NOW WE HAVE
TO ADDRESS THAT WORK ON
COULDN'T PASS THE CHEN. HER
BROTHER'S CENTER APARTMENT
CERTIFICATION. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO. YEAH GOING TO CALIFORNIA
WORKERS OKAY WAS BENEFITS OUT
OF THE HANDS OF CRIMINALS WHO
SEEK TO PROTECTING MY SISTER.
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE. WATCH THE VIDEO WERE TO
REMIND YOU THAT WHEN YOU SHUT
THE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS.
WERE ALREADY MAKING CHANGES TO
OUR SERVICE TO OUR CUSTOMERS
AND IMPROVE OUR ABILITY TO
FIGHT ONCE LET HER CRY. OUR
SYSTEM. I'M CALM. THAT IN THE-
RECOMMENDATIONS WILL FIND
SOLUTIONS TO PROBLEMS. AT THE
BOTTOM OF THIS ONCE IN A
LIFETIME PANDEMIC AND A
CHANGING ECONOMIC RECESSION IT
HAS COST. I HAVE WORKED IN THE
PUBLIC AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
I HAVE ENCOUNTERED SERIOUS
PROBLEMS IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS
DURING MY TIME GOVERNMENT. AND
FEES ARE FIXABLE. THERE ARE
PROBLEMS AS SOME OF THE MEMBERS
OFFICES PRACTICES AND
TECHNOLOGY. ONE OF THE AREAS OF
FOCUS FOR WARWICKSHIRE WAS THE
DEPARTMENT'S UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CLAIMS ACROSS. IN
SEPTEMBER BEATING STRIKE TEAM
WORKS FOR FINAL REPORT WITH THE
CATEGORIZATION. OF THE CLAIMS
BACKLOG. RESTRICTION RAY. THE
CREATION OF TWO. ONE MITCHELL
CRIMES. CONTINUE CLAIMS. WHICH
REFLECT THESE CATEGORIES
REFLECT FIGURES TO THE FIRST
PAYMENT OR FOR THE PAYMENTS AT
THE PAST TWENTY ONE DAYS. AT
THAT TIME ET EXISTING BACKLOG
OF ONE POINT SIX. CLAIMANTS
APARTMENT COMMITTED TO CLEAR
THIS INVENTORY BY THE END OF
JANUARY TWENTY ONE. PUBLISHED
FEBRUARY AS OF FEBRUARY SECOND
THEY ARE ALL COMPLETE.
CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY TO
RECOMMENDATION BECAUSE HE
CHANGES TO OUR CORPORATE TAX
BOARDS. WHAT ACTUALLY ACTUALLY
ACCURATELY CAPTURE WORK THAT IS
PRETTY ACTION RATHER THAN.
TRANSACTION WHOLEHEARTEDLY
AGREE WITH THIS RECOMMENDATION
FROM CARTER TO MORE ACCURATELY
REFLECT BLACKROCK. AS OF
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH
APPROXIMATELY NINETY ONE
PERCENT. MORE THAN NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND HE CLAIMS REFLECTED ON
THE TO CORRECT BACKLOG
DASHBOARDS COMPANIES TWO
CATEGORIES THIS IS 91% WAITING
FOR CLEARANCE CERTIFICATION. A
CATEGORY IN THE CURRENT
POSITION STASHED WHAT ARE THE
POTENTIAL OVERPAYMENTS WHICH IS
A SUBSET OF RESOLVING I WOULD
UTILITY ISSUES CATEGORY ON THE
CONTINUED CLICKS DASHBOARD.
BOTH OF THESE REQUIRE CREE
REDUCTION. IN AGREEMENT WITH
THE STATE AUDITOR YOU DO YOU
WILL BETTER REFLECT THAT
REFLECTS WHAT HE PROCLAIMS TO
CERTIFY WE WILL CONTINUE OUR
WHICH TO OUR CLAIMANTS MISS
REQUIREMENTS. THREE WELL IT
ABILITY REGISTRY CHOIR. FOR EDG
CAN PAVE THE FIRST PART THEIR
PAYMENTS EVERY TWO WEEKS. THIS
THIS CATEGORY DOES NOT REFLECT
EDT WORK REGISTERED TO PAYMENT.
YOU WILL ALSO REMOVE A
POTENTIAL PAPER EXECUTED
CONTROL OVER PAYMENT DATA THIS
WORK BY EIGHTEEN THIS IS WORK
RIGHT LEADING TO ASSESS WHETHER
OR NOT INDIVIDUALS HAVE
RECEIVED MORE BENEFITS FROM
QUALIFY FOR AND IT DOES. NOT
TRIGGER EIGHT. MOST OF THE
REMAINING 9% BETTER REFLECTED
TO DASH BOARD BACKLOGS ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE EFFORTS
TO IMPLEMENT NEW- PACKED
EVERYTHING FROM ASSIST AND
ENDEMIC EMERGENCY COMPENSATION
WHICH WERE SIGNED INTO LAW IN
DECEMBER. ALL OF THE MAJOR DATA
ELEMENTS ARE BEING CONSIDERED
CONSOLIDATED ENGINE ONE WAS
DIFFERENT DATA PASSPORT SHOWS
TRENDS OVER THE PAD. WHAT
INDICATE THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS
WAITING LONGER THANTWENTY ONE
DAYS FOR PAYMENT BECAUSE OF THE
CELEBRATIONS. THAT NEW TABLEAU
STYLE DASH FOR SCARE GET FROM
THIS MONTH. THE COST. THE WATER
OUT A NUMBER OF ISSUES RELATED
TO OUR CALL CENTERS LOCAL BUT
STAFF ARE NOT ABLE TO ANSWERING
THE CALLS HOURS AND NOT RECEIVE
FIRST CALL RESOLUTION. REGISTER
COLLECTING AND SUFFICIENT DATA.
INCREASE THE CALL CENTERS
OVERALL WE CAN SEE. THE
DEPARTMENT IS TAKING ACTIONS TO
ADDRESS THIS COURT. PERFORMANCE
THESE INCLUDE AN EARLY GRADE.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BRANCH
COMMAND CENTER PROVISION TO
MANAGE ALL CALL CENTER
RECOMMENDATIONS OKAY CALL
CENTER OPERATIONS. I MUST SAY
THAT THE COME FROM THE PRIVATE
SECTOR IN MY EXPERIENCE AND
SOME OF THE DEPARTMENTS OF
THOSE UNITS OF CHRIST- A
DIFFICULT. TO STOP THE CALL
CENTERS HAPPEN. TO OUT OF A TO
THESE PEOPLE HARD TO GET.
QUINCY ASSIST THEY NEED. BY
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE ET NO
I SERVICE AUCTION DATA TRUMP OF
THE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE. THIS
WILL INCLUDE MORE SELF SERVICE
AND OUR CALL OPTIONS AND THOSE
OF YOU WHO HAVE HAD EXPERIENCE
WITH CONSTITUTIONAL THIS IS
REALLY VERY CRITICAL- ADDITION
TO THE CALL CENTER. BACK SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN- ACTUALLY
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE THINGS
THEMSELVES. AND THE
IDENTIFICATION OF SPECIALISED
TRAINING STAFF TO BETTER ASSIST
CALLS WE HAVE INITIATED OUR
CRITICAL WORK TO ACCELERATE THE
SUPPORT CALL CENTER AND I'M
MEETING WITH HIM TOMORROW. BORN
MAY TWENTY TWENTY ONE EDT FOR
STAFFORDSHIRE POLICY TRACKER-
FIRST CALL RESOLUTION DATA.
BETWEEN MAY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
OR TWENTY TWENTY ONE. EDT WILL
GOOGLE TOOLS PROCESSES TO
COLLECT FIRST CALL RESOLUTION
DATA. TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE WILL
CONTINUE DEPARTMENT WHAT THE
CALL CENTER. PROVIDING
EFFECTIVE ASSISTANCE TO COLLEGE
STUDENTS TO THE STATE. WE ARE
ALSO WORKING TO REESTABLISH THE
CALL BACK FEATURE FOR THE RULES
WHICH WILL CALL CENTER PLATFORM
SOON AS POSSIBLE. THIS WILL
ALLOW CONGRESS TO REQUEST A
CALLBACK FROM JUDGE INSTEAD OF
WAITING ON HOLD FOR ASSISTANCE
OR HUMAN NEED TO CALL.
CONTINUED DURING THE DAY. WHERE
HIRING NINE HUNDRED MORE STAFF
THIS MONTH. THE STAFF MUST BE
TRAINED BY THE ON YOUR WELL AND
NEED THESE COMPLEX RULES THEY
WILL BENEFIT FROM THE KNOWLEDGE
MANAGEMENT TOOLS OF DEPARTMENTS
USING. THIS TOOL PROVIDES
TRAINING ARTICLES WHAT
PROGRAMMERS INSTRUCTIONS FROM
THE TRAINING MANUAL CHILL
SEARCHABLE DATABASE. JEAN
REPORTER OF A STANDARD INDUSTRY.
THIS ALLOWS OUR WORST ACTIONS
KEYWORD SEARCHES TO FIND IN
THIS TOOL TO FIND RELEVANT
INFORMATION THAT CAN READILY TO
A CUSTOMER WHO HAS A SPECIFIC
QUESTION. MAXIMIZE THE SINGLE
CALL RESOLUTION. WE HAVE BEEN
RECEIVING THREE FORMER RECALLS
A WEEK. WORKGROUP REVIEW OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE CHANGES
WE ARE COMMITTED TO ATTAINING
INDUSTRY BEST PRACTICES. YOUR
EXCEL OR ANY CHANGES WHEREVER
WE CAN AS OUR CURRENT CUSTOMER
SERVICES ARE SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE. THESE
IMPROVEMENTS MUST OCCUR SWIFTLY
SILVA CUSTOMERS CAN FEEL
CHANGES WHEN THEY CALL IT WILL
TO GET THEIR QUESTIONS ANSWERED
AFTER A SINGLE ATTEMPT. HELLO
WE ADDRESS OUR FRAUD AND FRAUD
PREVENTION. ANOTHER AREA WHERE
HE WITH ALREADY RECONSTRUCT
CENTERED ON EACH FRAUD
PREVENTION EFFORTS. BETWEEN
MARCH TWENTY FORTY AND JANUARY
SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
DEPARTMENT PROCESS NINE SHE
FIVE CLAIMS EIGHT OVER A
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN BENEFITS. FOR SOME
PERSPECTIVE AT THE HEIGHT OF
THE GREAT RECESSION CHEN
CALIFORNIA PROCESS JUST OVER
THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION
CRIMES THAT NEAR. THE MASSIVE
CASELOAD AND REPRESENTS THE
NUMBERS OF RECORD MEMBERS OF
THE GERMAN CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
UNABLE TO WORK BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. WE ALSO REPRESENT A
SOPHISTICATED ORGANIZED CRIME
SUBCOMMITTEE FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
TO COLLECT BENEFITS. USING
STOLEN IDENTITIES ACCURATE
INFORMATION. WELCOME TO DETECT
FRAUD PREVENTION MEASURES IN
PLACE WHAT SORT OF THE POINT
THEY WILL DEFINITELY SUFFICIENT.
UNPRECEDENTED VOLUME OF CLAIMS
FOR SOPHISTICATED NATURE OF
MYSTICAL TRANSACTION OF PRIME
ORGANIZATIONS. ARMS JUST CAN'T
WILL PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE
BENEFITS JOINT DIFFERENT GROUP
OF WORKERS DEPARTMENT HIGH
STREET HAS STARTED PROVIDING
BENEFITS FOR. WE HAVE HEARD ME
IDENTIFIED ABOUT 10% OF A
HUNDRED FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN BENEFITS. WHICH
WHICH EXTRA PROP. ELEVEN
BILLION WAS PAID TO FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS. CALIFORNIA'S CONFIRMED
PROJECT FRAUDULENT PAYMENT 95%
ARE ASSOCIATED THE PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
WHICH THE US DEPARTMENT RIVER
PREVIOUSLY NOTED WAS
SUSCEPTIBLE TO FRAUD. WHILE THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION FEDERAL
MINISTRATION PROBLEMS SUPPORT
STATE PARTY ORGANIZED CRIMINAL
ATTACKS ON GREENPOINT SYSTEMS
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO HAVING
A PARKING. PARDON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND WE'RE THANKFUL
TO LEADERS LIKE SENATOR
FEINSTEIN SENATOR PER. WE'LL
SEE FOR CALLING SUPPORT PRESS.
WE ARE ALSO INVESTIGATING
ANOTHER ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN CLAIMS THAT MAYBE
FRAUDULENT AS I GET A HARPER
PRODUCTS CLEANING TOOLS. NEWS
CLAIMS OF THE PARKS INCREMENTS
WERE ASKED TO IDENTIFY YOUR
IDENTITY OR ELIGIBILITY. JUST
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION CLAIMS.
JUST OVER THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND THESE WORKERS ABSENCE
CONCURRED BY IRAQI. NOW HAS
SYSTEMS IN PLACE THAT WILL STOP
BY THE DOOR NINETY WHAT IMPACT
VOLUME OF CLAIMS THAT ARE
SUBMITTED. SOMETHING YOU MIGHT
NOT HAVE HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT.
ALSO PROJECT CHIEF
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY BILLION
CHANGED HANDS WHICH IS EXISTING
AND MCCARTY TRACTION RIVERS
MEASURES- PERMITTED CAN CONTROL
SOME. OF THESE MEASURES INCLUDE
ID. TOP OF WRITERS FOR WE NEED
FOR. ASSISTANCE WITH CALIFORNIA
CYBER SECURITY EDUCATION CENTER
FOR HER MENTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES TASK FORCE TO
INVESTIGATE BURDEN HOLD
CRIMINALS ACCOUNTABLE WE ARE
COMPETING WITH A MEMBER OF
LOCAL INTERNET A. HUNDRED
THIRTY A LAST SECOND. AND WE
HAVE CREATE A NEW FRAUD.
IDENTITY WE SUSPENDED THE
AUTOMATIC BACKING AWAY CLAIMS
WHEN THEY SPIKED HARVEST WHICH
STRUCK DOWN HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF POTENTIAL
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS. BETWEEN
OCTOBER AND DECEMBER TWENTY
FOUR IDEA LOW ESCORTING OVER
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND FRAUDULENT ATTEMPTS TO
FILE A CLAIM. ACCORDING TO IDB
APPROXIMATELY 35% OF
APPLICATIONS SUBMITTED ACROSS
THE NATION HAVE BEEN FRAUDULENT.
THE DEPARTMENT IS ALSO IN THE
PROCESS OF HIRING A PART EXPECT
TO PROVIDE CONSULTATION
SERVICES AS WE FURTHER
STRENGTHEN OUR BROKERAGE. WELL
EIGHTY DEAN HAS MADE PROGRESS
IN THIS AREA. THERE IS STILL
MUCH WORK TO DO. MY PRIORITY IS
TO KEEP. OUT OF THE HANDS OF
CRIMINALS INTO THE HANDS OF
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS WE ARE
NOT DOING NOW AS GOOD A JOB AS
WE SHOULD. BUT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE CHANGED. BEFORE I CONCLUDE I
WANT TO THANK THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR ENERGY OR
PROFESSIONALISM ROB WATER
CRISIS. WE ARE EAGER TO SEE THE
BENEFITS YOURS BY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND
IMPROVEMENT. IN THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS. I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE EXTRAORDINARY
STAFF AT THE DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT WILL
CONTINUE TO SERVE OUR CUSTOMERS
AS THEY NAVIGATE THIS
CHALLENGING TIME. I WAS SO
APPRECIATIVE. OF THEIR
DEDICATION TO THEIR WORK
ESPECIALLY IS THIS PANDEMIC HAS
CONTINUED. ON CREATED CASH FLOW
PRESSURES IN THEIR LIVES AND
THE LIVES OF OUR CUSTOMERS. I
WOULD ALSO BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T HAVE THANK MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND WERE STOCK
MARKET CRITICAL PARTNER IN
SOLVING CONSTITUENTS CLAIM
SHE'S CHEN PROMOTION. REPUBLIC
THERE'S A LOT TO DO. AS I SAID
I'VE SEEN OUR PROBLEMS LIKE
THIS IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND
I'M CONFIDENT THAT THEY CAN BE
FIXED. I THINK THAT A LOT OF
THE REMARKS MADE BY BOTH PANELS
ARE GOING TO BE VERY USEFUL TO
US. LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE AUDITOR.
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE. I THANK
YOU MISS THANK YOU MISS SIGNS-
AND THE NUMBER OF LEGISLATORS.
HAVE SOME FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
FOR YOU- IMPORTANTLY I BELIEVE
I HEARD YOU SAY THAT YOU INTEND
TO FULLY COMPLY WITH THE
SCHEDULE. OF FIXES THAT HAVE
BEEN REQUESTED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR BOTH SUGGESTED AND
REQUESTED BY THE STATE AUDITOR
SO IT'S GOOD TO KNOW THAT YOU
INTEND TO COMPLY- WITH THE
SCHEDULED IT'S BEEN LAID OUT-
THE A AND I KNOW MY DISTRICT
STAFF WHO HAVE. PERSONALLY
HANDLED OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
CONSTITUENTS. ISSUES WHERE
CITIZENS CALL MY LOCAL OFFICE
TO GET ANSWERS THAT THEY'VE
BEEN UNABLE TO GET FROM E. D.
D. AND IF YOU MULTIPLY THAT BY.
EIGHTY ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT'S
UPWARDS OF A- SIXTY THOUSAND OR
SO IF WE EXTRAPOLATE- CITIZENS.
CAN'T GET ANSWERS TO COULD NOT
GET ANSWERS FROM EDT AND HAVE
TO CALL THEIR LOCAL STATE
ASSEMBLY PERSON FOR ASSISTANCE-
IT'S GOOD TO KNOW THAT YOU ARE
MOVING- IN LINE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ACCOMPLISH
THOSE FIXES ACCORDING TO THAT
SCHEDULE. NOW WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE START WITH MISTER GLAZER
BECAUSE HE'S ON THE- THE WEBEX-
SYSTEM MISTER GLAZER CAN YOU
HEAR. I CAN HEAR EACH YEAR DALY
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YEAH PLEASE
GO AHEAD SIR. YEAH THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU TAKE CARE
SALAS- COMMITTEE FOR HAVING
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING. I
CERTAINLY I SHARE IN THE
COMMENTS. WRONG COMMENTS AND
EMOTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED BY MY LEGISLATIVE
COLLEAGUES SAID IN THE COURSE
OF THE HEARING- MISS SIGNS I
APPRECIATE YOUR STEPPING INTO
THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT PLACE
I KNOW OF YOUR BACKGROUND OF
COURSE. EXPERIENCE THAT YOU
BRING TO YOU- ALL THAT YOU THAT
DILUTES THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR. SHAPE THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN WILLING TO STEP IN AND
HELP IN THIS IMPORTANT TIME I
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT YOU'RE
NEEDED THE JOB AND THAT THAT.
YOUR ABILITY TO- UNDER THE HOOD
IN ATLANTA COMPREHENSIVE WAY
HAS BEEN LIMITED THAT'S FAR-
BUT I DO WANT TO ASK YOU ONE
IMPORTANT QUESTION MAYBE YOU
CAN ANSWER TODAY. IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO IN THE
LEGISLATURE. TO HELP YOU DO
YOUR WORK BETTER. YOU HAVE ALL
THE TOOLS THAT YOU NEED ARE
THERE LIMITATIONS BY STATUTE OR
BY RESOURCES THAT WE- CAN BE
BETTER PARTNERS WITH YOU- AND
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING YOU
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS- WELL WE HAVE A
LOT OF CRITICISM. AND CONCERN
AS EXPRESSED IN THE AUDIT- WE
ARE ALSO- HERE TO BE HELPFUL
AND CONSTRUCTIVE THE OTHER
THINGS THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MENTION TODAY. MY EXPERIENCE IN
SPEAKING TO DIFFERENT
LEGISLATORS OVER THIS MONTH.
VERIFICATION SOME HOPE IT WILL
BE ABLE TO FORM A VERY POSITIVE
PARTNERSHIP. MISTAKES HAVE BEEN
MADE. TO BE RECTIFIED. SO.
RIGHT NOW I WANT TO FINISH UP
WITH CONSTRUCTING AN AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS. THAT WILL GIVE
ME A CLEARER VIEW DEEPER DOWN
OF WHAT NEEDS WHAT ELSE NEEDS
TO BE FIXED YOU CAN BE SURE
YOU'RE FARMING IDENTIFY
ANYTHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN HELP. I WILL COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE I WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT ARE ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS I DID WHEN THEY RAMMED
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES MR YOU YOU ALL WHEELS
AND REGULATIONS. DR WE HAVE TO
FOLLOW IN ORDER TO TAKE CARE OF
RECIPIENTS PRESSURES OF
POSSIBLE. CHILDREN WORKING WITH.
I DISCOVERED IN. HOW THE HAS
HAVE A NEED. ALSO READ THE HAVE
NOT BEEN REVIEWED FOR A YEARS.
SO IT WOULD NOT BE SURPRISING
THAT SOME OF THE BUSINESS
PRACTICES IN THE TECHNOLOGY
HAVE NOT KEPT UP- THERE. BOB
I'D LIKE TO A PART OF WHAT MR
MARTINEZ SAID ABOUT IT'S NOT
JUST THE TECHNOLOGY AND THE
BUSINESS PROCESSES THERE
THERE'S SOMETHING UNDERLINE
THAT WE NEED TO GET TO WHAT YOU
D. TELECHARGER HERE'S OUR DRIVE
FOR MODERNIZATION THERE IS
ALREADY A DRIVE JUST SERVE
CLAIMS. SO OUR FOLKS HAVE BEEN
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK TO
WORK TO TRY TO RECTIFY THIS
PROBLEM. THAT HAS BEEN CREATED
SO. THANK YOU FOR THE OPERATING
YES I PROMISE- SENATOR GLAZERS.
SHOULD SOMETHING COME UP THAT I
FEEL THE LEGISLATURE COULD BE
HELPFUL AND I WILL MOST
CERTAINLY- COMMUNIST. THANK YOU
MISS SITES AND JUST IN CLOSING
TO OUR WONDERFUL CHAIR DALY AND
SALAS- I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'VE
CONFIRMED THEIR WILLINGNESS TO-
MAKE THESE IMPROVEMENTS AND TO
BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEM I WOULD
ASK. FOR YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP IN GETTING CLEAR
TIMELINES THEIR TIMELINES AND
BENCHMARKS FOR THE PROGRESS OF
THAT WE CAN BE- KEPT CLOSELY
INFORMED. OF THOSE ACTIONS AS
THE DAYS AND WEEKS AHEAD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SENATOR GLAZERS- SHARE
SALAS- HAS SOME FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS FOR MATH SCIENCE GO
AHEAD SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
DALY- THE SIGN THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS AND WITH YOUR HISTORY.
OF COMING AND STATE AGENCIES
AND HELP FIX PROBLEMS- PREVIEW
CHU TESTIFYING LAST WEEK AS
WELL- AND BUDGET SUB FOR. AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU SAID THIS
WEEK. IN TODAY'S HEARING NOT
ONLY. BEING ACCEPTING OF THE
AUDIT RECOMMENDATIONS BUT ALSO
LOOKING AT TRYING TO REFORM.
THE EDT AND MAKING SURE THAT
CLAIMANTS GET PAID. WITH THAT
BEING SAID IN AND YOUR FOLLOW
UP TO THE SENATORS QUESTIONS IN
TERMS OF. LOOKING TO ENGAGE THE
LEGISLATURE IN ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTING SOME OF THESE
REFORMS ARE A NUMBER OF
LEGISLATORS THAT HAVE
INTRODUCED MYSELF INCLUDED
AMONG THEM- PROPOSALS TO
ACTUALLY HELP OR FOR ME TO DO
SO THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT. MAKE
SURE THAT THE FRUSTRATION THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE FEELING.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I GET
ADDRESSED AND GET ADDRESSED IN
A TIMELY MANNER ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE HEAR FROM THE AUDITOR AND
THE FIRST PANEL WHERE SOME OF
THESE ISSUES THAT. HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED FOR OVER A DECADE-
SO WITH THAT I JUST WANT TO
ASK- THE SIGNS IN YOUR TEAM.
ABOUT THE WORKLOAD AND WHETHER
YOU DD IS PREPARED. TO MOVE
FORWARD YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
CALL CENTER AND HIRING AND I
BELIEVE YOU SAID NINETY THREE
MORE STAFF THIS MONTH- BUT-
WHEN I LOOKED AT THE AUDIENCE
YOU KNOW WE FOUND THAT THE EDT
IS. FACING AN IMPENDING
WORKLOAD- STEMMING FROM TWELVE
POINT SEVEN MILLION ELIGIBILITY
ISSUES- THIS COULD HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT CONSEQUENCE OF
UPWARDS OF TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION CLAIMANTS- WHEN THE
OTHER LOOKED AT IT SHE SAID- IT
HER REPORTED INDICATED THAT
WOULD. NECESSITATE NEARLY THREE
MILLION HOURS TO SORT THROUGH
THESE ELIGIBILITY ISSUES SO THE
QUESTION IS WHAT IS THE DUTIES
PLAN AND TIMEFRAME FOR TACKLING.
THIS IMPENDING WORKLOAD. WELL
WE ARE HIRING I HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL STAFF THIS MONTH.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
SURPRISED ME WHEN I CAME INTO
THE DEPARTMENT IS THE AMOUNT OF
WORK THAT REQUIRES THE- MANUAL
INTERACTION. THIS IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT- ALSO ARE SOMETHING
THAT MISTER MARTINEZ MENTIONED-
IN HIS TESTIMONY ABOUT HOW THE-
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN EDT
STRUCTURALISTS. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WAS MY EXPERIENCE
WORKING IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
IS THAT YOU CANNOT- YOU COULD
NOT EXPECT INNOVATION AND
MODERNIZATION YOUR STAFF COMES
AND GOES BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS
IS. PEOPLE ARE. THEY'RE
LEARNING THE JOB THEY'RE DOING
THE JOB THEY DON'T HAVE THE
BANDWIDTH TO ENGAGE IN
MODERNIZATION. THIS IS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE TAKING A LOOK AT OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS. UP IN
THE- SO FAR. IT'S TOP OF MIND.
IN GENERAL PROVIDES. GRANTED
EXPERIENCE OF LOOKING AT THESE
TYPES OF THINGS BEFORE. WE WILL
BE DOING. KIND OF SERVICE AND
THEN THAT JUST BEGS THE
QUESTION OF SOME OF THESE
ISSUES HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED FOR
OVER A DECADE OF WHY DON'T WE
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN IN
PLACE. NOW IDT. THAT'S A
TERRIFIC QUESTION AND I'M NOT
GOING TO SPECULATE ON WHY
THINGS DIDN'T. GET DONE
NAKATANI. ET OVER THE PAST TEN
YEARS BECAUSE I WASN'T. BUT I
CAN PROMISE YOU AND THOSE OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
WHOEVER MY WORKING HARSH
NEGATIVE. SIX GOT IT SO WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT. TRYING TO
MODERNIZE AND REFORM THE SYSTEM.
HOW DO YOU ANTICIPATE MOVING TO
ANAUTOMATIC THE SYSTEM OF
AUTOMATION VERSES OF MANUAL
INPUT WHAT YOU'RE INDICATING TO
US IS WHAT'S TAKING SO LONG FOR
A LOT OF THESE CLAIMANTS IN THE
FRUSTRATIONS WERE HERE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. FOR IT'S A
COMBINATION OF BOTH- PAPER
PROCESSES AND MORE POPULATION
OF STAFF. AND LEARN ABOUT THEIR
HISTORY EDT DURING TWENTY
TWENTY. I HAVE GONE THROUGH THE
MODERNIZATION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES CALGARY
COUNTY AND MY BEST PROJECT IN
MY WORK WITH XEROX I KNOW THE
TYPE OF APPROACHES THAT HAVE TO
BE MEET. THE NEEDS OF. LOOK AT
THE REVISION OF BUSINESS
PROCESSES. HE ARE. SOLICITATION
OF RAMBLE OF VENDORS WHO COULD
DO LARGE SCALE WHAT THEY CALL
THE CHIEFS AND- I CAN TELL YOU
THAT IT'S SOMETHING THAT EDT
HAS CONSIDERED BEFORE I THINK
THAT THE THEY WERE ON THE VERGE
OF LOOKING AT SOME SORT OF A
CARD HE HE FOR THE PANDEMIC
CAN'T AND THEN EVERYTHING
TURNED TO GETTING POSTCARDS
RIGHT. OUR I BELIEVE THROUGH
THE PROGRESS IN DOING SUCH A
CHANGE AND THE PITFALLS OF
DOING SUCH A CHANGE AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I WILL TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION IT'S NOT AN EASY
LET I PROMISE YOU AND THERE
WILL BE MISTAKES. BUT SUCH A
THING GETS UNDERWAY. WE CAN BE
DONE. I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT PLAN YOU HAVE
MOVING FORWARD YOU KNOW GIVEN
YOUR HISTORY AND I APPRECIATE-
YOUR EXPERIENCE IN THIS
DEPARTMENT BUT- WHAT'S THE PLAN
MOVING FORWARD TO HELP ADDRESS.
A LOT OF THESE ISSUES I THINK
THE LEGISLATURE I THINK
CALIFORNIANS WILL JUST FILL A
LOT MORE COMFORTABLE KNOWING.
THAT THERE'S A PLAN IN PLACE AS
OPPOSED TO WE'RE LOOKING AT IT.
YOU KNOW JUST TALKING ABOUT
EVEN THE CALL CENTERS AND YOU
TALK ABOUT HIRING MORE
INDIVIDUALS. YOU KNOW HOW ARE
YOU DOING BEST PRACTICES-
BECAUSE THE AUDITOR IDENTIFIED
DEFICIENCIES THERE. WHAT ARE
YOU DOING YOU KNOW Q. NA JUST
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS IS
THERE A CHAT THAT PEOPLE COULD
CHAT WITH PEOPLE ONLINE TO
RESOLVE THEIR ISSUES. BECAUSE
WE LOOK AT THE ON RECORD IN.
AND THE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
THAT HAVE BEEN GENETICALLY TO
TV THAT. OPERAND THE M.
INDIVIDUALS AND SEEING THE
NEEDLE BARELY MOVING- DOESN'T
INSTILL A LOT OF CONFIDENCE AND
SO. HAVING A PLAN WILL HELP
INSTILL THAT CONFIDENCE IF YOU
COULD JUST EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF A- A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN
WHICH IS PART OF THE OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH YOU SAID
YOU WOULD IMPLEMENT- THAT WOULD
HELP US TREMENDOUSLY. YOU MAY
BE FAMILIAR WITH THE STRIKING
REPORT THAT WAS. NEUSTIFT
SEPTEMBER. THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF GOING FORWARD- SOLUTIONS AND
TIME LINES AND THAT. THE AUDIT
REPORT HAS PROVIDED A NUMBER OF
SOLUTIONS AND TIMER I AM GOING
TO USE THAT AS A BILL CREDIT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE-
NINETEEN. REVISI RESTRUCTURING
WHAT IT IS WE DO SO THERE IS A
PLAN. THIS IS NOT A LOT OF
STICKING AROUND- YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU FOR SOMETHING GOOD TO
HAPPEN WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
THINGS HAPPEN. WITH THIS BOOK.
WILL CONTINUE TO USE IT YOU SEE
WHAT WE'VE DONE ALREADY IN THE
AREA FRAUD. WE'RE NOT
COMPLETELY FINISH THEIR-
WACKSTAR. MOST IMPORTANT THING
IN MIND- ENDED SECATEURS TEAMS
VIEW IS CUSTOMER SERVICE WE
HAVE GOT TO HANDLE CUSTOMER
SERVICE AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I INITIATED A
CRITICAL ISSUES FOR. OUR CALL
CENTER. SO I'M NOT BIG ON A LOT
OF PLANTS I'M GETTING ACTION.
AND AS I SAID WE HAVE THE
BLUEPRINTS NOW WITHIN A- DO
WHATEVER WE CAN TO ACCELERATE
TEXAS. I APPRECIATE THAT MOVING-FORWARD- SO CAN YOU JUST TELL
US FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE THEN.
WHY DID IT TAKE SO LONG FOR
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS TO GET
THEIR BENEFITS AND HOW ARE YOU
GOING ABOUT TO. DECREASE THAT
TIME LINE SO IT GETS TO PEOPLE
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE. HOW I'M VERY
HIGH ON TRANSPARENCY BUT I
THINK TRANSPARENCY IS USELESS
WITHOUT ACCURACY SO I'M GOING
TO ASK ONE OF MY CHIEF DEPUTIES
TO STEP IN AND- PATTERSON THAT
THAT QUESTION IN MORE DETAIL.
THANK YOU. CAROL WILLIAMS
HELLO- THANK YOU. FOR RECEIVING
US TODAY AND ALLOW THIS TO
RESPOND TO THE ON EDGE THE
REASON WHY IT HAS TAKEN SO LONG
TO PAY CLAIMS IS- COMPLETELY
MANUAL PROCESS. PRIOR TO ME
COMING IN OCTOBER FIRST WHEN A
CLAIMANT WHEN. WHENEVER
INDICATIONS ON A CLAIM THAT A
CLAIM NEED TO BE REVIEWED IT
WAS A COMPLETELY MANUAL PROCESS
AND THAT LED TO WHAT EVERYONE'S
FAMILIAR WITH WAS THE ONE POINT
SIX MILLION BACKLOG CLAIMS AT
THE POINT OF- SEPTEMBER
NINETEENTH. AND THOSECLAIMS
WHEN ALL THE WAY BACK TO APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S WHY IT
THROUGH THAT WHOLE PERIOD THAT
WAS THE PRIORITY FOR THE
ORGANIZATION TO ADDRESS ALL
THOSE CLAIMS GIVE FOLKS PAID OR
GIVE THEM THEIR STATUS IT WAS
AN UNPAID STATUS. THE
AUTOMATION IS REALLY THE BIG
LEFT IN THE BIG OPPORTUNITY
HERE EDT FOR ALL OF OUR
PROCESSES- AND I APPRECIATE THE
POINT MADE EARLIER TODAY BUT AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AND GET READY
TO RESUME- PLANNING IN OUR
PROCESS FOR BUSINESS. FOR OUR-
OUR MODERNIZATION OF OUR
SYSTEMS WE CAN'T WAIT THREE
YEARS CLAIMANTS CAN'T WAIT YOU
CAN'T WAIT THE PUBLIC CAN'T
WAIT WE NEED TO TAKE IT IN
SMALL CHUNKS TO PROVIDE THE
AUTOMATION TO BEAT FASTER
FASTER THAN WE'VE EVER BEEN. SO
THE AUTOMATION. OF CLAIM
FILINGS A SIGNIFICANT. PRIOR TO
ME COMING IN ALL CLAIMS.
THERE'S A SIXTY PER AUTOMATION.
ON 40% FELL OUT FOR MANUAL
MANUAL PROCESS AND TODAY WE'RE
AT 8990% MAN ALSO. CLAIM
FILINGS- WHEN THEY'RE CLEAN OUR
ARMED STREAM WE FAST. WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL WORK AS WE ARE AS
BEEN MENTIONED TODAY WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK FROM THE PAST THAT
WE NOW NEED TO ADDRESS AND JUST
TO ADDRESS THE DETERMINATIONS
THAT WERE SUSPENDED PRIOR. LAST
SPRING WE HAVE A TASK FORCE
RIGHT NOW THAT IS LOOKING AT
ALL OF THAT WORK TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN MOVE THROUGH IT AS
SWIFTLY AS WE CAN BUT STE WE
HAVE TO FREE UP STAFF. WE HAVE
TO PROVIDE MORE AUTOMATION SO
STAFF CAN DO THE HARD MANUAL
WORK THAT TRULY IS REQUIRED IN
THAT TRULY HAS BEEN WAITING FOR
APPEAR TO TIME AND I'LL GO
AHEAD AND STOP THERE BUT THANK
YOU. I APPRECIATE THAT AND THE
AUTOMATION SO ON AVERAGE NOW
WITH THE REFORMS THAT YOU HAVE
IMPLEMENTED WHAT'S THE AVERAGE
WAIT TIME FOR APPOINTMENTS.
THIRTY WILL GUIDELINES WE ARE
IN A FOURTEEN TO TWENTY ONE.
DAY WINDOW TO MAKE THE FIRST
PAYMENT. AND AS OF MIND OR
STATS AS OF THE END OF DECEMBER
I BELIEVE WE WERE AT SIXTY PER.
AREA AS OF TWELVE THIRTY ONE WE
WERE MAKING FIRST PAYMENTS AT A
RATE OF. 76% OF THE TIME AND
THAT WAS AT THE TWENTY ONE DAY
MARK AND THAT IS UP FROM JUST
30% OF THE TIME AS OF TEN
THIRTY ONE WE WERE MAKING THE
FIRST PAYMENT ON TIME SO WE
NEED TO GET EIGHTY SEVEN AND
HIGHER. THAT IS THE FEDERAL
MANDATE THAT IS THE MARK BUT IT
IS ENCOURAGING TO SEE THAT
WE'RE LEAST GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION OKAY. GOT IT REMAIN
PRECIADO BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY-
LIKE CHAIRMAN DALY SAID WE ARE
HEARING FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS
WHO ARE UPSET AND I. I'M HOPING
THERE- MAYBE IN THAT OTHER. 12%
THAT NEEDS TO GET THEIR ISSUES
ADDRESSED UP. BUT WITH THAT I
WANTED TO ASK ANOTHER QUESTION
ON ON THE FRIDAY MAY. AND CAN
YOU TELL US AT THIS POINT HOW
MUCH OF THAT FRAUD BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE SEEN REPORTS
ANYWHERE FROM A MINIMUM OF TEN
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS AND
POTENTIALLY FRAUDULENT
PAYMENTS- TO ANYWHERE NEARLY UP
TO THIRTY ONE BILLION I THINK I
THOUGHT I SAW ONE NUMBER. BUT
HOW MUCH OF THAT IS ATTRIBUTED
TO THE U. Y. PROGRAM AND HOW
MUCH OF THAT IS ATTRIBUTED TO
THE PO I PRO P. YOU A PROGRAM.
SO WHAT STATE DOLLARS AND
WHAT'S FEDERAL DOLLARS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT NEEDS THE
VARIOUS WITH EDT- OF THE- ABOUT
ELEVEN BILLION OR SO THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED IN IN FRAUD TO THE
TEN PERCENT- 95% OF THAT IS IF
YOU A AND THE REMAINING FIVE
PERCENT. AS I THINK- MR
MOULTRIE- POINTED OUT IS THE U.
Y. SYSTEM. M. I'M SORRY HELP ME
WITH THE MATH WHAT DOESN'T WORK
OUT TO- IT'S ABOUT ITS FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION OR SO FOR THE
U. I. AND THEN THE REST IS UP
TO YOU WAY. ELEVEN BILLION
MINUS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION.
YEAH TO ISIS. CORRECT. GOT IT
AND SO I JUST WANT TO GO BACK
AND- DIRECTOR SCIENCE TOUCHED
UPON THIS EARLY BUT THE
DECISION TO SUSPEND THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS UP LED
TO SOME OF THIS FRAUD CAN YOU
HELP US UNDERSTAND THE
RATIONALE THEIR AND WHAT'S
BEING DONE TO SAFEGUARD- THOSE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS FROM FRONT
CONTINUING TO. EXIST IN THE
SYSTEM. LET ME TRY TO ADDRESS
THAT AND THEN- HELLO YES YOU
CAN DISCUSS MORE OF IT. SO AS I
SAID I WASN'T THERE FOR SOME OF
THE DECISIONS WERE MADE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT IN THE PROCESS
OF. WHEN THE PROCESSING THESE
CLAIMS. ARE THROUGH OUR
TECHNOLOGY OUR SYSTEM BEGAN TO
SLOW DOWN. AND FOR THOSE OF THE
MEMBERS FEEL ARE WITH
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S A VERY BAD
SIGN AND IF YOU PUSH THE SYSTEM
WHAT'S BEGINNING TO SLOW DOWN
IN THE BALLING THAT WE HAD THEN
THE SYSTEM OF THE CRASH. I
THINK THAT THAT WAS ONE OF THE
ELEMENTS IN THE DECISION WAS
MADE AT THE TIME. THAT'S IF YOU
HAVE ANYTHING TO SAY I WOULD
JUST THAT YOU KNOW- FROM FROM
WHAT I HAVE SEEN OVER THE PAST
FEW MONTHS THAT I'VE BEEN
HEARING SOME OF THE DECISIONS
THAT WERE MADE. I MEAN I CAN'T
FIND ONE THAT WAS NOT A GOOD
FAITH ATTEMPT. TO PAY PEOPLE
WHO WERE DESPERATE FOR HELP-
YOU KNOW AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S- IS SORT OF THE
UNDERLYING- COMMENT THAT I
WOULD MAKE ON ON SOME OF THE
DECISIONS NOT HAVING BEEN HERE
BUT I CAN HONESTLY SAY THAT
THAT. WAS A BIG PIECE OF IT
REMEMBER. YEAH AND I UNDERSTAND
THE SUDDEN URGE AN UP TICK IN.
TRYING TO ADDRESSED CLAIMANTS
BUT YOU KNOW MY UNDERSTANDING
TO IS THAT EDT REMOVE SOME OF
THOSE SAFEGUARDS WHICH WAS
OUTLINED IN THE AUTUMN. TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHY THOSE
SAFEGUARDS WERE REMOVED THERE
WAS ONLY FOR EXPEDIENCY BUT AT
WHAT COST AND WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE COSTS THAT BEING A MINIMUM
OF TEN BILLION DOLLARS OF
FRAUD. AND THEN I BELIEVE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT-
COMMUNICATED WITH. YOUR
DEPARTMENT- ASKING TO RE
IMPLEMENT THOSE SAFEGUARDS SO
CAN YOU HELP JUST EXPLAIN THAT
INTERACTION AND HOW THAT WAS
FIXED. ALL RIGHT LET ME JUST
SAY THAT THE SAFEGUARDS ARE NOW.
EDT MISTER CRITICAL SKATEPARKS
AND WE HAVE MORE SAFEGUARDS
EVEN IN THE INDIAN WHILE
SUGGESTED TO US. NANCY DO YOU
HAVE ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD TO
THEIR- I MEAN JUST AS AS YOU
KNOW YOU MENTIONED IN PART OF
YOUR TESTIMONY ABOUT- THE
SAFEGUARDS THAT WE HAVE NOW
WITH I. D. NY AT THOMSON
REUTERS AND STOPPING CRIED AT
THE AT THE FRONT DOOR- THAT.
THAT'S ALL I WOULD ADD
BASICALLY I MEAN WE ARE WHERE
WE HAVE A TASK FORCE WITH YOU
KNOW ALL WE ASKED AND THE DA'S-
IN ORDER TO INVESTIGATE FRAUD-
WE YOU KNOW THERE'S ARREST
THAT'S BEEN MADE AS AS THE
DIRECTOR MENTIONED- YOU KNOW I
DO THINK THAT WE HAVE STOPPED
FRAUD. AT THE FRONT DOOR AND
GOING FORWARD- THAT THAT IS THE
DIRECTION THAT WE'RE GOING IN.
IS STOPPING FRAUD BEFORE.
PAYMENTS GET MADE. WHAT GOT A
DEADLY SAY LET ME JUST ADD
SOMETHING TO THAT- I KNOW THAT
THE AUDITORS TALKED ABOUT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
NEEDING TWO THOUSAND TEN.
SECTOR WERE NOT IMPLEMENTED
COMPLETELY. R. YES WE HAVE A
LARGE BACK PACK. GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
GO BACK AND- CHECK ON THEIR
IDENTITY AND THEIR
CERTIFICATIONS. BUT I WANT TO
ASSURE YOU THAT THIS EXECUTIVE
TEAM IS COMMITTED. COMMITTED TO
MAKING SURE. NO ONE WAS ASKING
WAS TYPES OF QUESTIONS. AND TEN
YEARS FROM NOW. I APPRECIATE
THAT OBVIOUSLY WE ALL WISH
THESE REFORMS WERE IMPLEMENTED
PREVIOUSLY FROM THE LAST
DOWNTURN AND- THAT FIRST REPORT
THAT TO TWENTY TEN TWENTY
ELEVEN THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO
NOW- DO APPRECIATE THAT BUT- I
THINK WE'RE JUST GONNA EAGERLY.
WAIT YOUR IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
STATE ARE REPORTED REALLY YOUR
I HOPE WE CAN JOIN TOGETHER IN
CALTRANS PARTNERS IN THE
LEGISLATION- THAT HAS BEEN
INTRODUCED SO FAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT THESE REFORMS THAT
YOU SEEM TO WANT TO EMBRACE AND
HOPING YOU DO AND THAT'S
GENUINE- BUT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
IT. THERE'S STILL. STILL A LOT
OF QUESTIONS AND JUST THE
OVERALL WHAT IS THE
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO ADDRESS-
NOT ONLY THE DEFICIENCIES BUT-
HOW ARE WE MOVING TO MAKE SURE
THAT CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL
RECEIVING THE BENEFITS THAT
THEY NEED I THINK THAT. YOU
CONTINUE TO HEAR A LOT OF
MEMBERS KIND OF COME BACK TO
THOSE TWO POINTS AND I THINK
IT'S BECAUSE THERE'S NO CLEAR
INDICATION FROM THE DEPARTMENT.
OUR GETTING THERE AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THE AUDITOR WAS
IDENTIFYING IS A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN- IN PLACE. IN THE ECONOMY
THAT WE EXPECT AN UPTICK OVER
INTO THE- FOR ME DRESS THAT SO
I HAVE SAID THAT WE ARE USING
BOTH THE STRIKE TEAM RECOMMEND.
AND RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
AUDITOR. AS A CORPORATE OR WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO FOR ONE ISSUE
IF YOU JUST RAISED AT THE END
THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE. YOU KNOW.
THAT YES A CRITICAL. ELEMENT OF
HOW THE DEPARTMENT. SHOULD BE
ANTICIPATING WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN. IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
SCALE UP ON ON THE TURN OF A
DIME IT'S JUST- IMPOSSIBLE. YES
WE HEAR WHAT THE AUDITORS. HERE
WHAT A RENTER'S HAS SAID WE
WILL BE PER NEXT TIME. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT- I HAVE A
THIS QUESTIONS WHEN I KNOW I A
NUMBER OF MIKE'S MY COLLEAGUES
UP AND TO FOR TO THEIR
QUESTIONS AND COME TO MY THANK
YOU MISTER OKAY MISTER SAW-
MISTER BERMAN HAS BEEN WAITING
FOR- ON THE WEBEX. AND THEN LET
ME SHARE THAT- NEXT AFTER MR
BERMAN WILL BE MISSED ****
HORRIBLE OFF THEN MR PATTERSON.
AND THEN WE'LL TRY TO
ACCOMMODATE EVERYONE ELSE AS
SOON AS WE CAN BUT- MR BERMAN
EUROPE. THANK YOU CHAIR DALY-
AND THANK YOU ORDER HOWL AND
THAT YOUR TEAM FOR YOUR GREAT
WORK AND THANK YOU DIRECTOR FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY AS
EGREGIOUS IS THE FINDINGS OF
THESE AUDITS ARE THEY DID NOT
COME AS A SURPRISE NOT TO ME
NOT MY STAFF AND NOT THE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
HAD THE UNFORTUNATE EXPERIENCE
OF HAVING TO INTERACT WITH EDT
SINCE THIS PANDEMIC BEGAN.
BECAUSE FOR ELEVEN MONTHS NOW
WE HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES OF EDIE'S. THERE
ARE TOO MANY CAN GOAL EDT HAS
FAITH DURING CRISIS. PREVENTING
FRAUD VERSUS PAYING LEGITIMATE
CLAIM EFFICIENTLY. THE LAST
ELEVEN MONTHS HAVE BEEN A
CONSTANT TRADEOFF BETWEEN THESE
TWO PURPOSES. EARLY IN THE
PANDEMIC THERE WAS A DECISION
MADE TO ALLOW CLAIMANTS TO
RECEIVE THEIR CLAIMS WITHOUT
CERTIFYING ARE PROVIDING ID
VERIFICATION. THIS COMPLIMENTS
OUT FASTER BUT A LETTER
SKYROCKETING FRAUD. THEN AT THE
END OF LAST YEAR THERE WAS AN
EFFORT TO LIMIT FRIDAY. LEAVING
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE BRINK OF
HOMELESSNESS AND HUNGER CUT OFF
FROM THEIR BENEFITS WITHOUT ANY
WARNING. THE PENDULUM KEEPS
SWINGING WILDLY CREATING
CONSTANT CHAOS FOR CALIFORNIANS
WITH NO HOPE OF REACHING A
STATE OF EQUILIBRIUM. YOUR JOB
DVDS JOB IS TO PAY LEGITIMATE
CLAIMANTS THE MONEY THEY PUT
INTO THE SYSTEM AND TO NOT PAY
OUT FRAUDULENT CLAIMS. FOR
NEARLY ELEVEN MONTHS EVD HAS
BEEN FAILING AT BOTH JOBS. A
LOT HAS BEEN COVERED TODAY- I
DON'T TO FOCUS ON THE ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION CLAIMS THAT YOU
NEED BE SUSPENDED IN BETWEEN
CHRISTMAS AND THE NEW YEAR
WITHOUT ANY NOTICE TO
CONSTITUENTS LET ALONE TO US
LEGISLATORS AND OUR STAFFS. YOU
NEED THE SENT CRYPTIC AND
CONFUSING NOTICES TO ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION CALIFORNIA.
TELLING THEM THAT THEIR CLAIMS
WERE FROZEN DUE TO SUSPICION OF
FRAUD. AND PROVIDED NO CLEAR
PLAN FOR WHEN THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO PROVE THEIR IDENTITY
AND START RECEIVING PAYMENTS
AGAIN. NOT ONLY WAS THIS A
CRUEL BLOW AT A TIME WHEN THERE
WERE EVEN FEWER PEOPLE TO HELP
THEM IN BETWEEN CHRISTMAS AND
NEW YEAR. BUT CONFUSING
LANGUAGE IN THE NOTICE CREATED
UNNECESSARY FEAR AND ANXIETY
BECAUSE CONSTITUENTS MY
CONSTITUENTS TOM THEY
THEMSELVES WERE UNDER
INVESTIGATION BY THE
GOVERNMENT. WITH SOME WONDERING
IF THEY NEEDED TO HIRE LAWYERS
TO DEFEND THEMSELVES. TWO WEEKS
AFTER THEIR CLAIM WAS FROZEN
THEY WERE GIVEN TEN DAYS TO
VERIFY THROUGH ID DOT ME. I
THIRD PARTY VENDOR. BEFORE
THEIR CLAIM IT WOULD BE
DISQUALIFIED. I DID ON THE WAS
IT IS THAT. OUR CONSTITUENTS
DID THEIR BEST TO FOLLOW THE
INSTRUCTIONS AND WERE
CONFRONTED WITH OBSCENE WAIT
TIMES THAT NEVER BY. MYSELF
TOLD ME ABOUT ONCE WHO HAD A
FORTY ONE HOUR A WEEK. WHAT MY
STAFF INQUIRED ABOUT WAIT TIMES
THEY WERE TOLD BY EDT THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS NEEDED TO GET
THROUGH THE I'D BE DOWN THE
PROCESS BEFORE EDT COULD DO
ANYTHING. AND THAT THERE WAS NO
WAY FOR MY STAFF TO INTERVENE
OR ASSIST MY CONSTITUENTS.
DURING THE ID GOT ME PROCESS. I
CAN'T EMPHASIZE ENOUGH HOW MUCH
SUFFERING AND PAIN THAT
DECISION TO FREEZE THOSE CLAIMS
WITHOUT ANY PLANNED COST. A LOT
BUT I DO WANT TO TALK ABOUT ONE
OF HUNDREDS OF MY CONSTITUENTS.
ROGER WHO IS PUT THROUGH THIS
NIGHT. RAJU'S CLAIM WAS ON THE
SAN THIRTY. FOR TWO WEEKS ALL
EDT CAN TELL US WHAT HE NEEDED
TO WAIT A WAIT FURTHER
INSTRUCTIONS WHEN YOU RECEIVE
THE ID DAMILOLA. HE SPENT FOUR
TO FOUR HOURS A DAY TRYING TO
VERIFY HIS IDENTITY WELL I. D.
DOT THE SHOW TO EIGHTH CONSTANT
HOUR WEEK TIME THAT NEVER WENT.
I'M BI WEEKLY CALL MICE TO
SECONDS TO WHO GOT THROUGH I D.
DOT SIX TO HAVE THE CLAIMS UP
BY THE END OF JUNE. WHICH DID
NOT HAPPEN. EDT ALSO REVIEW.
THAT THEY WERE. ON THAT THEY
WERE. ON THE PROBE. NEED TO
POST BACK ONLINE AFTER. HAVE
BEEN VERY. TWO EDT SUSPENDED
POINT FOUR MILLION CLAIMS IN
BETWEEN CHRISTMAS AND NEW YEARS
WITHOUT ANY HEADS UP TO THE
LEGISLATURE UNDERSTANDS THAT
HAVE BEEN SERVING AS THE DE
FACTO EDT CALL CENTER FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS FOR MONTHS.
BECAUSE THE REAL CALL CENTER
DOESN'T WORK AND YOU HAD NO
PLAN FOR HOW TO GET THOSE
CLAIMS BACK ON TRACK QUICKLY-
APPROVE. THAT PLAN. ROGERS CASE
LANGUISHED IN THE CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM IS A HARDSHIP.
ROGER AND HIS SON ARE LIVING
OUT OF THEIR CAR HE RAN OUT OF
GAS HE RISKED HAVING HIS PHONE
PLAN CANCEL WHICH WOULD HAVE
CAUGHT HIM OFF FOR MY OFFICE
THE ONLY LIFELINE TO GETTING
HIS BENEFITS BACK UP- AND MY
STAFF HAVE SOUGHT HELPLESS. TO
RESOLVE ROGERS CASE AND SO MANY
OTHER CASES TO TRY TO HELP MY
CONSTITUENTS SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS WHY DID HE SUSPEND
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION CLAIMS
IN BETWEEN CHRISTMAS AND NEW
YEARS BEFORE FINALIZING THE
PLAN TO GET THOSE PLANS BACK ON.
WE THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS EVEN
CLOSE TO A RESPONSIBLE DECISION
TO MAKE. LET ME LET ME ADDRESS
THE FIRST PART OF HER. DOES
CRIMES STOP AS OF MARK. THAT
DISK THROUGH THE- THANKS
WRITERS FRAUD BERMAN. THE FIRST
EXAMPLES ARE THE HOW MOST
PEOPLE WOULD IDENTIFY YEARS
YEAH OBVIOUSLY- I YOU KNOW I
HEAR THE STORY ARE ARE YA. ALL
RIGHT I WILL APPRECIATE THE OUT.
THE THAT PEOPLE ARE TO MORE I
GOT CALLS MURDER ALL THE TIME-
SO- WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS WE
HAVE A REALLY COULD TO WORK
WITH A. TO LET PEOPLE KNOW
CLEARLY. IN EVIDENCE. WHEN
WE'RE THIS TYPE OF INACTION. AS
FAR AS CONCERNED THIS WILL
NEVER AGAIN. IT IS A OF THE- SO
YOU KNOW. I SAID EARLIER I NOT
A BIG PERSON DOING A LOT OF
PLAN I BELIEVE IN A- WELL
PEOPLE HAVE. YOU GOT IT FROM
STRIKE TEAM WHO GOT IT FROM OUR
IT'S NOW IMPORTANT FOR WOULD G.
TO PROVIDE LEAD TO MAKE SURE
THAT LISTINGS HAVE. THAT OFTEN
ARE CLEAR THAT ARE PARTNERS
WITH A LETTER IS. FOR MACINNES.
OTHER ESSENTIAL WORKERS- WHO
ARE THEY ARE NOT IN A POSITION.
TO BE WITHOUT MONEY. NO THIS IS
NOT LIKE A WELL PAID TECH
WORKER WHO LIVES IN A NICE HOME
AND- HAS SAVINGS BECAUSE THEIR
PAID TO WELL. ARE BARELY PAID.
YEAH SO I WANT YOU TO I JUST ON
THAT PART THE LAWN THIS. ON
THAT. I THIS IN THE PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO IS NOT LOST ON. I
APPRECIATE AND- YOU ARE ARE
STRUGGLING SO MUCH- AND HAVE
BEEN FOR LONG AND THE NURSE.
STRUGGLE SO MUCH- BECAUSE THEY
POUR THEIR AND- INTO THIS WORK
AND YOU KNOW I HAD CALL WITH
MOST IS ON FOR NIGHT BECAUSE
THEY GOT EMAIL FOR AND- WHO
SAID IT KNOW ALL. YOU KNOW
NOTHING TO ME I'M I'M KICKED
OUT ON THE STREET BECAUSE I WAS
ON A SOME- FOR MY PART IN AND
KNOW I TO GIVE MY BEST AND NOW
I'M OUT- AND THEN THAT HAS ON
OUR TEAMS- ALL OF THE STATE NAY
THEN- I'M I PRE THAT YOU'RE IN.
THAT ALSO- YOU KNOW REALLY WE
KIND OF THINGS. THE DECISION
THAT WE AND THE IMPACT THEY
WILL HAVE AND TRIED AT AND- THE.
THE YOU KNOW CHILD THE IN THE
IN AND STRESS THAT THAT THOSE
DECISION WILL CAUSE BEFORE- AND
GET AHEAD OF THAT AS MUCH AS-
SO LET YOU THE FIRST THING THAT
I CENTRAL WHY EXECUTIVE STAFF.
WHEN I CAME IN. THERE TWO
THINGS THAT ARE TO ME.
QUESTIONS I DON'T THINK TOO
MUCH TIME BUT HOW IS IT
APPROPRIATE THAT. IN IN THIS IS
GOING BACK TO THIS ISSUE. THAT
CONSTITUENTS WERE GIVEN TEN
DAYS TO VERIFY THEIR IDENTITY
VS THE SYSTEM THAT THAT WAS
NOT. PREPARED FOR THE VOLUMES.
THAT HAVE BEEN ARTIFICIALLY
YOUR TREAT CREATED BY BY
FREEZING ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
FINANCE BUT BUT HE- DOESN'T
FEEL LIKE THEY NEED TO PROVIDE
CONSTITUENTS WITH ANY TIMELINE.
FOR WHEN HE WILL COMPLETE THEIR
PART OF THE JOB- SERGEANTS TO
JOINTS. HAD TEN DAYS TO GET
THIS IDEA TO ME PROCESS. BUT HE
NEVER PUT ANY DEADLINES ON ON
YOURSELVES. WELL LET ME FIRST
ADDRESS. THE TEN DAY ISSUE-
THAT DOES WAS A- TO THIRTY
DAYS. BECAUSE AS SOON AS IT
BECAME MORE. AS SOON AS WE SAW
THAT PEOPLE ARE HAVING TROUBLE
WITH ID MISAKA PEOPLE NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO COMPLETE. SO WE
EXPECT TO BE. ABLE DID HAVE
THIRTY DAYS TO GET BACK TO US-
REGARDING THE OTHER PART OF THE
QUESTION I'M GONNA ASK OUR
CHIEF DEPUTY OF OPERATIONS. OR
IF SHE HAS SOMETHING SHE WANTS
TO ADD TO THIS ABSOLUTELY CARE
WAS COMING HERE THE SECOND PART
OF THE QUESTION AGAIN. YEAH WHY
IS TAKES CARE WHY WHY ISN'T D.
D. PUTTING COMMON ON THEMSELVES
YEAH- TO FIGURE THESE THINGS
OUT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. WE
CERTAINLY NEED TO IMPROVE WITH
OUR COMMUNICATION TO YOU AND
CERTAINLY WITH THE CLIENTS IN
THIS PARTICULAR NUCLEUS OF- OF
THE SITUATION- IT WAS DONE IT
WAS DONE TO ADDRESS FRAUD IT
WAS DATED JUNE DRIVEN DECISION
AS THE DIRECTOR HAS EXPRESSED.
WAS THE FIRST TIME THAT WE HAD
COMPLIMENTS COMPREHENSIVE DATA
ANALYSIS ON SUSPECTED FRAUD IN
HAND. A. AS YOU KNOW WITH ANY
DATA. ONE TIME AND WE CERTAINLY
ARE NOW UNDERTAKING UNDERTAKING
A WHOLE FRAUD EFFORT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS DATA IS ANALYZED
THAT THESE DECISIONS ARE
TIGHTER THAN THEY WERE THE
FIRST TIME IN THIS THE GROUP
THAT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
REFERRING TO WITH ALL. THAT WAS
WIDER THAN IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
BUT THAT'S WHERE WE NEED
EXPERTISE AND EXPERT ANALYSIS
TO COME IN HERE AND LOOK AT
THOSE FILTERS AND WE'RE
EXPECTING THAT ASSISTANCE TO
JOIN US WITHIN THE NEXT WEEK
WEEK AND A HALF. SO BACK TO
YOUR QUESTION. BUT THE NET WAS
TOO WIDE- THE DATA DID NOT
SUGGEST THAT IT WOULD. I DID ME
WOULD BE IMPACTED THE WAY IT
WAS IN THAT CLAIMANTS WOULD BE
IMPACTED THE WAY IT WAS. WHICH
IS WHY THE DIRECTOR JUST SAID
AS SOON AS WE HAVE THOSE
INDICATIONS OF FOLKS WERE
WAITING ON LONG. WAITING IN A
LINE ITEM IN EXORBITANT MANY
TIMES WE ACTUALLY SPEND THAT
TIME FRAME TO THE THINK IT'S-
FEBRUARY THE FIFTEENTH WHICH IS
AN EXTRA THIRTY DAYS. BUT THE
REASON WHY THERE IS A TIME
FRAME BECAUSE IF IT WASN'T IT
IS ABOUT PRIDE. FOR THOSE THAT
DO NOT RESPOND THAT NEVER
ATTEMPT. TO GO THROUGH IT ME
THAT NEVER ATTEMPT TO REALLY
VALIDATE THEIR IDENTITY. THIS
IS THE GROUP THAT YOU KNOW HOW
THERE'S THE STRONGEST
INDICATIONS OF FRAUD. AND
CERTAINLY WE WILL CONTINUE IN
THE PROMISED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THOSE FILTERS. SO THAT
WE ARE ONLY- IDENTIFYING THOSE
THAT HAVE THE ABSOLUTE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF. RISK OF FRAUD BUT
THAT IS WHY BECAUSE THERE IS AN.
END TO THIS AFTER. PROBABLY
PROBABLY. TIME IS. SO AND I AND
I AM THE NEED TO PUT A LOT BUT
THEN SHE MEDIA AFFORDABLE ON A
MINUTE OF YOU KNOW ONE HE'S GOT
YOU KNOW I HAVE. IS A PROCESS.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT'S YOUR
WHAT'S CITY THESE THAT ACTUALLY
CONCRETE DOUBLE FOR ONE YEAR
AND- THAT IT DOES PART OF THE
WORLD IN THE BOOK OF THE- OF A
WORKING THROUGH I THINK IT'S-
FAIR I THINK WE SHOULD BE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DEADLINES SO
LET US TAKE THAT BACK AND GO
BACK AND DO A BETTER JOB.
COMING FORWARD WITH WHAT CLAIMS
CAN EXPECT WHEN THEY ARE IN ANY
OF THESE WORKLOADS- ARE WORKING
SITUATIONS WITH US. WE'RE
SAYING IT'S TEN TO THIRTEEN
DAYS AFTER YOU CLEAR ID ME. SO
I'M GONNA. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER GERALD OTHER FOR MY
COLLEAGUES. ALL RIGHT MR BERMAN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION- NEXT IS.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN TASHA BOERNER
HORVATH THEN MR JIM PATTERSON
THEN WENDY CARILLO THEN SENATOR
BAKER SO- YOU ALL KNOW YOU HAVE
A SENSE OF THE TIME YOU'RE
GOING TO TALK THANK YOU THANK
YOU- I WANT TO THANK OUR ORDER
AND- BOTH COMMITTEES FOR
CONVENING THIS MEETING TODAY
AND FOR THE HARD WORK OF THE
AUDIT COMMITTEE- I WOULD LIKE
TO CHALLENGE EDT. BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THIS AUDIT IS THE
BLUEPRINT THIS AUDIT IS
RECOGNIZING THE DEFICIENCIES OF
THE DEPARTMENT HAD IN SERVING
CALIFORNIANS SO I DON'T ACCEPT
THAT THIS IS THE BLUEPRINT.
THIS IS CORRECTING WHAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN CORRECTED BEFORE AND
A BLUEPRINT IS PLANNING THE
PATH TO IMPROVEMENT SO WHEN I
HEAR THAT I GET VERY VERY
CONCERNED AND I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FIRST CALL
RESOLUTION BECAUSE I'LL TELL
YOU WHAT'S GOING ON IN MY
CONSTITUENTS WITH MY
CONSTITUENTS. THEY'RE CALLING
AT AND CALLING EIGHTY I'M
CALLING AT ONLY TO FINALLY GET
A HOLD OF SOMEBODY WHO CAN'T
FIX THEIR PROBLEM AND THEN THE
EDV PERSON SAYS GO TALKED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TASHA
BOERNER HORVATH. WE WANT WE
WANT TO BE A PER BUT WE CAN'T
BE A PRO OF WHEN YOU'RE PEOPLE
ARE SENDING BACK TO US BECAUSE
THEY CANNOT RESOLVE. THEIR
FIRST CONTACT PROBLEMS. SO I
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS AROUND
THAT- BUT I REALLY LIKE TO GET
SOME CONCRETE ANSWERS- I'VE
THREE QUESTIONS ONE PLEASE CAN
YOU IDENTIFY THE REASONS. WHY
EDT EMPLOYEES CANNOT RESOLVE
OUR CONSTITUENTS ISSUES ON
FIRST CONTACT. IT'S NOT BECAUSE
THE MANUAL ENTRY OF NOT BECAUSE
ANY OF THOSE THINGS WHY ARE
THEY NOT RESOLVING THAT AND WHY
ARE THEY SENDING THEM BACK. TO
LEGISLATIVE OFFICES. WHEN THE
FIRST ADDRESSING TO BUCKLE
COOPER BECAUSE I THINK I WAS
NOT CLEARING UP. SO I DID MY
EXPERIENCE OF BEING WILL CHECK
FOR ONE OF THE THINGS THAT. IS
STANDARD- PRACTICE IS FOR YOU
TO GET LESSONS LEARNED.
ABSOLUTE TIGHTER BY BLUE CROSS
THE PROBLEM. WITH THE IMAGINED
BECAUSE OF THE PROBLEM NOT THE
GENERAL GOSSIP ABOUT WHAT THE
PROBLEMS WHAT WHAT THE ROOT
CAUSE OF THIS MISSION I REFER
TO THOSE AT THE STRIKE GENE AND
THE- AUDITORS. BECAUSE WE NEED
TO. PUT INTO THOSE ROOT CAUSES
OF THE PROBLEM YOU FOR OF. LOOP
BRIDGE IS DESIGNED. THE BLUE
CREEK. THIS IS THE BLOOPER FOR
GETTING INTO A IS GOING WRONG.
AND WHAT NEEDS TO. THE CORRECT
NOW. THE FOR THE- WILL BE THE
THIS PRICE. AND THE TECHNOLOGY
SITUATION WAS WORKING MORE
CLOSELY SO I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
MAKING IT CLEAR. WONDER OUR
CARAMEL HAVE **** ANSWER THE
REST OF. THE QUESTION. WELL I'M
JUST GOING TO. CAROL WILLIAMS
JUST SAID STEPS SHOULD NEVER
REFER BACK TO YOU ANY OF YOU.
ANY OF YOUR- OWN AND WE DID
RECEIVE THAT OUR COMMUNICATION
I BELIEVE EARLY LAST WEEK AND
WE HAVE ABSOLUTELY INTERESTED
WITH ALL CONTACT CENTER STAFF
IT IS INAPPROPRIATE AND
INEXCUSABLE- SO. IF I COULD
JUST HAVE A FEW MORE MINUTES TO
TALK ABOUT- THE MAGNETIZATION
OF THE OF THE CONTACT CENTER
THAT ARE DIRECTOR SPOKEN ABOUT
ONE OF THE KEY FOUNDATIONS OF A
WELL RUN EFFICIENT. MODERN
CONTACT CENTRE IT'S CALLED
MONITORED THAT IS THE BASIC AND
SO WHAT WE ARE ON THIS QUEST TO
MODERNIZE THE CONTACT CENTER.
BASIC TOOLS ARE MISSING AS WELL
AS OUR SEARCH FOR IT THE
ADVANCED TOOLS BASIC TOOLS CALL
MONITORING WERE ALL CALLS ARE
MONITORED AS A AS A
COMMUNICATION AND TRAINING TOOL
BACK WITH THE EMPLOYEE BUT ALSO
SERVES AS A- ACCOUNTABILITY
TOOL. AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE WE DO LIVE
MONITORING. ONLY GOES SO FAR SO
WE ARE AS MUCH AS WE'RE
INTERESTED IN HIRING GREAT
FOLKS AND WE DO HAVE FANTASTIC
EMPLOYEES KEEPING THEM WELL
TRAINED AND MINIMIZING OR JUST
PROVIDING THE TRAINING THAT'S
NEEDED SO THAT THEY CAN BE OF
BENEFIT. TO OUR CLIENTS AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE. WE'RE ALSO PART OF
THAT GOOD SHE TRAINING IS- IT
IS PART OF CALL GOOD CALL
MONITOR AND GOOD COMMUNICATION
WITH OUR STAFF- BACK TO
TRAINING JUST A LITTLE BIT IT
HAS BEEN- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE DONE TO IMPROVE THE
TRAINING IS OUR ADVANCED
TRAINING AND THAT'S FOR- THE
HIGHEST LEVEL CLASSIFICATION IS
NOW THIRTEEN WEEKS. IT IS A
CONTINUED IT IS A JOURNEY
BECAUSE THIS IS VERY ADVANCED
BUT- THE STRIKE TEAM HAD
EARLIER RECOMMENDED TO STOP
TRAINING AS YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE
NEED OUR FANS SUPPOSED TO BE
IT- RESOLVING CLAIMS. AND NOW
THAT. WE ARE MOVING THROUGH
THAT. THE TRAINING AND THE
HIRING IS A MORE OF A
CONTINUOUS BASIS SO THAT WHILE
WE'RE HIRING NINE HUNDRED FOLKS
THIS MONTH APRIL IT WILL BE
MORE CONTINUOUS AND IT'S NOT
JUST WHAT WE HAVE VACANCY. IT
IS ANTICIPATION OF VACANCIES
AND ANTICIPATION OF THE MOMENT
TRICIA RIGHT THAT WE HAVE WHICH
IS VERY HIGH THAT WILL KEEP US-
AT A HIGH. LEVEL TO RESPOND TO
CLIENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILLIAM OF READ MY MIND ABOUT
THE SECOND QUESTION BECAUSE I
WAS ON. ONE OF THE THINGS I'M
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT IS THE
EXPECTATIONS YOU'RE STUDYING
WITH US. AND OUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND THE DISCONNECT WITH THE
AUDITOR IS CLEAR STATEMENT THAT
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A VIEW OF A
MOUNTING BACKLOG. RIGHT AND
THEN YOU NEED IT YOU KNOW
THERE'S MORE THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE. WHAT I DON'T SEE IN THIS.
IS HOW YOU INTEND THE PLAN IN
THE NEXT SIX TO TWELVE MONTHS.
TO PREPARE FOR ANY MORE SURGES
IN ET DECLINES YOU KNOW IT'S
NOT LIKE ANYTHING IN THE LAST
YEAR HAS STAYED CONSTANT. IS
FLUCTUATED AND SEEMS LIKE YOU
SHOULD BE PLANNING FOR THAT SO
WHAT ARE YOU DOING RIGHT NOW TO
TRAIN PEOPLE ON FIRST CALL
RESOLUTION TO THE MORE FIRST
CALLED THE RESULT ON THE FIRST
CONTACT. THE LESS BACKLOG YOU
HAVE IN YOUR DO YOU HAVE A HUGE
BACKLOG. SO WHAT ARE YOU DOING
ON TRAINING- TO A TRAINING TO
INCREASE FIRST CALL RESOLUTION
RIGHT NOW TODAY TOMORROW YOU
KNOW NEXT WEEK. AND WHAT ARE
YOU DOING AND IF YOU CAN PLEASE
IDENTIFY. WHAT EDT SURGES YOU
EXPECT IN THE NEXT SIX TO
TWELVE MONTHS. AND WHAT YOU'RE
DOING TODAY TO PREPARE THEM SO
WE'RE NOT SITTING HERE IN SIX
MONTHS AND HAVE TO REPEAT. THIS
WHICH WE'VE ALL GONE THROUGH
FOR THE LAST YEAR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CAROL WILLIAMS. WHAT
WE'RE DOING TODAY IS. WELL LET
ME BACK UP ONE OF THE BIGGEST
EFFICIENCIES THAT EDT HAS
REALIZED WHICH HAS FREED UP
STAFF FROM MANUAL WORK WAS I
CAN BE IN OCTOBER WE CANNOT
PROCESS CLAIMS EFFICIENTLY IF
FOR HAVING TO TRY TO MANUALLY
ADJUST INTOTOUCH INTO PROCESS
CLAIMS AS WE HAVE BEEN- IN PAST
TIMES I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
MY TESTIMONY EARLIER WAS
CORRECT. PRIOR TO ID ME WE WERE
AT A 60% AUTOMATION 40% MANUAL
AND THAT 40% WAS HUGE I DID ME
YOU'RE NOW MANUALLY PROCESSING
CLAIMS AT A RATE OF 90% 89290%
BUT THAT LEAVES US 10% TO
TOUCH. THE MORE AUTOMATION THAT
WE CAN BRING IN IN AND THE
KRUGMAN'S IT FREES UP STAFF TO
WORK DIRECTLY WITH CLIENTS ON
THEIR MOST- OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT CALLS WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS WE'RE- WE'RE PRO
ACTIVELY NOW COMMUNICATING WITH
CLAIMANTS TO REDUCE THE COST
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
CALL AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE WERE
TEXTING. WOULD HONOR- WE ARE
CALLING TO MAKE AN OUTBOUND
CALLS QUITE HONESTLY TO CLAIM
IT'S BECAUSE THERE'S. PART OF
THE CLAIM PROCESS. WOMEN HAVE
TO COME BACK TO EATING AND
RESTART IF THEY'RE ELIGIBLE
EVERY TWO WEEK. YOU FILE YOUR
CLAIM ONCE BUT YOU HAVE TO
RETURN TO FIX THAT YOU CAN
STILL UNEMPLOYED AND YOU-
QUALIFY FOR BENEFITS. WELL OF
OUR CLIENTS. EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND RIGHT NOW HAVE NOT
RETURNED. IF THEY'RE NOT
RETURNING BECAUSE THEY ARE
BENDING THEIR THEIR CLAIMS
THAT'S FOR THE BEST REASON
THEY'RE NOT EMPLOYED RE EMPLOY.
BUT I FEAR IS THAT THERE'S
STILL COMMUNICATION GAP AND
THERE'S A LACK OF UNDERSTANDING
AND THE NEED TO RETURN AND
RECERTIFY AND THEIR CLAIM A
LITTLE THE SIT THERE SO THE
OUTBOUND COMMUNICATION CHANNELS
OVER CREATING THE CHAOS AND TAX
THAT I MENTIONED WE ARE
LITERALLY DOING TO MAKE SURE
FOLKS UNDERSTAND THE ENTIRE
PROCESS WE HAVE INFORMATION ON
THEIR YOU WILD ONLINE ACCOUNT.
AS WELL AS- THANK YOU TO BE
GOTTEN INTO VIDEOS MAKE IT IS
UNDERSTANDABLE AND IS LESS
COMPLICATED BECAUSE- THE
PROCESS WE HAVE PRESENTED IN A
VERY COMPLICATED WAY OVER TIME-
I'M TRYING TO DEMYSTIFY. THE
CLAIM FILING EXPERIENCE SO THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO CALL. IN
WHEN WE DO WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
AVAILABLE SO THE CONTINUED
HIRING. THE MODERNIZE TRAINING.
NOW THIRTEEN WEEKS NOT SIX
MONTHS. BE CREATING CHANNELS OF
COMMUNICATION PUSHING IT TO
CLAIMANTS WE ARE SEEING- DID
RESULT IN MATH BUT QUITE
HONESTLY WHEN WE BRING ON NEW
PROGRAMS AS WE HAVE NOW WITH
THE NEWS. YOU KNOW TEARS UP
ACT- THIS IS WHEN WE HAVE TO BE
MOST AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE THESE
ARE NEW PROGRAMS THAT ARE IN
PLACE- THEY'RE UNSURE OF THEIR
ELIGIBILITY AND BECAUSE WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE PEAKS WE
CONTINUE TO REALLY STOP OR IN
THE PART OF SERVICE. BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE CERTAINLY
LOOKING FOR AND THE DIRECTOR
SPOKE ABOUT OUR COMMAND CENTER.
THAT'S WHAT THE REASONS WHY IT
HAS BEEN CHALLENGING FOR EDT IN
THE PAST IN TERMS OF SERVICE IT
WAS DECENTRALIZED IT IS NOW
BEING CENTRALIZED SO ALL THE
COMPONENTS THE EFFICIENCIES
THAN. MODERN TOOLS AND QUITE
HONESTLY THE RIVER VIEW OF WHY
CLAIMANTS ARE CALLING AND THEIR
FEEDBACK AND TO ENSURE WE
UNDERSTAND HOW GOOD WE'RE DOING
WITH FIRST CALL RESOLUTION. IS
NOW WE HAVE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THAT AND WE HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THAT SO WE'LL BE ABLE TO
POINT OUT TO YOU AND HOPEFULLY
MORE THAN THAT WOULD. BE ABLE
TO DO BETTER. THANK YOU. IF I
IF I CAN ADD ON TO THAT AS
WELL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER I THINK
IT WAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
THAT MENTIONED YOU KNOW WE HAVE
TWO GOALS AT AT- AT EDS TO. YOU
KNOW PAY LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS
AND TO PREVENT FRAUD AND YOU
KNOW THEY OFTEN DO- YOU KNOW
INTERSECT BUT I THINK NOW THAT
WE HAVE. I KNOW NOW THAT WE
HAVE. YOU KNOW A DVD THAT SEES
YOU KNOW 35% OR SO OF- ATTENDED
APPLICANTS LIKE THEY STOP THEM
AT BASS STOP THEM. YOU KNOW AND
THEN WE ALSO HAVE THOMSON
REUTERS- AS OUR FRONT DOOR DOOR
CHECK. ON FRIDAY THAT WE CAN
THEN REALLOCATE THOSE RESOURCES
THAT WE WERE SPENDING A HUGE
CHUNK OF YOU KNOW ONE AND TWO.
ON FRAUD. ON THAT WE CAN NOW WE
ALLOCATE THOSE PEOPLE TO
PAYMENT LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS
AND THAT'S ANOTHER- I THINK
IT'S A THING THAT HAPPENS THAT
YOU KNOW. WE SEE INTERNALLY AT
EDT BUT- I THINK IT'S GOING TO
MAKE A HUGE. DIFFERENCE TO BE
HONEST HELLO. THANK YOU. GOOD-
THANK YOU MISTER FORMER IRVINE
MR PATTERSON IS NEXT THEN
MISSED CAREER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THE AREA THAT I'D LIKE
TO- EXPLORE HERE HAS A LOT TO
DO WITH WHAT AMOUNTS TO THE
COLLATERAL DAMAGE. TO THOSE WHO
HAVE PLAYED BY THE RULES THOSE
WHO DID EVERYTHING THAT EDT ASK
THEM TO DO. AND THEY HAVE BEEN
CAUGHT. IN EMBARRASSING AND IN-
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT I THINK ARE
THE DIRECT RESULT. OF WHAT THE
AUDITOR HAS FOUND. MY OFFICE.
HAS PROCESS BEEN IS PROCESSING
RIGHT NOW. THREE THOUSAND
CONSTITUENT CASES. ALL ABOUT E.
D. D. OUR CALL VOLUMES ARE NOT
GOING DOWN THERE GOING BACK A-
THE CALLS THAT WE ARE GETTING.
TO OUR OFFICE R. AS DESPERATE
AS THEY HAVE BEEN- AND SO I
JOIN WITH OTHER COLLEAGUES HERE.
IN SAYING THERE ARE FACES THERE
ARE REAL PEOPLE. PEOPLE THAT I
HAVE KNOWN IN FRESNO MY
LIFETIME. I WAS THE MAYOR THERE
FOR EIGHT YEARS I HAVE RADIO
STATIONS IN THE AREA I NOW
REPRESENT THEM IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THEIR MESSAGE
TO YOU. PLEASE HEAR OUR CRY.
THE BUREAUCRATIC IMPEDIMENTS
HERE HAVE BEEN THOROUGHLY LAID
OUT IN THE WATER. BUT I WANT
YOU TO HEAR THE VOICES OF
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T IN THIS ROOM.
BUT WHO I KNOW AND WHO MY
OFFICE HAS DEALT WITH. I WANT
TO FIRST ASK A QUESTION ABOUT-
THE DEBIT CARDS. THOSE DEBIT
CARDS WERE THE LIFELINE. THEY
WERE ESSENTIALLY UNILATERALLY
FROZEN. THE RESULT OF THAT HAS
MEANT. THAT I HAVE RECEIVED
PHONE CALLS FROM FRIENDS OF
MINE IN THE DISTRICT. WHO WERE
STANDING THAT THE CASH REGISTER.
AT THE GROCERY STORE. AND HAD
THEIR CAR DENIED. SO THEY NOT
ONLY HAD TO WALK OUT OF THERE
WITH NO. FOOD THEY WERE
PUBLICLY EMBARRASSED. OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE THE EARLY
WARNING SYSTEM WITH RESPECT TO
THE FAILURES OF. EDT. AND I
WANT TO ASK A QUESTION ABOUT.
WHAT WELL I GUESS I HAVE TO
LOOK AT THIS IS. THIS IS SORT
OF A THIS IS SORT OF A KICKBACK
SCHEME. WE HAVE CONSTITUENTS.
WHO HAVE BEEN COMMUNICATING
WITH US SAYING. THAT THE FEES
CHARGED ON THEIR DEBIT CARD.
THEY ARE PAYING FOR. SO I WANT
TO ASK THE QUESTION MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE IS A FEE
SHARING CONTRACT. THAT FEE
SHARING CONTRACT. SPLITS IN
SOME DEGREE THESE DAYS BETWEEN
BANK OF AMERICA N. EDT. A
CENTURY PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING
FORCED TO PAY FOR THE PRIVILEGE
OF GETTING THEIR OWN
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FROM
PEOPLE WHO CAN BARELY BUY
GROCERIES. FIRST OF ALL I WANNA
KNOW THE JUSTIFICATION. FOR
THIS PLEA THAT THAT THE SPLIT.
AND I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
PERCENTAGES AND- HOW MUCH IS
THE PERCENTAGE OF THE OF THE
CHARGE. AND WHAT IS THE SPLIT
BETWEEN EDIE DM BANK OF AMERICA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NATIVE AREAS
WITH EDT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
GET BACK TO ON THAT I DO KNOW
WHAT YOU HAVE ARTICULATED I AM
AWARE OF THAT HOWEVER I AM NOT
AWARE OF THE EXACT SPLIT- I.
WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK AND LOOK
AT THE CONTRACT. I'M GET THAT
INFORMATION TO YOU- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU SHOULD KNOW IS
THAT THIS IS A TYPICAL TYPE OF
ARRANGEMENT. MADE BY BENEFIT
PROGRAMS- JOHN. ACTUALLY
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG THE
STATE WE ARE NOT ACTUALLY HEY.
BANK OF AMERICA THIS IS HOW
THEY GET PAID CORRECT IT'S A
ZERO DOLLAR CONTRACT CORRECT.
IS IT NOT A FACT THAT THE-
EXTRACTION OF THAT. PERCENTAGE
FIFTY COMES OUT OF THE PROCEEDS
THAT WOULD BE GOING TO THESE
INDIVIDUALS. I I'M NOT 1100%
SURE ON HOW THE CONTRACT IS
STRUCTURED I APOLOGIZE AND WE
CAN CERTAINLY GET BACK TO YOU.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE- I JOIN-
OTHER MEMBERS. WE'VE BEEN
ASKING FOR THIS INFORMATION FOR
A LONG TIME. AND I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT I'M JOINING WITH THE
MEDIA THAT HAS BEEN ASKING THIS
REPEATEDLY OF YOUR OPERATION
ONLY TO BE TOLD. I'LL GET BACK
TO YOU. THIS IS PUBLIC RECORDS
PUBLIC DOCUMENTATION WE SHOULD
KNOW WHAT YOU SHOULD KNOW AND
BE ABLE TO EXPRESS IT TO US.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT THIS IS
MY EX IS ALSO SIR IT'S ALSO MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A COPY OF THE
CONTRACT. SO IT'S NOT LIKE
WE'RE TRYING TO HIDE IT FROM
YOU BUT WE DO WANT TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH ACCURATE INFORMATION.
I CANNOT SPECULATE ON WHY. THE
INFORMATION IS NOT SHARED WITH
YOU PREVIOUSLY BUT YOU WILL GET
NOW. YEAH I WANT TO LOOK AT THE
DETAILS BUT IT'S THE IT'S THE
BOTTOM LINE HERE. WHERE PEOPLE
WHO ARE BARELY HANGING ON OR
HAVING THEIR DEBIT CARDS. ARE
FROZEN AND THEN ON TOP OF ALL
OF THAT. THEY END UP HAVING TO
PAY FEES FOR THE PRIVILEGE. I
MEAN THIS THIS HAS TO BE ON
WILD AND IT HAS TO BE.
EXPLAINED OTHER COLLATERAL
DAMAGES YEAH. YEAH LET DOWN THE
GUARD RAILS. IT NOT ONLY OPEN
THE TV APP FOR FRAUD. BUT IT
ALSO OPEN IT UP FOR IDENTITY
THEFT. AND I RECEIVED COUNTLESS
CALLS FROM PEOPLE IN THE
DISTRICT ARE SCARED TO DEATH.
THAT THEIR OWN EMPLOYMENT. WAS
TAKEN BY SOMEBODY ELSE. AND
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO RECEIVE.
A TEN NINETY NINE G. I THEY'RE
GOING TO YOU'RE GOING TO BE
FLOODED. WITH CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE GOING TO BE SEEING WHAT
THEIR TAXES ARE GOING TO LOOK
LIKE. AND YET THEY EITHER
DIDN'T FILE OR THEY HAD. THEIR
ON EMPLOYMENT TAKEN BY
FRAUDSTERS. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THERE'S BEEN A- PHONE.
NUMBER STOOD UP FOR PEOPLE TO
CALL. AND I TRY TO GET THIS
RESOLVED. I HAVE NOW A GROWING
LONG LIST OF MEMBERS IN MY
COMMUNITY WHO CANNOT. GET
THROUGH THAT PHONE NUMBER. SO
HERE WE HAVE ANOTHER PHONE
NUMBER IN A CURRENTLY A CALL
CENTER- THAT IS FAILING OFF A
LOT OF MY CONSTITUENTS. LOOK
EDT. YOU'VE GOT TO CORRECT THIS.
AND THE ONLY WAY IT SEEMS TO ME
IS THAT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
ZERO OUT. THESE THESE THESE TAX
FORM SHOWING. AN TO ASK PEOPLE
TO GO THROUGH. A LONG
CONVOLUTED PROCESS OF
EXPLAINING THAT THEY DIDN'T GET
THEIR BENEFITS. AND YET THEY'RE
BEING TAXED FOR IT. NOW THE
ONUS YOU'RE GOING TO PUT THE
ONUS ON THEM TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT IT'S A HARDSHIP. SO WE
KNOW THE FROM APRIL THROUGH
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY. EDT
RESPONDED TO LESS THAN 2% OF
THE FRAUD REPORTS ONLINE.
HERE'S WHAT THE AUDITOR HAS
SAID. YOU NEED TO PUT UP ON THE
WEBSITE FOR CUSTOMERS. AN EMAIL.
SO THAT THEY CAN QUICKLY GET A
RESOLUTION AND THE AUDITOR SAYS
THEY WOULD LIKE THAT RESOLUTION
ON THE WEBSITE POSTED CLEARLY
TO SEE BY MID FEBRUARY. WHEN
WILL THIS HAPPEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NANCY VARIOUS- I BELIEVE
THAT IT IS UP ON THE WEBSITE
NOW IT IS OUR ASK ET DE IT'S A
DROP DOWN MENU AND THEN EMAIL
AUTOMATICALLY GOES THERE'S A
DROP DOWN FOR THE TEN NINETY
NINE- QUESTION I BELIEVE THAT
WAS PUT UP- I CAN'T REMEMBER
BUT IT WAS RECENTLY LAST WEEK
OR SO. OR SO. IS THAT A VERY
CLEAR ICON WITH RESPECT TO TEN
NINETY NINE IN OTHER WORDS THE
AUDITOR HAS SAID. IT HAS TO BE
RIGHT IN FRONT OF THEIR FACE
AND IT HAS TO BE A CLEAR ONE
CLICK. TO TELLING ME THEY GOT
TO GO THROUGH A DROP DOWN TO
GET THEIR- IT IS BUT I BELIEVE
IT'S ON THE TEN NINETY NINE
PAGE WE HAVE- A PAGE OF
INFORMATION ON THE TEN NINETY
NINES AND IT IS PART OF. ON
THAT PAGE. SO IF SOMEONE IS
LOOKING FOR TEN NINETY NINE
INFORMATION THAT WOULD BE PART
OF THAT PAGE. PRECISELY WHAT.
WILL YOU BE DOING. WITH PEOPLE
WHO CONTACT YOU TELLING YOU THE
STORY THAT I JUST TOLD YOU
ABOUT CONSTITUENTS. HOW ARE YOU
PLANNING TO ON WIND OF THE
PROBLEM. THAT YOU CREATED. BY
TAKING DOWN THE GUARD RAILS AND
BY PROVIDING. TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PIECES OF MAIL GOING OUT
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WITH SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS AND NAMES AND
ADDRESSES AND- YOU CREATED
THIS. YOU'VE GOT ON WIDER FOR
THESE PEOPLE HOW DO YOU INTEND
TO DO THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CAROL WILLIAMS. WE'RE IN
WINDING THAT- FIRST AND
FOREMOST LET ME START WITH WITH
WHAT'S MOST PRESSING OR ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT'S PRESSING. OF
THIS WEEK OR LATE LAST WEEK
WE'VE BEEN PUSHING OUT
INFORMATION IT'S ON OUR
WEBSITE- AND IT'S TAX
INFORMATION IT IS FROM THE IRS
BECAUSE THIS IS ABSOLUTELY A
NATIONAL NATIONWIDE PROBLEM.
THESE TEN NINETY NINE JEEZ.
THAT- THEY'RE NOT EALIZING
CLAIMS ARE FILED IN IN THEIR
OWN. IT USING THEIR SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER I'M OUT IN JUST
A SECOND I WILL TELL YOU
EXACTLY HOW WE ARE UNWINDING
THAT WE WORK WITH THEM. BUT
FROM A TAX PERSPECTIVE THE
IRISES MESSAGE THEY'RE PUSHING
IT OUT WE'RE PUSHING OUT OUT
OUT AS WELL IS DUE TO THIS
NATIONWIDE CRISIS- TAXPAYERS
ARE BEING REQUESTED. AND
ENCOURAGED TO FILE AS
APPROPRIATE MEETING. WHAT LOBBY
MIGHT HAVE A TEN NINETY NINE
INCOME IN THEIR POSSESSION BUT
THEY WERE NOT RECEIVING THOSE
FUNDS IRISES DIRECTION IS DON'T
REPORT IT. THAT'S FIRST AND
FOREMOST BECAUSE YOUR STATE
AGENCY WILL CATCH UP AND GIVE
YOU THAT CORRECTED TEN NINETY
NINE THAT WAS ZERO OUT- THOSE
RECEIPTS SO. HOW DO. YOU HOW DO
YOU INTEND TO CATCH UP. YOUR IN
OTHER WORDS YOU'RE SUGGESTING.
DON'T REPORT IT SOONER OR LATER
I'M LOOK PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
GET REAL SCARED ABOUT NOT
REPORTING TEN NINETY NINES.
UNDERSTOOD WHAT HE UNDERSTOOD
THAT IF THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU
WHAT ARE THE BILL'S GOING TO
SAY IS THAT THE DON'T
REPORTING. NO NO NO NO I'M
GIVING YOU THE TOP LINE FOR THE
JUST FOR THE TAX SITUATION WHEN
THEY CONTACT US AND THE FASTEST
WAY WILL BE THROUGH. THE ONLINE
BECAUSE WHEN THEY GO THROUGH
THE- ASK EDT THE TIME I DO MY
LINK- DID FRAUD. THERE WILL BE
A PRE FILLED WORK SEE AND THAT
SHE WILL BE ASKING THE
QUESTIONS THAT ALIGN AGENT
WOULD ASK IT'S INFORMATION THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO DETERMINE. THE
TRUE CLAIM IT FROM THE
FRAUDSTER AND SEPARATE THEIR
TRUE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
SOME THAT CLAIM AND THE LAST
STEP IS TO. ZERO OUT OF TEN
NINETY NINE G. AND SEND THAT TO
THE TRUE INDIVIDUAL THE VICTIM
SO THAT'S THE HIGH LEVEL OF THE
OF THE PROCESS. OR DID TO US.
YOU WERE UNABLE TO DEFER
BETWEEN FOR AND REAL CLAIMANTS
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
FRAUDSTERS AND REAL CLAIMANTS
BY A BY A CLAIM OF THE
INDIVIDUAL. THAT I DIDN'T GET
THIS. AND THERE'S AND SPECIFIC
INFORMATION TO THEM HOW THEIR
ADDRESS HOW LONG DO THEY LIVE
THERE CAN BE SUBSTANTIAL THINGS
THAT THE FRAUDSTER WOULD NOT BE
IN POSSESSION OF. THEM CAN YOU
GIVE US AN IDEA OF WHAT KIND OF
AN HAVE ACTIVITY YOU HAVE SEEN
IN THAT PORTAL. IT'S BUSY IT IS
TAX TIME AND WE ARE SENDING OUT
UPWARDS OF SEVEN MILLION TEN
NINETY NINE BUT I CAN'T TELL
YOU THOUGH. WE'VE DONE OUR BEST
TO THE PROPERLY THROUGH THE
IRISH GUIDELINES WITHHOLD
SENDING TEN NINETY NINES THAT
WE ABSOLUTELY- CLEAR
INDICATIONS OF FRAUD SO YES
IT'S NOT PERFECT. FOLKS ARE
RECEIVING THEM STILL THAT DID
NOT- FILE FOR BENEFITS
POTENTIALLY AND WE HAVE TO WORK
WITH THEM ONE ON ONE TWO. TO
CLEAR THEM OF THAT REPORTING.
AGAIN I HAVE RESERVATIONS ABOUT
THE CLAIM THAT YOU CAN DO ALL
OF THESE THINGS WHEN YOU DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY FOR THE
FUNDAMENTAL THINGS ARE DOING.
UNDERSTOOD I DIED UNDERSTOOD.
START WITH THE- THAT'S WHY I
STARTED WITH THE TOP LINE THAT
IF THEY DID NOT RECEIVE A TIME
IN MIND THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED TO
REPORT ON THEIR TAXES BUT I'M
I'M WONDERING ONE FILER THE
CLAWBACK. HOW MANY PEOPLE AND
HOW MUCH IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY YOU KNOW THIS UNIQUE
WITH THEIR PROCESS TO DETERMINE
AYE YOU APPLICANTS. CLEAR
ELIGIBILITY. WE THINK THERE'S
SOMETHING LIKE TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION I THINK THE AUDITOR HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT. THE ORTEZ IS
GOING TO BE THREE MILLION HOURS.
TO CLEAR THIS UP. DOES THE EDT
REALLY IN TEN. TO MAKE THESE
PEOPLE WHO DID NOTHING WRONG
AND FOLLOW THE RULES EVEN WHEN
YOU LOWER THE RULES SEND THEM
BACK AND CHECK. SEND THEM BACK
MONEY. HELLO THIS IS KIND OF
MILITARY FOR THE QUESTION- SO
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO APPROACH
THESE OVER BANKS ON A CASE BY
CASE BASIS- BECAUSE AS YOU SAY
THEY'RE- GONNA BE LOOKING AT.
THERE ARE NONE OF THE FOLKS WHO
HAVE BEEN RECEIVED BENEFITS
FROM US WHO MAY HAVE AN
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP- YEAH THIS IS
A SITUATION WHERE- SOMEONE
WHO'S BEEN INCARCERATED IN
COLLECTED BENEFITS THEY'RE
CLEARLY NOT GONNA MEET AND
HARDSHIP REQUIREMENTS WILL BE
DOING. EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR
POWER TO RECOUP THOSE FUNDS-
AMONGST THE MANY MECHANISMS WE
HAVE TO DO SO. AS IT RELATES
TO. ONE ESSENTIAL WORKER WHO
MAY HAVE COLLECTED BENEFITS ON
A WEEK IN WHICH THEY WORK AND
THERE WAS SOME CONFUSION ON
THEIR PART ABOUT. WHAT TO
REPORT AND WE WILL WORK WITH
THEM TO COMPLY HARDSHIP
PROVISIONS ALLOWED. WITHIN OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE AUTHORITY TO.
ACTUALLY WAVE THAT OUT OVER.
ALL RIGHT YOU SAW THE AD OF THE
AUDITORS. GRAPHICS ON THIS.
WHERE THERE WAS A TYPICAL
INDIVIDUAL. LEGITIMATELY
ELIGIBLE FOR. THEIR BENEFITS.
WHEN YOU LOWERED THE
REQUIREMENTS OF REPORTING. THAT
INDIVIDUAL. WORKED UP SOME PART
TIME. AND IN FACT. NOTIFY DDD.
AND THE RESULT WAS BETTER AT
WAS THAT EDT NOW DETERMINED
THAT THEY WERE AT FAULT. AND
THAT THEY NOW HAVE TO. CLAIM A
HARDSHIP WHY DO PEOPLE. TO GET
ALL THE RULES FOLLOWED ANSWER
YOUR QUESTIONS. THEN WERE
DEEMED SOMEHOW OVERPAID WHEN
YOU. PUT THE RULES BACKUP OF
WHATEVER. WHY DO THEY HAVE TO
CLAIM A HARDSHIP BEG FOR YOUR
FORGIVENESS WHEN IT WAS EDT
THAT DID IT TO THEM WHY CAN'T
YOU FIGURE THAT OUT FOR
YOURSELF AND DEAL WITH THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. WELL LET ME SAY IN
THE FIRST PLACE. YOU HAVE AN
APPRECIATION FOR THE DIFFICULT
TO WORK ON. WELL THIS IS ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT I WELCOME.
SKINNER SO CONSTRUCTING THESE
THINGS OUT. MARK KEVIN WOULD
YOU FOR. RESPOND TO THIS
QUESTION. YEAH I THINK IT
DOESN'T PERTAIN TO TRYING TO
GET SOME OF THESE FUNDS BACK
FOR FOLKS WHO YOU KNOW MAY HAVE
BEEN. RIGHT OR BENEFIT STERLING
AUTO CERTIFICATION WE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ADDITIONAL.
BURDEN OF ON WORKING THROUGH
POTENTIAL HARDSHIP WAIVER
REQUEST. HOWEVER AS YOU
MENTIONED BY- CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE THERE IS A- WE
DON'T WANT EMPLOYERS TO BE
CHARGED FOR FUNDS NECESSARILY
IN THE BAY- THE WORD GIVEN TO
BENEFIT. CORPORATE TO
INDIVIDUAL THROUGH PROVIDED
BENEFITS- WINDOWS INDIVIDUALS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PAY. BACK
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE YOU KNOW
FOR THESE FOLKS WHO ARE IN
CASES WHERE THEY ARE OBVIOUSLY
DEFRAUDING THE DEPARTMENT WHERE
YOU NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO RECOUP THOSE FUNDS-
WITHOUT DOING A SORT OF BLANKET
WAIVER OF THE- OF ALL THE OVER
PAYMENT DOLLARS. YOU NEED TO
LOOK AT THEM ANA ON AN
INDIVIDUAL BASIS TO GATHER SOME
FACTS SO. OR INTENT IS TO BE A
BIT MORE SURGICAL APPROACH TO
COLLECTING THOSE FUNDS BACK-
ALSO PROVIDE AN AVENUE FOR
PEOPLE. WHO ARE HAVING
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. AND WHILE
IT'S- OBVIOUSLY. AN IDEAL THE
THERE WOULD BE AN- A
INTERACTION THEY WOULD HAVE TO
HAVE PART. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT FURTHER PUTTING
PEOPLE AND ECONOMIC DISTRESS-
IF TAKING THOSE FUNDS BACK
WOULD DO STUFF. WELL AGAIN I.
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT TO-
ANSWER THE QUESTION BUT IT
SOUNDS MORE LIKE YOU'RE DODGING
AROUND MY BASIC POINT. THAT
BASIC POINT IS YOU WERE THE
FOLKS THAT PULLED DOWN THE
GUARDRAILS. DURING THAT PERIOD
OF TIME. THOSE INDIIDUALS
REPORTED TO YOU THAT THEY
WORKED A LITTLE WHILE. RIGHT
AND THEN THERE CAUGHT UP. IN A
CLUB IT WAS YOUR LACK OF
OVERSIGHT AND YOUR UNILATERAL
REDUCTION OF THE GUARDRAILS.
THAT OPENED THAT PERSON WHO
FOLLOWED ALL YOUR RULES AND
REPORTED TO BE NOW IN A
POSITION TO BE CLAWED BACK.
DOZEN TDS HAVE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT
ACTIVITY OF COURSE OF COURSE-
EDT HAS SOME RESPONSIBIITY SO
LET ME RESPOND TO THAT SO THAT
WE DON'T GO ARE YOU FAR IN THIS.
YOU HEARD A NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS ABOUT HOW. CAN YOU
BRING THEM UP YOURSELF ABOUT
HOW EASY HE- ACTS THE
GUARDRAILS. THIS HARDSHIP- THE
RULES AND REGULATIONS THAT ARE
YOU KNOW SHOULD PEOPLE BE TO
STOP BECAUSE THEY DID
EVERYTHING RIGHT AND THEN WHAT
HAPPENED ONCE EACH QUARTER UP
AND YOU KNOW OF COURSE THEY
SHOULD BE ARE YOU CAN'T BLAME
THEM FOR THAT HOWEVER WE ARE
NOT GOING TO DO THIS WEBI OF
THE GUARD RAILS. ALL OVER AGAIN.
FIND AT THE WE HAVE LET PEOPLE
IN WITH ALL THE PAYMENTS. OKAY
AND PAY THEM BACK I SHOULD
NEVER HAVE CLEANED UP NOW IF
YOU'RE ASKING THIS IS GARCIA OR
MISTER THOMPSON WHO DIDN'T
QUITE UNDERSTAND THE COLOR OR
THE DIRECTIONS ARE WE GOING TO
CHASE AFTER THEM TO GET THEIR
MONEY NO WE'RE NOT WE HAVE A
PROCESS FOR THAT AND WE'LL KNOW
MORE WHISKEY THE PROCESS THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT YOU WALL
INSISTED ON AND WE WANT YOU TO
KNOW WE TAKE IT SERIOUSLY SO WE
WILL DO OUR BEST TO ENSURE
THESE PEOPLE GET WHAT THEY
NEED. BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T RELEASED THE
GUARDRAILS AGAIN. WELL AGAIN
I'M GOING TO CLOSE THIS IS-
I'VE BEEN A VERY FRUSTRATING-
PERIOD OF TIME FOR PEOPLE IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. AS I SAID
WE PROCESS THREE THOUSAND. IN
OUR DISTRICT ALONE. AND YOU'RE
GONNA BE HEARING. FROM US AND
YOU'RE GONNA BE HEARING FROM
OTHER MEMBERS AND YOU'RE GOING
TO BE HEARING FROM THE PUBLIC
THE PROBLEMS ARE STILL THERE
THE INNOCENT ONES WHO PLAY BY
THE RULES ARE STILL GETTING
HURT WE'RE STILL SEEING FRAUD
WE'RE STILL SEEING DELAYS WE'RE
STILL SEEING DEBIT CARDS.
FROZEN THAT'S STATUS QUO HAS TO
END IT HAS TO END NOW. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MR PATTERSON-
MISS CARILLO IS NEXT AND SHOULD
BE FOLLOWED BY SENATOR BAKER
AND THEN ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RANDY VOEPEL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- INTO THE BOTH
CHAIRS WERE FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT HEARING AND HELLO TO
TWO FIVE HELLO TO THOSE OF YOU
AGAIN- FROM EDT THE DIRECTOR
AND THE STAFF OR FOR AGAIN
DOING THIS HEARING AND- IT
SEEMS LIKE SEVERAL OF THE
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS THAT ARE
BEING ASKED HERE WERE ALSO
ASKED AND BUDGET UP FOR. A JUST
A ABOUT A WEEK OR SO AGO TIME
KIND OF. BLENDON ALTOGETHER BUT
I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS REGARDING
A CMMENT THAT MISS SIGNS MADE
EARLIER TODAY- REGARDING
LEADERSHIP AT EIGHTY. SO I'M
I'M CURIOUS TO KNOW HOW MANY.
DEPUTY DIRECTORS OF
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. HAS THE
DEPARTMENT HAD IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS. GREAT QUESTION OF
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG. ALL I
THINK WE HAVE LOST THREE.
TWENTY TWENTY WELL ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S CURRENT THANK YOU. WE'VE
WE'VE HEARD FOR OF YOU WANT TO
DO DIRECTORS OVER THE LAST. THE
CURRENT VACANCY. SO THERE HAVE
BEEN FOUR DEPUTY DIRECTORS OF
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE THAT
REPORT TO THE SECRETARY OF
LABOR IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS. I
WANNA MAKE THAT VERY CLEAR IS
THAT ACCURATE- I'M SORRY I
THOUGHT YOU WERE ASKING SOLELY
ABOUT THE U. Y. MANAGERS SO- I
THINK YOU'RE ASKING THE
DIRECTORS OF THE E. D. MY WRONG
NO I WAS ASKING ABOUT YOU I
DIRECTORS. SPECIFIC OKAY ARE.
NOT YES BOB WHO IS THE CURRENT
DIRECTOR OF YOU I. IS VACANT
HOW LONG HAS THIS BEEN BAY WE
HAVE. A WEEK. WEEK TWO WEEKS A
WEEK TWO WEEKS AND WE HAVE A
THREE NEED. HI FOLKS WHO HAVE A
LOT OF EXPERIENCE DOWN THERE.
THERE ARE STILL TAKING
LEADERSHIP RIGHT NOW. HOW LONG
WAS THE PERSON ACTING AS THE U.
R. DIRECTOR IN THE POSITION. NO
THE DIRECTOR THAT JUST LEFT
WAS- IN THE POSITION FOR THREE
MONTHS. OKAY AND THEN WE HAVE
NOW THERE THE OTHERS ARE IN-
ACTING ROLE. TO FILL THAT SPOT
I AM I'M ASKING BECAUSE IT'S
INCREDIBLY INCONSISTENT TO ME
RIGHT TO WHAT YOU'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING AND I CAN SEE HOW.
HOW IS THE DEPARTMENT OF NOT
HAVING CONSISTENT LEADERSHIP.
IS AN INCREDIBLE CHALLENGE AS
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PANDEMIC
IT WAS ALREADY A CHALLENGE IN
TERMS OF THE DIRECTION OF THE
DEPARTMENT BUT EVEN MORE SO
NOW. AND NOW WITH THE SECRETARY
OF LABOR ALSO LEAVING THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND JOINING THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION. AND
THEN UNDERSECRETARY'S POSITION
WHO HAS NOT BEEN FILLED IN OVER
A YEAR WHO IS ACTUALLY
RESPONSIBLE. AND TAKING
ACCOUNTABILITY. FOR THE CURRENT
SITUATION THAT WE ARE AND. THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION. I AM
THE PERSON WHO IS RESPONSIBLE.
AND I AM THE PERSON WHO IS
GOING TO BE ACCOUNTABLE. I
APPRECIATE THAT DIRECTOR SIGNS
AND YOU COMING IN AND TAKING
OWNERSHIP OF THE POSITION BUT I
WANT TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR. TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA- AND
REALLY TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THAT
THE INCONSISTENCY IN
LEADERSHIP- ADNAN D. D. HAS LED
US. TO THIS INCREDIBLE PROBLEMS
AFFECTING MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND A LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WITH THE AGENCY- AND INABILITY
TO MOVE FORWARD AND THEN
ABILITY TO CREATING SYSTEMS AND
AN ABILITY TO HEED THE ADVICE
GIVEN IN TERMS OF- THE YEARS OF
NEGLECT WITHIN A TECHNOLOGY AND
A DEPARTMENT THAT. FAILS TO
MEET CURRENT STANDARDS. IS NOT
A NEW PROBLEM IT IS A PROFIT IN
A CONSISTENT ISSUE WITH LACK OF
MANAGEMENT LEADERSHIP- ALL THE
ALL THE WAY ACROSS. CAN YOU
TELL US- WHEN THE NEW EDT-
SYSTEM WILL BE UP. NOT IN THE
NEAR FUTURE AND LET ME TELL YOU
WHY. THE PROCESS OF STANDING UP
THE NEW SYSTEM IS HIGHLY. OF
INTENSIVE REQUIRES THAT PEOPLE
WHO ARE YOU ARE AND THEN I. T.
B. TAKEN AWAY FROM THEIR
CURRENT RESPONSIBILITIES. TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE DEVELOPMENT
OF NEW BUSINESS PROCESSES. AND
TO REVIEW THE KINDS OF
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE. SO RIGHT NOW WE
ARE GOING TO GET THE JOB BEFORE
IT'S DONE. THESE ARE THE ISSUE
OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES WILL BE
SOMETHING THAT. WE WILL LOOK AT
MORE CLOSELY WHEN WE START UP
THE BSM SYSTEM AGAIN YES I'M
PROJECT AGAIN. A LOCAL REQUIRE-
AND ANYONE WHO DEALS WITH
TECHNOLOGY- HAS APPRECIATION
FOR THIS. YOU REALLY HAVE TO
PULL PEOPLE OUT OF WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AND HAVE THEM OUTSIDE THE
BUSINESS PROCESSES AND WHAT
BUSINESS PROCESSES COULD BE
IMPROVED AND WHAT DIRECTION IN
ADDITION TO THE I. T. PEOPLE
COLLUDING WITH THE VENDOR TO
DEVELOP IN THE SYSTEM. IS THERE
AN ADDITIONAL SYSTEM THAT'S
BEING CREATED THAT'S SPECIFIC
TO P. YOU ARE SORRY POS. NO ALL
DIRECTOR SIGNED BY I HATE TO BE
THE ONE TO POINT THIS OUT TO
YOU BUT- LABOR SECRETARY JULIE
SUE WAS IN A TOWN HALL JUST
RECENTLY WITH SENATOR HENRY
STERN WHERE ACTUALLY I'M I'M
READING AND FOLLOWING HIS
TWITTER ACCOUNT WHERE HE SAID
SPECIFICALLY UPDATE P. UA
UNEMPLOYMENT OF MONEY TIMELINE
FOLLOWING YESTERDAY'S TOWN HALL
LABOR SECRETARY JULIE SU SAYS
NEW EDT SYSTEM WILL DELIVER P.
WAY PAYMENT IN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS UPON APPLICATION THE NEW
PLATFORM WILL BE UP IN TWO
WEEKS BENEFITS WILL DATE BACK
TO THE FIRST WEEK OF FEBRUARY.
R. O. OKAY THAT'S VERY EASILY
EXPLAINABLE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IN ADDITION TO THE CURRENT
SYSTEM. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
UPDATE USING MODULES THAT
ADDRESS A PARTICULAR- ISSUE
LIKE THE P. WHERE'S YOUR
PRODUCT. SO I PUT IN MY MIND
THE SYSTEM IS A WHOLE NEW LEVEL
OF BASIC PLATFORM SO MY MISTAKE
I WAS ARE MISINTERPRETED WHAT
YOU SAID. THAT LAST WEEK WE
HAVE WE ARE REGULARLY ADDING
MODULES TO THE CURRENT SYSTEM
AND THOSE ARE UPDATES. OKAY I
THINK PART OF THE- THE
SITUATION THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES IN IS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO CATCH UP TO
INFORMATION. AND THESE HEARINGS
ARE IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE NEED
TO GET ON THE SAME PAGE SO WHEN
LEGISLATORS ARE ASKING ARE
FRUSTRATED ABOUT SYSTEMS AND
SYSTEMS NOT WORKING AND- BEING
REFERRED BACK TO OFFICES OF THE
LEGISLATURE ACROSS THE STATE WE
DON'T HAVE THE SYSTEMS WE DON'T
HAVE THE INFORMATION THAT YOU
HAVE SO WHAT WE WANNA DO IS. BE
SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING ON THE
SAME PAGE IN TERMS OF WHAT ARE
THE CHANGES THE CHANGES THAT
YOU ARE IMPLEMENTING BECAUSE ON
ONE POINT YOU'RE SAYING IT'S
NOT GONNA HAPPEN FOR QUITE SOME
TIME. YET THERE ARE CHANGES
TAKING PLACE RIGHT NOW. TO
IMPROVE THE SYSTEM. AS A PART
OF THE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY PROCESS IS
ACTUALLY LETTING US KNOW WHAT
ARE THE CHANGES. THAT ARE
TAKING PLACE AND THEY SHOULDN'T
BE IN SILO WITH ONE MEMBER OF
EITHER HOUSE WHO HAPPENS TO
HAVE A TOWN HALL. WITH THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. SO IN IN THE
HEARING THAT WE HAD LAST WEEK
THAT I CHAIRED A BUDGET SUB
FLOOR. WE CAME TO AN AGREEMENT
THAT ANY NEW INFORMATION WILL
BE SENT TO THE ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE SO THAT WE ARE ALL
ON THE SAME PAGE. AND I WOULD
LIKE IT'S NOT UNHEARD. I GOT IS
NOT A REASONABLE REQUEST WELL I
WOULD LIKE A CONFIRMATION FROM
YOU AS TO WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
CAN EXPECT. DIRECT
COMMUNICATION FROM YOUR OFFICE
TO EACH OF OUR OFFICE SO THAT
WE'RE NOT FINDING INFORMATION
VIA TWITTER. I UNDERSTAND SAY
AND- WE ARE ALREADY. THROUGH
THE MICHIGAN SO WE'RE HAVING TO
BUY WEEKLY MEETINGS THAT WERE
HAPPENING. I THINK WE PROBABLY
GET TO WEEKLY MEETINGS KEVIN.
BERMAN THOSE WITH. SO ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HAPPENS IS WE
MY UNDERSTANDING A LOT OF
INFORMATION IS GOING TO YOUR
STAFF. AND IF THAT'S NOT THE
RIGHT WAY TO DO IT. PLEASE LET
US KNOW AND WE'LL CHANGE THAT-
BUT OUR WATER BAR INFORMATION
DOESN'T GO OUT TO THE
LEGISLATURE- SO. THAT'S NOT
WORKING WILL IMPROVE IT. WELL I
YOU KNOW I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION
YOU'RE BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE
BY YOUR CONSTITUENTS WITH A
PERSONAL INTEREST IN THIS- AND-
OF. THE EXPECTED NUMBER HE
WEIGHS MORE INTERESTING THE
ACTUALLY ARE CONVEYED THAT TO.
WIDELY BRIEFINGS AND IN WRITING
SO- I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
BREAKDOWN IS BUT WE'LL GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF IT. OKAY IF I MAY
UM I THINK THERE BE A LITTLE
CONFUSED GOING ON ANOTHER
SEPARATE PERFORMED ON. HAULS
MARCH APRIL AND MAY OF TWENTY
TWENTY. I THINK THIS WILL BE
COMING FROM POSTPONED. APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY IN WHICH- WE WERE
ANNOUNCING. THE LAUNCH OF THE-
PROGRAM. IT WOULD BE ON. ET DEC
I'LL SO IT- SO THIS I DON'T
THINK THIS IS A NEW. OUR HOST
THAT WE'RE REFERRING SO JUST
WONDERING. MAKE SURE THAT THAT
WAS CLEAR I MEAN HAVE OF COURSE
IT IS OUR INTENTION TO SHARE-
UPDATES OR RELEASES OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN. A PLAN TO DO SO.
I JUST ONE. I'M SURE THERE'S
BEEN SOME SORT OF A BREAK OUT I
KNOW IT'S VERY INTERESTING-
NEVER SECRETARY STUDENT. WE
CONVEY THIS INFORMATION. SO
WE'LL SEE WHAT WENT WRONG THERE.
AND WHAT IS WHAT IS YOUR
EXPECTATION IN TERMS OF WHEN
WILL SOMEONE BE HIRED TO TAKE
ON THE NEW POSITION OF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF YOU I. WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF RECRUITING RIGHT NOW.
SO AS A- CAROL INDICATED SHE
WOULD HAVE TO BE. OUR THREE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ROTATING THE
RESPONSIBILITY AS WE SPEAK. AND
MY APOLOGIESTHAT THE TWEET IS-
FROM APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY-
AND SO THERE IS THERE ARE WHAT
THE EXPECTATION IS STILL THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WILL RECEIVE
UPDATED INFORMATION IN TERMS OF
HOW QUICKLY YOU'RE CHANGING
SYSTEMS ENOUGH DURING THE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE NEW
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE SYSTEM THAT
ARE CURRENTLY. IN THE PROCESS
THAT WOULD BE REALLY GREAT FOR
US TO KNOW INCLUDING LANGUAGE
COMPETENCY- IN ADDITION TO YOU
KNOW FOR INFORMATION THAT FOLKS
ARE ABLE TO GET ONLINE SO CALL
CENTER INFORMATION RESOURCES TO
THE CALL CENTER- LANGUAGE
BARRIERS AT CETERA. HELLO WORLD
AND GIVEN AND GIVEN THE
CHANGING OF THE CONSTANT
CHANGING OF LEADERSHIP-
DIRECTOR SIGNS I'M I'M REALLY
GRATEFUL TO YOU WHEN YOU'RE
COMMITMENT YOU'VE EXPRESSED IT
SEVERAL TIMES- IN SEVERAL
HEARINGS STEALING YOUR STUFF-
AND SO I KNOW THAT WE ARE IN A
PLACE OF HAVING TO MOVE FORWARD
AND FIND SOLUTIONS. FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WE WILL
THE STATE IS IN A INTERESTING
POSITION AND THAT IT HAS NOT
REPLACED THE UNDERSECRETARY OF
LABOR IT WILL SOON BE ON THE
SEARCH FOR A NEW SECRETARY OF
LABOR. YOU ARE NEW TO YOUR
POSITION THERE CURRENTLY IS NO
ONE- IN THE POSITION OF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AND SO IT'S IT LEAVES
US ALL IN A- KIND OF AN IN THE
DARKNESS. AS WE TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW DO WE HELP OUR
CONSTITUENTS THOUSANDS IF NOT
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE
STATE SENATOR SUPPORT YET THESE
POSITIONS. ARE VACANT. AND SO
HOW CAN WE OUR JOBS. WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE THE PEOPLE AND
PLACES OR PEOPLE WILL SOON BE.
MOVING ON. TO ACTUALLY FIX THIS
PROBLEM TO THE QUESTION ON MY
COLLEAGUES WERE WERE ASKING
EARLIER ABOUT THE CONTRACT
BETWEEN EDT AND BANK OF
AMERICA. THAT CONTRACT IS SADLY
NOT AVAILABLE ONLINE BUT HOW
AYE BUT WHAT I SAID IN THE PAST
AND WILL CONTINUE TO SAY. THAT
CONTRACT BELONGS TO THE PEOPLE.
IT IS NOT A SECRET DOCUMENT. IT
IS NOT TO BE HIDDEN AWAY IT IS
A PUBLIC DOCUMENT. AND SO I
MOVED CAN WE HAVE A COMMITMENT
FROM YOU TO MAKE THAT DOCUMENT
AVAILABLE ONLINE. R. I'LL GO
BACK AND SEE IF THERE'S ANY
REASON WHY IT CAN'T BE DONE.
WE'LL TO MY OFFICE OBTAINED IT
FROM THE FROM YOUR DEPARTMENT
FROM GDP DIRECTLY. BUT IF NOT
IT IS YES LONG IT IS
COMPLICATED THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT CHANGES TO IT. BUT IF
ONE PERSON FROM THE LEGISLATURE
IS WE WANT TO SEE IF WE WANT TO
KNOW WHAT THOSE DETAILS ARE.
TRANSPARENCY IS THE BEST
APPROACH. AND SO I HOPE THAT
ABSOLUTELY I HOPE THAT
ABSOLUTELY AND TRANSPARENCY
WITH ACCURACY I'M ALL FOR THAT.
GREAT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO A
SENATOR BACKER OF EUROPE AND
THEN MR VOEPEL. I THANK YOU
BERMAN THANK YOU TO. AT OUR
DAILY TO YOURSELF OVER NUMBER
FIFTY OUR- AND I WOULD TRY TO
BE QUICK WITH A COUPLE POINTS
IN A COUPLE OF. SO THE
QUESTION- AREA AND- BUT I'M
SURE PARKING FUTURE PRECIADO
GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE HERE-
QUICK QUESTION AND DIRECTOR
CENTER PRECIADO RESPECT HER
RESPECT YOUR BACKGROUND. TO YOU
SEE ME LEADERSHIP IN THIS
COMPLEX AND CHANGING SITUATION
AND YOU'RE STOPPING HERE TODAY.
ONE CLARIFICATION FROM ORDERS
THE FOLLOW UP THAT WE HAD. AS I
READ IT THERE IS A EIGHT
HUNDRED TEN MILLION A FRAUD.
TIED TO THE- THE INCARCERATION
DATA AND ANOTHER BILLION THAT
LOOKS CERTAINLY LIKE FRAUD BUT
OF THE OTHER TEN POINT FOR THIS
BEEN REPORTED- SHE SAID IT MAY
BE FRIDAY MAY NOT BE FRAUD
METHODS ET DE TO DECIDE WHETHER
WE KNOW. WHETHER THAT WAS
ACTUALLY FRAUDULENT OR NOT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER NANCY OF
VARIOUS WITH EDIE WE HAVE
CONFIRMED THAT THAT IS FRAUD-
WE CONSIDER THAT IDENTITY THAT.
THE CLAIMANTS HAVE NOT
CONFIRMED THEIR IDENTITY. AND
AS MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED
EARLIER YOU KNOW THERE IS A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
PEOPLE HAVE TO CONFIRM THEIR
IDENTITY IF THEY DO NOT- HAVE
ASSUMES THAT THAT THAT THAT IS
FRAUD. OKAY THIS PASSWORD IS
NOT BUT THAT IS THE SECTION AT
THIS POINT THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING. ANYWAY I APPRECIATE
A LOT OF COMMENTS HERE AT- YOUR
PERCENT IN A YEAR TAKING. THE
REINS TO EVADE AGENCY THAT
SOMEHOW MANAGES ME VERY
DIFFICULT YOU KNOW ALLOW
MASSIVE FRAUD ON A MIND
BOGGLING SCALE. AND ALSO DENIED
CAL THE BENEFITS TO. MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS RELY ON THE
LINE. INCLUDING MY CONSTITUENTS
FOR FOOD SHELTER. AND THE AND
SHATTERING MANY LVES- IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WE KNEW THAT
THIRTY FIVE STATES CROSSMATCH.
CLAIMS AGAINST INCARCERATION
DATA. WILL YOU COMMIT TODAY TO
LOOK AT BEST PRACTICES FROM
OTHER STATES NOT JUST ON FRAUD
DETECTION BUT A CALL CENTER
TECHNOLOGY CALL CENTER
TRAINING. AND THE OTHER OTHER
KEY ELEMENTS OF THE SYSTEM.
ABSOLUTELY THAT'S GREAT WE
APPRECIATE IT AND YOU KNOW JUST
WE LIVE IN A WORLD OF TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN ACCESS TO ONLINE TO
MOBILE SERVICES WE SHOP TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN WE SHOULD HAVE AN
EXPECTATION OF PEOPLE CAN
ACCESS THEIR ACCOUNTS EMAILING
QUESTIONS GET RESPONSES MY
FINAL QUESTION FOR YOU IS WHAT
ARE THE THREE BIGGEST CHANGES
THAT YOU BELIEVE HE CAN MAKE TO
GET BACK TO RESIDENTS IN A
TIMELY MANNER AND WITH A
SATISFACTORY ANSWER TO THE
QUESTIONS WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
THE THREE BIGGEST CHANGES. I
WAS CALLING PEOPLE RATHER THAN
THAT CALLING THIS WAS PROVIDING
SELF SERVICE OPTIONS EVERY YOU
BACKGROUND IN TECHNO- YOU. ALL
OF THE REASON THAT WE'RE
GETTING ALL THESE CALLS IS
BECAUSE PEOPLE CANNOT COULD NOT.
TAKE CARE OF THIS ONE OF THE-
YEAH EXACTLY SO EXACT SO THAT
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE X. RAY. THREE TO FOUR
MILLION CALLS. GOING TO WORK IT
CAN'T MAKE A CALL SO THAT. WHAT
YOU HAVE TO YOU HAVE TO LOOK
OTHER OPTIONS THAT PEOPLE CAN
SEE SERVE. SO THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO WAIT ON THE PHONE SO
THEY DON'T HAVE TO- YOUR- IT'S
PARKING CLEAR. IN THE COMING.
MAKING SURE BARBARA WHAT. IS
FELLOW SIMPLE TO OUR NEW. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE- ARE CLEAR.
TO ME OPTION TO. OR IS OF THIS
AS YOUR- BUT YOU'RE STILL. SO
I'M I'M NOT LOOKING FOR. AN
WONDER TURN ARE. INTO STANDARD
FOR THE CALL CENTER. YEAH- THE
FEDERAL OUR- THINK I COULD ASK
YOU HER TO THE COST OF WAR
CALLED PEOPLE NOT WE ARE SO FOR
THE- ONE OF THE OPTIMAL WAYS TO
USE OF THE COLUMN THE TIER ONE
STAFF THERE THAT THEY'RE TRYING
TO FASTEST- BUT THEY CANNOT DO
THE COMPREHENSIVE. FULL SCOPE
OF THE CLAIM WE'RE HAVING TO
MAKE OUTBOUND CALLS TO CLIENTS
REGARDING THEIR ACCOUNT WHEN WE
SEE THAT IT'S THAT IT'S IN A
STOCK OR A STATUS THAT HAS NOT
BEEN PENDING STATUS WITH A NEXT
ACTION. IS ON THE CLAIM WITH
THE CLAIM IT HAS TO TAKE ACTION
TO MOVE BACK WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
MAKING THOSE PHONE CALLS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S NECESSARY IN ORDER TO
GET THE- BIG BENEFITS THAT
THEY'RE SEEKING. M. ALSO DURING
THAT CONVERSATION WERE ABLE TO
EXTRACT IF THEY'RE IF. THEY
WANT TO ABANDON THEIR CLAIM AND
THEN YOU KNOW IT CAN TAKE IT
OFF THE FILE BUT THOSE ARE THE
NEXT ACTIONS UPSET WAS A LOT
FOR YOU NEED TO DO BUT WE-
DOUBT THIS APPROACH TO BENEFIT
CLAIMANTS TO BE MORE PROACTIVE
WITH THEM ONCE THEY DON'T HAVE.
TO CALL INTO WE CAN GIVE THEM
EDUCATION THAT'S MORE WITHOUT
REACHING EDUCATION. FOR THEM
REGARDING THE STATUS OF THE
CALL. OKAY GOT THANK YOU. THANK
CENTER TO REMOVE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOPE JUST LOCAL POLICE.
MISTER CORRECTOR. I WOULD LIKE
TO- SIMPLY SAY. THAT I AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES SAY
PROSTRATIONS MINE. CONSTITUENTS
HAVE SUFFERED THE SAME ON
DISASTER NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A LITTLE BIT FOR A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION. THIS
CRISIS WILL PASS THEY ALWAYS DO.
BUT IN THE FUTURE WILL HAVE.
MORE AND DIFFERENT CRISES
WHETHER IT'S A BIOLOGICAL-
EVENT FOR A RECESSION OR
DEPRESSION. AND YOU WILL HAVE
SURGEONS OF CLAIMS. SO I
SUGGEST YOU MAY WANT TO EXPLORE
A RESOURCE THAT YOU MAY OR MAY
NOT HAVE THOUGHT OF- I SPENT
THIRTY NINE YEARS IN THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY AT A
RELATIVELY HIGH LEVEL OF YOU
MAY WANT TO EXPLORE USING
INSURANCE COMPANIES AS A BACK
UP THE MILITARY HAS RESERVES I
CAN CALL UP DURING EMERGENCIES
OR WAR THEY CAN CALL UP THE
RESERVES. NATIONAL GUARD YOU
MAY WANT TO HAVE A READY
RESERVE. IF THIS TYPE OF EVENT
HAPPENS AGAIN CONCERNS
COMPANIES HAVE. THEY HANDLED
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF CLAIMS
A YEAR ACROSS ALL THE LINES AND
THERE'S A SAYING IN THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY THAT CLAIMS
IS CLAIMS. THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ALL THE
DIFFERENT LINES AS THERE WOULD
BE A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN EDIE
DECLINES BUT THESE INSURANCE
COMPANIES HAVE CUTTING EDGE I.
T. THEY CAN TURN ON A DIME.
MASSIVE CALL CENTERS WITH
HIGHLY TRAINED VERY DEDICATED
PEOPLE. SO YOU MAY WANT TO DO
IN THE FUTURE A PILOT PROGRAM
WITH SONIC AREA. CROSSED THREE
IN HAVE A POTENTIAL RESERVE TO
HELP YOU OUT THE NEXT TIME
SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPENS ON
IN I WOULD IMAGINE THAT THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY WOULD BE
VERY OPEN TO IT NOT JUST TRYING
TO MAKE A BUCK. BUT TO DO A
COMMUNITY SERVICE HELP YOU OUT.
AND IT ALSO HELPS THE HELP THE
ROMAN PLEASE BECAUSE DURING
TIMES LIKE THIS THEY HAVE
LAYOFFS AS WELL SO THAT'S MY
COMMENT- HOPEFULLY YOU MIGHT
WANT TO PURSUE THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUGGESTION. THANK YOU
MR VOEPEL. AND WE ASK THERE'S
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS- LET ME GO AHEAD AND
JUST ASK FOR CLARIFICATION
BECAUSE I KNOW THIS WAS DRESSED
A LITTLE BIT EARLIER. AND THIS
WAS- IN REGARDS TO. THOSE
CLAIMANTS OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
DONE EVERYTHING. I WANT TO SAY
THEY'VE DONE EVERYTHING RIGHT
THEY'VE DONE EVERYTHING ASKED
OF THEM BY EDT. BUT NOW WE'RE
HEARING CONCERNING CASES WHERE
PEOPLE MIGHT BE PENALIZED ARE
ASKED TO GIVE SOME OF THE-
MONEY BACK TO EDT THAT THEY
WERE. THAT THERE I GUESS HE DID
HE WOULD CLAIM THEY WEREN'T
ENTITLED TO COULD YOU EXPLAIN
TO US- THE PLAN IN PLACE TO
DEAL WITH THOSE SITUATIONS
PLEASE. THERE ARE. HI CAROL
WILLIAMS. SO WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A TASK FORCE AND
NOTE THAT WE GET YOU TO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GET TO YET BUT
I DO APPRECIATE BEING ABLE TO
EXPLAIN- THE MAGNITUDE AS YOU
UNDERSTAND THE OF THIS DELAYED
WORK IN THIS TASK FORCE IS
LOOKING AT STREAMLINING TO
DETERMINATION PROCESS WITH
CONSIDERATION FOR EQUITY AND
GOOD CONSCIENCE ALONG
FLEXIBILITY IS PROVIDED UNDER
BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL ALSO LET
ME EXPLAIN THAT JUST ANOTHER
LEVEL THE CONTINUED ASSISTANCE
FOR THE UNEMPLOYMENT UNEMPLOYED
WORKERS AFTER TWENTY TWENTY IT
DOESN'T ALLOW STATES TO WAIVE
OVER PAYMENTS NOT ONLY FOR POOL
BUT FOR THE ELDERLY WOULD LOST
WAGES SYSTEMS PROGRAM. THE
LANGUAGE IN THE ACT ALLOWS-
UNDER TWO CATEGORIES. FOR BOTH
PROGRAMS ONE. IF PAYMENT WAS
MADE FULL OF THE- INTO IF THE
REPAYMENT WOULD BE THEY CALLED
CONTRARY TO EQUITY AND GOOD
CONSCIENCE WHICH IS THE
FINANCIAL ABILITY OF A PERSON
AND MORE ANXIOUS FOR ADDITIONAL
LABOR GUIDELINES AS WELL AS ALL
THE STATE'S ON THE WHOLE EQUITY
AND GOOD CONSCIENCE BUT WE'RE
STANDING AT THE READY TO
UNDERSTAND THESE ADDITIONAL
PROVISIONS THAT WILL HELP US
TO. PROVIDE THESE WAIVERS- NOT
NECESSARILY A BLANKET APPROACH
BUT IF WE COULD WE WOULD- BUT
CERTAINLY AS IT APPLIES TO
CLAIM IT SO THIS IS HOW WE'RE
LOOKING TO UNDERSTAND THE
PROVISIONS AND APPLY IT TO THE
THIS GROUP OF- BASICALLY. THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DELAYED FROM
LAST SPRING HOPE THAT ANSWERS
YOUR QUESTION. NOAH DOES I JUST
WANNA. THE JUST THE FOLLOWING
QUESTION WOULD BE. WHEN YOU
NOTIFY INDIVIDUALS.
ADDITIONALLY WILL THEY BE
INFORMED- THIS WAIVER PROCESS.
IF AN OVERPAYMENT- IS SENT
THESE ARE ALL RIGHT SO IT
ABSOLUTELY WOULD BE INCLUDED-
IN THAT NOTIFICATION WE'RE
HOPING TO MAYBE UNDERSTAND THE
COLD WAR EVEN BEFORE THEN BUT
EVEN GOING TO LET THE TASK
FORCE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
COHORTS BIG. GROUPS OF THEM AND
SEE WHAT WE CAN DO ON TO SCALE
AND TO MINIMIZE THE IMPACT TO
CLAIMS BUT WE DO REACH OUT TO
THE THEM THESE OVERPAYMENTS ARE
ISSUE THEY'LL HAVE ALL THAT
INFORMATION ON AND THEY NEED TO
THEN CIRCLE BACK WITH US AND
SELF CERTIFY YOU KNOW
ELIGIBILITY FOR WAIVER. THAT
MAKES SENSE KEVIN ANYTHING ELSE
BUT GET BETTER. IT'S KERN. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU AND I THINK- AS
YOU WERE DOING YOUR UPDATES
WITH THE LEGISLATORS WITH YOUR-
UPDATED MEETINGS THAT MAYBE YOU
INCLUDED THAT IN THERE BECAUSE
I AM SURE OUR OFFICES WILL BE.
FLOODED WITH CALLS ONCE THAT
STARTS- BECOMING MORE PROMINENT
I JUST HEARD THE DIGITAL. VERY
SIMILAR QUESTION BUT ARE WE
ALSO DOING JUST THE SAME TYPE
OF PROCESS WE CAN EXPECT FOR
THE TAX FORM THE TEN NINETY
NINE G. WHEN THOSE GO OUT TO
INDIVIDUALS AS WELL AS WE HAVE
A PROCESS IN PLACE OF REFUGEES-
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS OF A FALL
INTO THAT CATEGORY. THEY'RE
MISTAKENLY ON THE- MISTAKENLY
RECEIVING- ADDITIONAL FUNDS
THAT THEY NEVER RECEIVED. WE
HAVE THE SAME PROCESS YES. THE
CRIMINAL WE WILL EDUCATE PEOPLE
WHEN WE NOTIFY THEM WHEN THEY
CONTACT US. PLEASE EXPLAIN.
KEVIN I THINK- IT WOULD BEHOOVE
EDT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE TURN
AROUND TIME- ON THOSE WOULD BE
FAIRLY QUICKLY AS PEOPLE SEE A
FORM. HOW WOULD THEY BE TO PAY
THEIR TAXES AND YOU KNOW AS THE
SOONER YOU CAN GET THAT ADDRESS
THE SOONER YOU RELIEVE A LOT OF
ANXIETY FOR CALIFORNIANS. SO
LOOK FORWARD TO ACTUALLY SEE
YOU DO YOU IMPLEMENT THAT OF A
TIMELY FASHION- WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF. ONE OF THE
ONE. I THINK- I THINK WE
SHOULD- AND INVITE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT- LET ME- ALSO THANK-
MISS SIGNS IN HER STAFF FOR-
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS FROM
LEGISLATORS- TO THE BESTOF
YOUR EXPERIENCE AND ABILITY AND
KNOWLEDGE- AND- PLEASE LET US
KNOW AS WE GO FORWARD. HOW HOW
THE LEGISLATURE CAN- CAN HELP
YOU IN ACCOMPLISHING YOUR
MISSION. AND AGAIN THANK THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY- I'M
AN OPEN IT UP NOW TO PUBLIC
COMMENT- ARE WE AWARE OF ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO HAVE
PHONED IN OR- CRISPUS PORSCHE
ARE ON THE PHONE LINE ON THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU HAVE A
QUESTION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU I SHOULD
HAVE MENTIONED THAT THERE IS A
TELEPHONE OPERATOR WHOSE- WHO'S
PLAYING A- TRAFFIC COP- IN THIS
AREA. BUT NOBODY HAS STOOD UP.
DID YOU SAY YOU HAVE TO. I
DIDN'T CATCH THAT I'M SORRY.
NOPE I'M SORRY NO ONE HAS
QUEUED UP FOR A QUESTION ON THE
PHONE OKAY GOOD GOOD GOOD THANK
YOU FOR RESPONDING- ALL RIGHT
WELL- WANT TO THANK A- SHARE
RUDY SALAS- THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT AUDIT
COMMITTEE AND ALL THE
LEGISLATORS WHO PARTICIPATED
TODAY. WE HAD AN OUTSTANDING-
LEVEL OF PARTICIPATION FROM THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY AND-
WANT TO THANK ALL THE STAFF WHO
WERE INVOLVED IN THIS- HEARING
TODAY. AS MR COOLEY POINTED OUT
TO US AND HAS HE HAS-
FREQUENTLY THE OF OUR OVERSIGHT
ROLE. IS CRUCIAL. IN THE CHECKS
AND BALANCES OF STATE
GOVERNMENT AND- MISSILE HIGH
LEVEL OF FRUSTRATION ON ON THE
SUBJECT SUBJECT OF- THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. AND- WE WANNA. I
HOPE THAT- WHAT E HEARD TODAY
IN TERS OF THE COMMITMENT TO
COMPLY WITH THE AUDITORS.
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND THE TIME
SCHEDULE THE TIME FRAME TO DO
SO- WILL BE ACCOMPLISHED AND WE
HEARD THAT COMMITMENT AND- IF
NOTHING ELSE WAS ACCOMPLISHED
TODAY GETTING THAT COMMITMENT
ON THE PUBLIC RECORD IS
VALUABLE. THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH AND AT THIS POINT- WILL
ADJOURN THIS HEARING THANK YOU.